want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
ultimate motivation from david goggins
enjoy
for several years i gave myself a way
out
when you were three hundred dollars now
i was 300 pounds and i was
only up till i was 24 years old i would
climb a mountain i fall back down i
start climbing i fall back down for the
first 24 years of my life
i went to my first tail week my second
hell week and then my third whole week
came
in seal training and the co captain
bowen looked at me
i'm on crutches i'm all jacked up he
says hey this is your last time you're
gonna go through buds
this is it i had several stress
fractures
i had double pneumonia i was jacked up
and he gave me a few months to heal
he said this your last time going
through i shouldn't even let you go back
through
wow i started navy seal training with
stress fractures
stress fractures that's hard to finish
stress fractures
starting the hardest training argument
in the world with stress fractures
and this is when i started to not put a
cap on the
body if the mind is there every morning
i
wake up at 3 30 morning 4 o'clock in the
morning go to my dive cage
go in there before anybody saw me i'd
get duct tape
and i would tape from my forefoot all
the way up to the middle of my calf
and i would put two black socks on and
so
i ran not using the pivot oh my gosh
and i ran my hip flexors so for the
first 45 minutes to an hour
i was in absolute excruciating pain
but what motivated me through that whole
process
was the fact that this kid
came from that i'm in the hardest
training in the world
in the worst shape of my entire life
what if i can graduate amongst these
studs wow
all these guys around me are studs
they're stallions they're gladiators in
my class they're all healthy
most of them they're not broken like
this they may have some
you know everybody's sick going down
training but if i can graduate
it would change everything for me if i
can start the hardest chain in the world
broken and graduate so my mind
fed off of that you are now from the
weakest man you are now the hardest man
to ever
live if you can do this if you can do
this
life is one big mind game yeah and
you're playing it with yourself
is it true i don't care
it got me through the hardest training
starting out
broken when most people quit
i just started wow and when you take
that mindset and you learn to flip that
around
that's what made me powerful and my body
followed
and three months later my stress
fractures
were healed by running on them do you
like suffering or do you just
deal with suffering real answer real
answer yeah
i like to see
real answer i like to get a bunch of men
together okay
men that are the hardest of the heart
and i want to be with these men
and i want to see them suffer
because i'm suffering right along with
you but i want to see me get
through it i want to see what you're
made of
i want to see like almost like the
coliseum
in rome go to the coliseum
and the only way to see who the better
is is to suffer
you can't do it by writing a paper so
let's go
because why what i found out through my
life was i thought of myself as some
weak little
kid and what i found out and the only
message i want to get across to people
is once you change one thing
your mindset you can attack
everything and i find it fascinating i'm
fascinated because i'll be in these
moments
i put these guys on some pedestal yeah
which people do with you they do with me
and they shouldn't
and i was this guy who was a piece of
look at this oh my god how are you guys
it's amazing but once i worked my way up
there
i said my god man we can all compete
let's go so do i like suffering i like
suffering
in the way that is competitive
that brings out the absolute best in me
and everybody else so like i want to see
a man be defeated
i want to see a man get broken and say
i love these men these men i love
but there's very few of them there's
very few of them
and there's very few that are willing to
go there
more than once i get a lot of questions
people asking me for help so i asked
them
will be done to help yourself most of
them say
i've been working hard i'm all about
being your own
hero but i'm not about kissing your ass
in life a lot of us believe that we're
working much harder than we actually are
we think if we got up early for four
days
we've earned something you gotta drop
your entitled mindset
it's dead weight we believe you work
harder than we actually have
trust me most of us have it
the one thing in life you gotta realize
is this
learn to help yourself don't count other
people
to help you also if you wanna have more
self belief and self
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day for 254 days
the research says it can take up to 254
days for you to build a new habit and
this
program will help you get it once again
it's free and the link to join is in the
description below
you will never learn from people if we
always tap dance around the truth
everything i didn't want to do is what
got me to where i'm at today
what if i can become someone that no one
thinks i can be
and just that just me talking about that
i have the hair going up on my arms
my mom didn't know how bad my grades
were she never saw one report card
i hit i hate everything from and she
didn't even ask she was so bogged down
with life
and so i got away with a lot of because
her mind was occupied
so it made me honestly a weaker person
so i scammed life
my mom helped me scam life for a while
but this time i couldn't scam life
i went the second time took the asvab
test failed it again
and a week later she got a letter in the
mail from my high school
and i'm a junior in high school and she
and it later says pretty much your son's
going to flunk out he's missed 25
at school because she was always gone
sonny went to school he's gonna miss
school
and so or he's gonna flunk out so i was
exposed once again my mom goes well
she read the letter to me she put my bed
and her best advice was guess what
you're gonna flunk out of school that
was it in a conversation
so this is when i developed my
accountability mirror and
this is awesome i i look in the mirror
and at this time
i didn't want to be the black kid in
school there's like five or six of us in
school and like
1700 kids like that and
i made up a character
to kind of like draw attention from
color
okay and so what i did was i started to
design haircuts and one haircut i had
was the old man
and i shaved my head up here just like
this you did this
i did this and i would keep the hair on
the side like a old man has
and one time i shaved my whole head and
had a reverse part so i had hair up here
and it kind of zigzagged so i did things
to be this
cool crazy kind of like creative kid
you know like crisscross came out this
time pants sagging but backwards
so my back pockets are here i had two
freshman i was crazy man
but i was a crazy cool kid in school
so i look in the [ __ ] mirror i see
this letter i'm
i'm i'm [ __ ] up and i'm like you know
what man no one is coming to help me
yeah i remember back to what my
principal said i went to the principal
when they wrote that [ __ ] on my car and
in my notebook
and the best advice he can give me god
help his soul was this
they're ignorant they spell [ __ ] niger
god and so that's but honestly i talked
to the guy as i wrote my book
and i have nothing wrong with principal
freeman
he he actually i actually interviewed
him for the book and he was happy to
interview he was good man
what you could tell us some black cuz
you're a white guy in white society we
could
we could tell me you could shut the
school and have a damn
so i started talking to myself this way
in this mirror
what this principle because at that time
like this is the best you can
do principal freeman that was my mind
then but in in this mirror
it wasn't my mom it wasn't principal
freeman it wasn't my dad it was me
because when nobody coming back to help
david goggins that was my mindset now
and so with my non-spelling ass i
started getting these sticky notes
and writing my mom wakes up like what
what is wrong with you i go man
i'm i have to change because i i can't
stay here
i can't i i looked at myself in here and
i was defeated i go
look at myself i'm like who am i so i'm
defeated in this mirror and i'm like
okay i'm changing
on the other side of that extreme place
that i call suffering call whatever you
want
there's a whole other world that people
have not even examined
but you have to go to that extreme place
to examine it
we want to stay here in this comfortable
place once you're going to push yourself
to that extreme place
it's like a whole nother universe it's
almost like like you're an astronaut and
you've examined something like up in
outer space
no it's always been there but you have
to be going through all the muck and all
the
it's examined and you realize why god
through all this crap there's a whole
other
whole universe over here in my mind yeah
yeah hold that universe
when i was in the worst time of my life
in hell week i looked at everybody
and said i'm the most trained person
here yeah well that's the truth i've
gone through more mental torture than
any ewok even fathom yeah
so i'm looking at the baddest people on
the planet i'm looking i'm like this
you guys can't hold a stick so i started
looking at verses like i don't belong
here
versus like i might be the best person
ever come here
wow who could have pulled this off
who could have been given a sewer to
live in in their mind
and say okay at birth i'm gonna put you
in the worst place on the planet earth
and let me see if you can go to the top
of the mountain right
with nothing right but just hard work
grit
and figuring it out and not putting
yourself back in the dungeon every time
something got hard
so that's what became my daily voice was
you really are the baddest person on the
planet
and after a period of time you start to
believe that
right we have two voices in our mind and
boy i know they're [ __ ] true
i've heard them i hear them now and
they're real
there's that one voice that voice i used
to love to
hear that we love to hear it's that soft
that soft voice that says sleep the
[ __ ]
it's okay it's that cuddling voice
you want to be hugged and nurtured and
all that that says it's gonna be okay
well there's another [ __ ] voice
that wakes you up in the middle of the
night
it's not your girlfriend it's not your
boyfriend
it's that demon [ __ ] voice that
whispers in your [ __ ] ear
that says get up [ __ ] you're not
good enough you gotta work harder
you haven't put enough time in it's that
voice you want to run away from
it's that voice you don't want to hear
but guess what
it's that voice you need to listen to
stay hard
listen to the whisper did you cast out
negative people in your life
or just use it as fuel to do even better
and do you still have relationships with
energy sucking vampires
there's no relationship with so energy
people that suck the life out of me
you're gone that's a total tom ferry
like energy sucking vampires avoid those
people right but this is the thing about
though
yeah you can't use it for fuel either
yeah you have to get that
hate you can't move forward with hate
yeah you can't i try to do it yeah i
used to have energy and all that stuff
but what happens is we when you're in a
horrible situation in life
that hate and anger for some reason you
can't remember
because that place you're at is so
disgusting you forget about them
yeah so you might just let go of it
anyway we had this class
that they designed e to l for one by
that time
self-talk visualization arousal control
it's all great it's all great it has to
be a lifestyle
yeah you work on
mental calisine on a daily basis
because you're you know your brain your
mind like your brain is in the muscle so
much
you will lose it you will lose the
ability to suffer in the worst of times
if you come out of it for too long
if you can lift 315 pounds and you stop
going to the gym for a month
i guarantee you won't be able to pick
the same weight up again
you're going to find peace from going to
war with yourself cause we all got
we all got people look at me the reason
why my story resonates with people
because i don't hide i'll tell you
exactly the [ __ ] i am i will admit to it
people are great at hiding so they want
to just find peace no you gotta you
gotta take your [ __ ]
fix whatever's up in you don't just
shove it under a rug fix it and then
you'll find some
peace later it's funny you talk about
that i work with a guy
who's in a business like this for five
years i'm not gonna mention his name
yeah
he called me up five years ago and said
i want you to work with me yeah his job
a big day for them was if you had five
meetings
and 40 calls 40 that was like according
to their big business plan
that was a day yeah he said i want to
make more money
um all this just bug you know it's
bogging me down i said
this is your day five meetings and 40
calls like do you start at 10 and yeah
and and
this company you work for says that this
is a great day this is what we want
i had this guy no [ __ ] one day
he made a thousand cold calls
and had seven meetings yeah so his new
norm
which is now the company like how did
you become he made a hundred thousand
went to making six hundred thousand
dollars in three years
yeah that's that's the jump he had just
because his mindset changed because the
company
put this this label this is what is a
good day
a good day is 40 calls five meetings i
said
that's a day because you're comparing
yourself with mediocre people bingo
bingo do not run with mediocre people
i'm going to tell you how to beat these
mediocre people this
is your new 300 dials in
eight meetings yeah and his whole world
changed
how do we learn from you and the seals
to handle our pain we're in the midst of
pain
what because it hurts and it hurts
physically sometimes
obviously and then some of us are
dealing with emotional pain
what do we do in those moments when
we're feeling the most pain and we're
going i
cannot go one more second
so this is the thing a few years ago the
navy seals
designed a program called um the buds
butts prep program and my last two years
in the military
i did 21 years they sent me down to
great lakes chicago
and we were training these guys to get
ready to go to buds still training
because a lot of guys weren't getting
through we thought this program would
help them get through
so these guys would leave our program
studs
push-ups sit-ups swimming everything but
the numbers were the exact same
so i was scratching my head like how the
work these guys go through two months of
this before they get the buzz and still
quit
yeah and we'll ask you a question in a
second don't go for it
i started going back through my mind and
realizing one thing
we were building bigger stronger faster
quitters
why is that if you don't work on the one
thing the most powerful weapon in the
world
is your mind yeah so the answer your
question is this
whether it be physical pain or mental
pain
we all have to start from zero with pain
and what that means is
if you don't go back we all have
something that bothers us
everybody in this world is insecure
about something that's right
something in life whether it be your
family your mom your dad your brother
your sister your wife your husband
your kids something has messed you up
and whenever you're in physical pain
even though
you might not be thinking about that
mental stuff that happened to you
your mind is thinking about it all these
dungeons that we've created all these
trap doors that our life has created
most of the time we quit is because we
don't have any mental tools
to get us through the other side so
my whole thing for people is you have to
examine
why are you doing it in the first place
what makes people quit so much in still
training in in all
other special ops training is the mind
it's always comfortable to sit there you
watch the navy seal show
discovery channel you're in a 72 degree
house oh yeah
you have your lemonade your milkshake
whatever yeah i can do that oh sure
you're comfortable although i'll say
this i never say that well some people
do yeah
a lot of folks think you know because it
feels very comfortable in that
comfortable environment oh totally
absolutely
the second you get out there in that
environment where
it's 40 degrees like in my third house
we you know we had a guy die
of pulmonary edema died out there my
third hell week
you have to really want what able you
know whatever you're going for yeah
if not all these questions that come up
like you said
how you go one more step further yeah
your mind's gonna ask you
all these questions how can you go one
more step further if you don't have the
answers to that and i can't give them to
you yeah that's right
you have to know why am i here for me
when i was going through seal training
i was willing to die so all these
negative questions that kept on coming
up my head
i had the answer for them it's those
people that don't have the answer
for those negative questions right and
and if you can't answer those questions
you will quit
when you're when you're mine this is
this this whole 40
rule that i talk about all the time that
i made up a long time ago
i started making it up through pain tell
them what that is what you go so
basically the 40
rule is i am a strong believer that we
quit because why
how the 297 pound cockroach guy
right who quit on everything is now
considered one of the best man on the
planet
how is that possible it means i
had to change one thing my mindset so
there's no way in hell that that was it
but that was that guy was in me
when that guy came down here and said
hey guess what man
you're a fat ass but i'm gonna now make
you a badass
i want a miracle to be a badass no
it was in me i had to believe and make
that belief
work and through hard work i did that
so the 40 rule was like we have a like a
car
some cars have a governor on it and when
you gets like 92 miles an hour that car
start doing this because it can't go any
faster those cars that don't have
governors on like
like a fast ass whatever porsche
whatever i'ma [ __ ] bury it dawn
we have that abilities but we have put
this governor
on our minds and you have to
the factory that put the governor on
that car the factory is now you
that put this in your mind you gotta
take that off
until you take it off you're gonna
constantly get to 92 miles an hour and
do this
because you ain't growing faster yeah in
my fact you might even go slower
so basically i started realizing this
through my life through going through
all these times
so i get a lot of emails about how do i
stay motivated
hungry driven well let me tell you
something
most days in life when i wake up i'm not
motivated hungry or driven
i've committed to myself the best person
myself
what most of us are looking for is a
special [ __ ] feeling of
oh i feel great this morning i'm gonna
get out of bed and get a quick five
miles in or go to the gym
if you're looking for that feeling let
me tell you one thing ain't gonna come
you have to learn to do when you don't
want to do it
learn to bring that savage mentality out
of yourself the animalistic [ __ ]
you think a savage gives a [ __ ] about
how he feels or how she feels
then just do it learn to be your best
self when you're least motivated
stop looking for a feeling to control
what goes on in your life
you have an obstacle to overcome so
overcome
i'm a big guy in visualizing i'm a big
guy in making a world
it may not exist to me it does
to me it does and
i'm overpowering myself every day and
you gotta find
tools to do that that's the tool that i
use
anybody that can accomplish anything
that is hard
the only separator is is that they
really want
to be there there's some people that get
inspired
and that inspiration moves them to try
to do something but the inspiration
is very high right now in this nice
environment we're in a nice environment
the ocean's out there i'm talking to you
if i want to go to the
refrigerator and get something to drink
eat i can
i watch a movie about some bad asses
you're inspired
but the second you're not in this
environment
and you're actually doing what inspired
you
that suck factor is not real you can't
just get off your
couch and get a shake or get a box of
donuts or turn the tv or go take it
or go go get your girlfriend and cuddle
up nah
you're now there and only those people
who have been there a million times in
their minds
and have lived in that water and have
suffered
a million times and realized my legs may
break
my knee may break my bones will hurt
i will be the coldest i've been in my
life i will be miserable
and accept that because what happens is
we when you get in a horrible situation
in life your mind i call it my one
second decision
when you get a horrible situation in
life your mind immediately says get the
out of here everybody does even if you
want to be there
but it starts to have all these
different questions
in your mind in that one second it says
okay why are you here why are you doing
this why this why that
and then you start to say yourself if
you don't want to be there that bad
i have a beautiful wife at home man why
the [ __ ] doing this man
like this is stupid this is gonna get
these guys injured
like they're gonna pay for this for the
rest of their lives i'm not gonna break
my body up to do this
your mind starts to say yeah this is
stupid
but if you have if you are already
knowing that this is gonna happen to you
you have all the answers to these
questions that your mind starts to give
you when you're in suffer mode
let's say for shits and giggles i'm
training for 100 mile race yeah let's
say a 200 just for shits and giggles i'm
training for 100 mile race right okay
good
so let's say i'm training for 100 mile
race and i get to mile 50
yeah and i feel like and
like everybody else my mind gets soft
why because i'm human i'm not some damn
you know
hybrid creature that was formed from the
heavens above no
not human i suffer i don't like it i'm
uncomfortable i don't like it
so my mind starts to get weak and we
start to forget
about how badass we are i call that the
cookie jar but it's not about the cookie
jar right now
this is about self-talk yeah but but the
cookie jar kind of
goes to self-talk too it's a piece of it
so basically what i do here
is you have to make sure that your mind
doesn't become [ __ ]
when it's suffering whether it's in pain
all it wants to do is find the easy way
out which is usually quit
if you quit the pain goes away
immediately yeah you got to give
yourself
enough energy and fuel in your mind to
stay just a little bit longer
so you can talk yourself into staying
for the whole thing
this how it works most of us never start
anything
cold if you're going to go to college
you got to steady your ass off if you
want to run a 100-mile race a marathon
if you want to go be mr olympia if you
want to go
be a scientist a doctor you're one of
the best salespeople on the planet
you've got to work
you've got to work but this is you got
to build you got to build that but what
happens is
in that moment when we need self-talk
when we're failing
and we're in our worst spot possible we
forget
the back end yeah my fault the front end
the all the build up to where we're at
today we forget
how much work we put in so for me i'm at
my office
one more time so i'm in the middle of it
right i'm making my calls i hate it
you're at mile 50.
i hate it your mind's getting you know
wiggly on you i just want to get out of
here yeah
we forget that we put years years maybe
not
into making these dials but to getting
where you're at today to become this
person become this person to be in a
position to make this money where the
[ __ ] you want to make whatever you want
to do in your life yeah
we forget that we forget that journey
on what it took for us to get in this
moment to make the right decision
yeah so that's my self-talk is this okay
i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here man
i'm done
then i remember this you ran
2 000 miles training
to be in this moment right now we forget
that
yep we forget the three o'clock in the
morning runs
or getting up early for work or whatever
you're doing we forget all that
in that moment of suffering i remind
myself yeah
i only have 50 more miles i put in six
months of training you did sixty seven
thousand sixty seven thousand pools
that's 130 right exactly this is no big
deal we forget all of that
yeah so what i do my self-talk is
basically
going back down memory lane yeah of all
those
days i ran the rain or i had to
study real late at night and i didn't
want to do it but i did it to get
here yeah that's the hook that is the
hook it's the hook
i want it to get here yeah now you're
here and now you want to
quit yeah so you got to be mindful but
this thing about it
if you haven't put in any hard work to
reflect on
you yeah so there is no self because you
got nothing to pull back it's just a lie
nothing to say hey you've done this
before that's right or you've done
something like this before
all this all this like people want to be
all positive
all this positive talk it doesn't work
if it's a lot like
if you didn't study for your big exam
and you go into it saying i'm gonna pass
it yep
no you're not yeah you're gonna fail it
yeah that self-talk is not gonna work
self-talk without real work is just a
lie
yeah so my self-talk is me reminiscing
back
on the struggle to get to this moment
and that tells me we're not quitting
today
yeah not today for instance in hell week
yeah they said when you get to wednesday
of hell week you're broken so everybody
on wednesday but give them contacts
yourself okay 72 hours a day i'm talking
about 130 hours of training yeah
it starts on sunday ends on friday and
on wednesday
you're almost done halfway through yeah
so everybody on wednesday
they hear this because everybody says
wednesday's like man you're so tired
you're done
so that becomes your new norm yeah no
you're cruising into wednesday getting
ready to feel tired when you don't even
know why
because someone told you you could feel
tired so for me i was like hang on a
second i started studying my mind a
whole bunch while growing up
facing these things don't listen to
anybody's
dialogue but your own they're tired
they're not you
yeah so it's just all about this is your
mind has a tactical advantage over you
at all times
it knows your weaknesses it knows your
strengths and it will guide you into
your nice
comfort zone yeah we have to reprogram
our mind to get it
like a different vantage point so that
you know how to be in charge of yourself
versus your mind being in charge of you
no matter how far you get in life
you have to be able to go back to
scratching your mind
at a moment's notice you can never get
so far
beyond scratch what that means is
when you accomplish something in life if
you want to go back to scratch
and go back to that seven dollar a month
place where i once lived
and visit that place for a long period
of time if you were
here when you went back to scratch you
would now be here
scratch is what makes you better scratch
friction obstacles create growth
there's no friction when you're this far
up in the game anymore
you think there is that's right when you
cheat so much the friction is
is is minor because why
i'm sore i'm gonna get a massage today
i'm hungry i'm gonna eat today the
refrigerator is always full
so your comforts are now so your
discomfort is now
very miniscule to your discomfort back
here in the seven dollar month place
so you have to go back to the total
discomfort
to then raise your level of where you're
at now
i'm not saying stay there and stay there
visit
visit it and then you raise your level
take a day trip
that's right yeah always take day trips
yeah don't stay there that's right
but take a date i start there first yep
so i worked with a few pictures i won't
name their names big name pictures
and i studied them for a long time i
want to be better man i want to be
better and be better
so i i got film on i studied him i
studied about okay what is wrong
that's it yeah i saw it
whenever something bad would happen on
the mound
that's the first thing they would do
totally the head drops
shoulders roll forward they look down
that sends a direct message to your
brain that i failed
i am a failure that starts the
downward spiral to being a failure
on that mound you can't even recover
yeah it's that
so i started teaching this it's that
person who you throw a bad pitch
you get the ball back your chin is not
high
because it shows that you're way too
proud your chin stays here
your shoulders stay nice and level your
feet
firmly on the ground your hands planted
like i'm ready to beat somebody's ass
and i'm ready for battle it tells your
mind
wow maybe we didn't [ __ ] up that bad
we're still in the fight
so that's the one thing i always do is
like even if i [ __ ] up
yeah keep your body positioned like
you're still a warrior
like you're still fighting if you get a
hundred bad calls in a row
yep
hello i'm david goggins how you doing
today yep
okay wrong one don't start getting poopy
pants and get upset with yourself no
it's a mentality and your body language
has a direct
thing to your brain and how it functions
what's your daily
meditation or mantra or repetition to
yourself
every day i tell myself i used to
believe i was the weakest man that god
ever created
so now i believe that i'm the hardest
human being that god ever made
i don't care if it's true or not it's
the most important conversation to me
it's the thing that drives me every day
it it it's the one thing that keeps me
going every day is that
you must constantly be that man that you
want to be so before i start this
journey be navy seal
i go back to see my dad because i
realize now i gotta fix some [ __ ]
i'm blaming everything i gotta go back
you know how a lot of times you're like
if you're a runner you're you're your
your right knee may hurt
but it's not your right knee that hurts
it's really left hip yes but we're
constantly on the right knee
i'm concentrating on all my but i need
to go back to the root of the problem
which is my dad i gotta face the demon
i gotta go back and see what made him so
to make me so
why am i mm-hmm so i go back and i
and i go back in as a as an older man
now i'm in my 20s
i'm not a kid anymore and i want to see
this man and face him as a
as a as a grown man but still as a kid
in my head
i was still a kid but i was a grown man
as my age
i went back and i realized he was the
same man that he was still the same
still the same and i talked to him he
was still nuts
and um but i i i go back and face that
one more time
but to face it in a different way how'd
you do it differently
i looked at him in a way we never said
sorry to one another
and he went off about my mom and my
grandparents and all kind of
i looked at them in a way that i
realized now
why you put this up i had to
almost be him to realize it's okay
brother
it's okay because i realized that
somewhere in your life
something brought you up and you didn't
deal with it
and so you put that [ __ ] on me my mom
and everybody around you
i'm gonna deal with my wow so even
though you gave me all this
you you gave me a satchel that i didn't
deserve and now i'm off
people think i'm a liar you gave me this
you created this nightmare of goggins
i'm gonna fix it though i saw these navy
seals before i became one my god they're
better than me
yeah they bear me i gave up a hundred
sets
and i had to work up to realize these
are human beings yeah
with the same that i have yeah this some
people run faster swim better
but mentality's mentality yeah there's
no i
you're not gonna outwork me so i'm gonna
catch up somewhere yep so that being
said
i used all that 300 pound man that fat
guy
that dumb guy people say why you say
dumb you have to be real
with your self you got to be wrong if
you're not smart you're
dumb but you can become smart you can
become smart it's not a permanent tag
you're dumb forever yeah you're fat
forever no be raw
don't find the cushy word so who i was i
was this nobody guy
and i created this goggins and that
goggins
there's david goggins and there's
goggins david goggins is a
calm cool guy that sits back used to be
a you know weak kid now he's just a
normal guy
goggins is a guy that is willing to tape
up his legs to go after it
um in that book you read about david
goggins and also goggins
what i realized in my life is that
goggins is who i love
goggins is who i created my dad
created david goggins i created goggins
so what's happening with me and
since can't hurt me came out and since i
got on social media which is why i
don't like social media which i'm not on
there very much which i give people
one time i have to do me
i have to do me so people get it twisted
man
i am who i am yeah what's in that book
is me yeah so now what they see
is this guy who's trying to get people
to get off their [ __ ] ass
that just happened to happen man i
didn't
set out when i set out to be a conceal
and set out to go to ranger school and
all the stories i did and break records
i didn't set out to [ __ ] please right
i didn't set out to say hey pay me now i
got a great
story and i realized now that my life
has kind of gotten to a point where
people know me
i have followers and whatnot the biggest
depression of my life
is you get caught up into helping so
many people out
and it's great and i love that but you
lose yourself in all of that
truth it literally and people go man but
but my god like you're you're changing
i get all that [ __ ] man but what the
is motivating you in that book
what's motivating you is the stories i'm
telling you about what i
did in my life once i stop living that
i'm no more yes i
am not the that you are now being
motivated from
so right now in the mirror i now got
back to goggins
i'm now back to running 100 miles a week
i'm now back to getting
i saw and i talked to my girl about all
the time
you you you travel you speak you you
know you you all this
it's all great and dandy for some for
most people
i'm goggins what makes me me is the
dungeon
and yeah and people well oh my god
they're gonna hear this my god dude
you don't have any peace in your life
don't get it twisted weak people
who hear me get all poopy pants about
how i talk
so be it what changed me
was i had to be hard on myself
and i have to continue to grind
myself into a fine dust yeah
period that's where i feel good i think
i accomplished something
if things come easy it's not fun i must
fail at something repeatedly it has to
haunt me
and then once i complete it i feel like
i accomplished something
i don't want to set out and say oh
there's an a
we're good right stupid no i want to
turn it in a million times and say you
fail
you failed and i said okay roger that
and sit there
and analyze what i'm doing wrong go
to these places that people don't go to
anymore because all this
social media everything's computerized
i want to go to that dark place my mind
says okay how are we going to get this
done we live in a world that's so busy
and so active and moving so fast
right now i am sitting with tom ferry
my mind is sitting with tom ferry
is not talking to tom ferry about
thinking about my god i can order some
more books i'm sort out out of here i'm
doing this i'm doing that
that's the first thing about
visualization yeah you must make sure to
silence out
all the of life which is very hard to do
and it is very hard because
your your visual picture must be
clear it has to be clear it can't be
like
kind of in and out like a like a fuzzy
tv you got to see it
it has to become real you got to take a
snapshot of it a million times
put in the bank that snapshot of me
was getting that 4021 pull-up yeah
knocked out because the record was 4020.
yeah
i visualized that over and over and over
again
i visualized what i was going to say
because a guy's name was steven highland
i was thinking like
what you're going to say to me to him on
video i finally got his ass yep
so i visualized success
but then i went through that's the
that's the fun part
yeah i have to do 4020 pull-ups to get
to that 4021 pull-up
i know now because it took me three
chances to get it
all those failures they were great for
me
to examine where i was [ __ ] up at
along the way
so i take all that and i and i put in
the bank as far as visualization okay
when i get to 2500 pull ups my hands
start to rip
okay get ready for that so i started
visualizing how am i gonna handle the
pain
mm-hmm okay then you start visualizing
okay my
my nutrition was off you start
visualizing all these things because
you have to mimic it a million times but
i can't mimic 4020 pull-ups
by doing it but you can see all the
milestones where you fail
right and see yourself going beyond it
that's right yeah so that
that was my big thing about i either
walk in
get the chalk see i had to see
everything over
and over and over again and when i
realized i had to keep that visual
that picture in my head for 17 hours it
took me 17 hours to break that record
so for 17 hours while i used to be loud
everywhere i went
i put these headphones in yeah i never
listen to music
by listening to one song going the
distance
you know for 17 hours it's 2 minutes and
13 seconds yeah
for 17 hours i had that in that's a lot
of rocky a lot of rocky
and i just went here yeah for and so i
was able to visualize
every rep yep so i visualized my hand
placement
making sure that felt right before i got
going i didn't ignore
all the little pains my hands got sweaty
okay that means
i was aware of everything that means my
okay my hands about to rip
it's getting sweaty wipe it off be aware
everything i was totally in the moment
because of how i visualized
everything i have a good living now for
me where i'm at in my life
i was out on a fire in colorado and we
were digging fire line
on this like 50 like it was like on the
side of a daggone
mountain yeah and we're trying to keep
the fire from moving and we're digging
this fire line
14 inches or my fault 18 inches wide
three miles long 12 of us digging
and it is the hardest work you make
twelve dollars an hour wow okay
nothing you set up your shop like
when you're done digging you pretty much
lay down you go to sleep and you get up
you dig some more
really happens for two weeks longer what
are you digging it's like a whole
line so you're trying to get down to a
mineral source so you're trying to get
down to the to the earth
so so that if that fire is moving it
can't burn dirt
really so you're moving fuels got it
you're you know so so not only are you
digging
you're cutting down trees it's hard work
but the moral story is i'm 43
don't need to do it at all this is why i
do i'm making money i'm making my own
i i i have a good life i don't need to
do it
everybody ask me why i do it this is why
this 21 year old kid was out there
and he wanted a pair of running shoes
that's all you want with pair of runners
shoes 60 70 100 bucks or whatever you
know
easy for us yeah shoes
he looked up at the mountain that we had
been on for days digging this fire line
and he said that'd take me five or six
hours of work to buy those shoes
something like a buyer it's the
perspective of life that perspective of
life right there
of that is the value that we lose
when things start to come so easy in
life
it's the perspective that 21 year old
have we looked about that mountain and
thought
he looked at his hands he looked at the
at the amount of hours
of pulling that pulaski that that tool
and raking that ground
and then cutting those trees and moving
them and
that hours of work he looked at his feet
and said these old shoes would do
it's that perspective in life that we
lose
and that's that story to most people may
not mean anything
it's that story i always want to have in
my life
you cannot lose perspective of
where you've come in life i mean a
thousand dollars a month 300 pounds
just i can't do any of this stuff yeah
these people are better than me
yeah so the first thing is that's the
first big problem right there
first big problem is that you have put a
lot of people above you
yeah put no one above you yeah no one
whatever but
if if if you believe in something say
that again say that again because that's
you know but you know but the man the
people that make more money the people
that are better looking the ones that
are on social media and they're so good
at this
i put god above me besides that there's
no one better than me got it
you have to become an equal so this i
look at it
if you're playing and i talked about it
at your conference if you're playing
roger federer yeah
okay be before you
get on the court with roger federer he's
the best of all time
yeah but you're also a professional
tennis player man
yeah you're forgetting your own resume
yep
so once you get on the court let's say
it's a grand slam
it's five sets hopefully if you can go
the distance with this guy
yeah but before you even bounce the ball
to serve it
you're down two sets because while you
look across and you're playing
roger federer yeah but guess what you
get a good shot on roger federer
in the third set and you realize i can
play with this
but it's too late yeah you gave up two
sets before you go on the court
you gotta stop giving up two incest
before the game begins
my dad really helped create this i'm not
giving him credit
yeah like oh he was a great dad like
clapped my hands for his ass
he helped create this because he was
just that he was a
a devil you know he was a guy that had
to be
very insecure very beat down something
had happened to him when he was younger
because the the way he treated me my
brother my mom was just horrible
so he would beat us my mom my brother my
me and i'm not talking
like oh you got in trouble something to
give you a weapon
he would he was drunk okay so whenever
he woke up man he woke up drinking
went to bed drinking and that's how it
was and when he get drunk
he just got violent so my mom caught my
dad cheating
we got home about four o'clock in the
morning so i'm about
seven eight years old and i hear some
ruckus outside my room as i'm getting
ready to bed down for the night
and my mom and dad are outside my room
because there's a staircase right there
and my dad is smacking the hell out of
my mom
and knocks her almost unconscious where
she's kind of out of it you know she's
kind of loopy
she falls down he grabs him by her hair
and drives you downstairs by her hair
and so at this age i'm starting thinking
man you know what the
dude man like you know i'm scared but
then something in me saying
you gotta go and do something oh my god
but i'm scared of death of this guy
he's been beating me since i can
remember and i mean like
laying me out for nothing and i'm still
thinking man okay man like
what am i gonna do so my brother he and
i were very different
when my brother would see the fighting
he would go to this room and hide all
right
yeah i didn't do that i always stuck
around so this time i stuck around i
decided to help her out
so i go on the stairs and i jump on his
back
and literally he tells my mom you're
raising a gangster
and she's like on the floor and he's
almost smiling almost like proud
but that smile went to a frown pretty
quick and he beat
the living hell out of me and he beat me
literally from my neck
down to my ankles like black and blue so
the next morning
um i was gonna go to school half today
my mom woke up
and she pulled the covers back and what
she saw
was how bruised i was and
so when she pulled the covers back and
saw a bruise that was i'll never forget
looking at her face
because she used to write letters for me
you know for me my brother
to miss p.e because we were so bruised
up from getting beaten
so you know he's sick or whatever and so
you know she was lying a lot from my dad
so this particular day she didn't write
a letter
but when i laid in the bed and looked at
my mom and she pulled the covers back
i never forget looking at her face and
her face
is tattooing my brain and while i say
that
um this past year i got the vfw award
for
americanism award and if you google
david goggins vfw award
i'm in front of 5 000 veterans and i'm
getting this amazing award
john mccain got it and i'm up here
thinking man i'm not freaking this award
this is amazing
it's for giving back and also having a
great military career
and i could give this six minute long
speech and i'm up there man i'm talking
and i'm thinking i'm thinking people who
help me out i get to my mom
she's sitting back you know she's
sitting right here on stage behind me
and i haven't cried in 30 years i can't
even picture
it haven't cried in 30 i don't do that
and i turn around and say and i
want to thank my mom for um not picking
me up
when i was knocked down but teaching me
how to get up because she never picked
me up ever
and because her circumstances sucked
yeah so anyway i looked back and i said
that
and i got done i didn't even get a
chance to say it
i looked at her eyes and my head went
right back
to her face when she saw me bruised up
and that me up in for 58
seconds look at the video and you'll see
me
my head's down and i'm sobbing wow and
i'm in front of 5 000 vets
and the guy who was who was hosting the
thing had to come up to me
and like put his hand on my back and i
was just destroyed
overcome with emotion and then 58
seconds go by and i get up and i deliver
this speech
and so i tell you that because life
my life tattooed me whenever times got
hard my mind said
you're not good enough right let's go
right so
my mind wasn't my eyes my mind weren't
connecting
right so how do you combat that so how
you can bat that is this
i call it the cookie jar okay
you have to remind yourself we all have
a story
we've all all of us have gone through
very hard times
but we're when we're in a hard time our
mind has a way of forgetting
what all we've overcome i have a way
of taking one second when i want to quit
and say okay you endured this
so i look at my life and how i came up
as the ultimate training ground
versus most people look at it as why
what was me god why
exactly why right i had to flip this
upside down and say hang on a second
god was training me to be one of the
baddest men on the planet
absolutely right that's how he this was
this was my journey
when i was younger life in society
made this big world with all these
endless possibilities
endless possibilities my life made my
possibilities
this big yeah because it made me afraid
of all these different things
yeah so all this stuff trapped my mind
it shackled my brain it made me a
prisoner within my own self saying
this is all i can do because why i'm
afraid of this
i'm insecure over here i got stuff down
over here
back behind me good lord who knows who's
behind me i might look behind me so your
life is this big
versus it being like i can do all this
out here if i start to break down these
ball you know these
these different walls and barriers and
that's what i started realizing
i could become a navy seal i could
become this but
i was afraid of the water think about
this i know
why are you going to go be a navy seal
when all you do is play in the water
yeah for and we don't play we are in it
and we're living in it you're tying
ocean you're swimming for me
the ocean is unforgiving yeah so my mind
is i'm gonna go be a navy seal
yeah if i didn't face that fear
no one would ever know me i was number
three behind michelle obama for a long
time until my book sold out yeah
and i was a guy just 21 years ago
who was 300 pounds can barely read and
write
and now the book just two spots behind
michelle obama yeah
hopefully hopefully we get it above
today right just because i was afraid
yeah
but you overcome those fears guess what
happens the whole world
you unlock this door and everything
opens back up again
in the race of life life's not going to
give you
a glass of water when you're thirsty
and i realize that and once again people
at my god your life is horrible
it's not yeah this is how i live
it's how i live this is what i want i
don't judge anybody
this is how i live and there
if there's not people like me in this
world
with this kind of mentality it's not be
like david goggins
go around 200 miles take something from
this
take something from this remember where
i started from
you don't need to go where i went right
i went this far
i started opening different doors to the
cellar in my brain
my god is this possible oh my god that's
possible this is possible
i start to open up different
compartments you can leave them shut
i don't care i'm looking at all these
different races and one comes up number
one the hardest race in the world
bad water 135. 135 mile race through
death valley
i'm like that sounds nuts but i did
but it didn't describe that it was a
like a couple day race
i'm thinking okay that has to be like a
seven day race
because i don't know people run like
that so i end up calling chris cosman up
chris carson is the race director of bad
water
and he lives out here in california he's
like hey man
i'm like hey chris i call him up in the
first conversation i actually have all
the emails
in my book yeah for me him going back
he's he's a stickler man
i'll tell you that so i called him up
and said hey man i'm gonna do this race
it's like have you ever run 100 miles
before
i'm like no he goes well to get my race
you have to do 100 mile race
and you got to do 100 miles in 24 hours
or less there was only two more races i
could do
before the deadline dropped and so i'm
like
he goes you live in san diego right i'm
like yeah this was wednesday
i called him up on a wednesday morning
he goes well there's a race on saturday
and it's a it's called a san diego one
day
at um hospitality point in san diego
where you run around a one mile
track for 24 hours so many miles you can
get
something like this guys kind of call me
out i'm gonna get
done i'm a seal i'm a badass been
through ranger school and
i got this hardest thing i did my entire
life dude was this one race
so i go harder than
than getting through hell yeah i was not
prepared okay
at all so i go i sign up for the race
i show up i'm this big bodybuilder
looking guy
shirt off black hat arm you know and i'm
i set out so every mile i'm going to see
this blue lawn chair
i had rich crackers and mild plex that
was my nutrition man no water no not
just
no water no no plex dude come on
you know i never drink water on runs and
i didn't know about all this
so i go out there and i'm running i get
through 50 miles i'm gonna cut to the
chase because i detail it
really well in the book um i get going
i sit down at mile 70. um
and buddy i hadn't sat down
yet and i sit down and everything falls
apart
literally man i'm like peeing blood down
my leg
i have some crap coming out of me and i
got 30
miles to go and i'm in the worst shape
in my entire life
and so i won't get too deep into it man
but i end up
going back through my cookie jar and i
talk about you know my
my cookie jar is basically something i
invented about we forget how badass we
are
when we're suffering because our mind
just stays right there and suffering the
cookie jar is a reminder
you know how your mom used to have the
cookie jar you want you know you don't
know what kind of cookie you're gonna
get
but it may be uh oatmeal raisin maybe
chocolate chip meat because you know
she's dumps him in that [ __ ]
he's grab one and go
so my cookie jars the things i've
accomplished failed at didn't fail that
just just kept on grinding through
so i take this one second i calm down so
i realized okay man
i gotta be able to just stand up first
come all dizzy and lightheaded now go
through this process
and i said i might quit but not yet i go
this is the worst shape of my life so i
said i might quit
because when you're not going to quit
something you have 30 miles to go your
mind's spasm
like i'm like i like 30 miles a long way
to go
just fresh i've already gone 70 i'm the
worst in my life
i'm like okay so i i'm giving my mind
some space
because if you don't give it space it's
just going to freak out something you
know what i'm going to quit but let me
just sit here for a second and
drink some water now now i'm drinking
water i i have my crew
going over to get some you know
nutrition some food for me i'm getting
better
so now i stand up like wow i'm able to
stand up now
because i wasn't able to i was all
light-headed yeah i'm going on this
track
and i get to my 81 and i wasn't going to
make the time because i was moving slow
you're behind time
way behind okay and this is the this is
the craziest thing in the world
and i think you not
i'm in the worst shape my entire life
ever i've never even been close to this
again never my 81
i'm not gonna make the time as slow as i
was moving
and when your body and mind
connect and i think this is the only
time i've ever done this okay
you become a cyborg
i end up running 20 miles
at about a 10-15 mile and get done with
that race i did 101 miles and 19 hours
and six minutes
and to this day and i don't and i don't
detail it well with you
but in the book i do i learned
more from that 19 hours and six minutes
than i did in all three hell weeks
ranger school and
this is months ranger school was 60
something days
hell week and and all the buzz is six
months i was in
i was in buzz for like 18 months you
know i went through delta four selection
twice
you know pull up records i learned more
in that one race that i wasn't prepared
for
that 19 hours brought me from
utter misery happiness failure
success depression i went through every
emotion
in the world in 19 hours most people who
are failing
are trying to [ __ ] ass off yep most
people who are feeling are being
criticized by people who haven't
attempted
what you're even trying to fail at so
what i'm failing at so after
i did 2500 pull-ups my first time going
for the record yep
you mean people were criticizing me
people sitting there eating chips on the
couch
do a pull-up exactly look at your
audience who's criticizing you first of
all yeah they're not even in your
world yes you don't even talk to me yeah
block them out that's the first thing
yep the second thing is through failure
you get all the
answers you get all the lessons all of
them yes they're all there
yes so i was able to go back through and
say okay this happened this happened
this was wrong this is wrong this is
wrong
so i don't even look at failure like i
didn't call it failure yeah
i i don't because i don't look at my god
i failed no i look at okay
like trying to invict [ __ ] light bulb
i'm afraid you know
what what's failure i'm trying to invent
a light bulb yeah
i'm trying to break 4020 pull-ups
that's failure yeah anything you do
along that way is
amazing so on this journey in life
there's a lot of people who are
right now on the journeys you always be
that in the sewer you came from
that's grabbing at your ankle as you're
leaving that sewer
that's going to drag you right back down
because you
figured it out they're not willing to
figure it out there's not much to figure
out
the only thing to figure out is this
gosh and everybody has a different
equation
my equation is different than yours my
equation was very different than most
people
i have to live what i say
so when you come from a world of used to
lie a lot
and my big thing is facing all this crap
i cannot tell you something i have not
done right because why
when you start to formulate this
character
this code of ethic this ethos that you
live
not anybody else this your own i cannot
tell you something that i haven't done
why because it will
haunt me you are now drinking the
kool-aid a lot of people write books on
self-help mental toughness all this crap
half of them are living up to that
standard
half of them are living up that standard
you
have to be able to practice what you
preach it has to be what you are
that's why people say my god when you
speak on stuff it's so passionate
because you're making me relive my life
it's not a comfortable life this life
was made
this life was earned yeah and if people
like it great if not so be it
real how much time you waste during the
day and most of it is on these
computers phones you know instagram and
back and forth whatever the heck you
call
nowadays tweeting and texting we waste
so much time
on our little gadgets it's unreal
and we talk about we have no time if you
really take you have to take your day
and write write down this one day
everything you do write that down and
you're like my god i am wasting so much
time
on frivolous not even funny i mean it
will it will if it doesn't
infuriate you it should because there's
so much time
i can't get it in look at your schedule
you just wasted seven hours now
i mean you don't have an hour a day to
try to get something in for yourself
i guarantee everybody can find an hour
most of us live our entire lives
avoiding failure it's funny
i walk around people come to me they say
man
you're that navy seal you went through
ranger school
you were you know air force tac p you
know you uh
did the pull-up record you run all these
ultra races all this [ __ ] man
the funny thing about it that i think
about is this
they know that part of me this is the
part i don't know about myself
i thought the asvab tested in the
military three times
in the air force thrown at pear rescue
in the seals it took me three times to
get through navy seal training
the pull-up record took me three times
this is what i know about me
so what i'm saying is this you can't
live your life
being afraid to fail all those failures
made me the success in the day stay hard
not giving civilized is about having a
savage mentality
civilized is something where people um
it's a it's a comfortable world
a lot of us say you know like for
instance i see these athletes right now
who retire
you know i'm 38 you know i'm 39 i did 20
years
at the top of my game and i'm chilling
out now you see them a year later
and how they look what the hell just
happened to you dude
what the hell you're one of the greatest
athletes of all time
kids looked up to you women men of all
ages looked up to you
and they hit the pinnacle where it's
time to retire and their mind says
i'm civilized the worst thing that could
ever happen to any human being
is they become civilized it's that total
accountability
like even when you retire there's a
looking at me and judging me right now
man
i'm i was the baddest person to ever
live
it doesn't go away man you got to wake
up even though you retired
you're never retired you're setting the
example
every single day of your life
and being civilized feels so good i'm
sorry man
once you get to the top you may retire
but you ain't never coming back home man
because now you're judged
people see you falling off you want to
be that guy who knows i may be retired
from the sport or forever i did but i'd
be
damned if you ever see me looking like
feeling like not arriving people i've
arrived
i've arrived mentality you're always
setting the example
civilization feels so good these
comfortable feelings are what people
want they want retirement
they want that they need that they it's
a it's a yearning feeling
i want it too people love putting a
label on me about
my god man you're just wired different
not wired different dude i'm thinking
right now after i got past my stuttering
thing now i'm on a roll i'm good now
you know what i'm thinking about right
now i gotta wake up tomorrow
and do the same again i gotta leave this
interview and go stretch out for two and
a half hours
i hate that but guess what it does
though
i'm constantly callousing over my
victim's mentality
that i once had growing up every day
you have to do this because why when you
stop doing it you don't just maintain it
if you stop shooting a gun you're not
going to be a great shot if you pick a
gun up a year from now
the only way to keep from getting rusty
is to constantly oh that
machine the machine is this you got to
keep challenging it every day
and i always talk about it i talk about
i'm always paying rent
in that seven dollar a month place where
i grew up in that nasty little place i
grew up in
i remember it i remember like it was
yesterday and i'm glad i do
i never want to forget the dungeon of
where i come from
even though it's real spooky and it's
scary and there's no lights on in there
and there's cobwebs and some creepy
mothers in there some demons
all those mothers in there made me
goggins made me who i am today that's
where the strength came from
you got to go back to the beginning to
to the fundamentals of life
to the very fundamentals of where it all
like playing basketball
you gotta go back to the fundamentals
you just you know you can't always just
stay
up here you got to go back to scratch
i learned to visualize in my life
by watching rocky and mainly rocky one
i'll have them all
but like the rocky three running on the
beach seeing all that but rocky won
14th round at least a thousand times
what about you
no at least 20 000
why is that yes um i've
dissected that two minutes and some
seconds two minutes and 13 14 15 seconds
at least 20 000 times when i did the
pull-up record
and i finally broke it took you three
times yep did 4 000 30 in 17 hours
i listened to one song
for 17 hours and it was going the
distance
oh my god 2 minutes and 13 something for
14 seconds
on a loop on a loop but first the guys
guy named nandor
he kept playing out loud for everybody
and i brought my own little ipad i don't
ever listen to music
but i was failing so many times at this
record i had to go to that place
so i said you know i don't want to bore
you all anymore with this same song
because i had
i had a crew of people there filming it
you know because they had to be
documented
so i didn't want them to be there for 17
hours listening to the same song
kind of it born so i put in my ears
listen the whole time
but i'm going a step further in that
round
when rocky gets knocked down and
mickey's saying stay down stay down
and he's getting up apollo creed thinks
that he knocked him out
so i have this thing called taking souls
okay
and when you see apollo creek turns
around arms in the air
i got him do you see when he turns
around
and he sees because he apollo creed
knows i was
this dude up he kept
coming after me and i finally knocked
him down
when he turns around and looks at rocky
and and he says and watches him get up
and rocky gets his gloves and most of
him to come to him
apollo puts his head down and just goes
like this
it's not so much rocky getting up
that's big for me apollo creed's
face became
every that verbally and non-verbally
looked at me because you know that look
they give you when you think that you
know
they may not tell you your piece of your
nobody
they look at you almost like you poor
thing
i got them all i got them all now you
know that
that that little wheel you have with
everybody's name on it and phone numbers
i got my number in my head and i spend
that every day
and i know right now
whether you hate me love me i'm a i'm
like this i'm a dad
whatever you want to think i made it
and i know all of you are looking just
like apollo creed did
because i just kept getting all i
wanted people to do in my life i don't
care about the
money i don't care about the fame i
don't care if i care if all my followers
go away tomorrow
i wanted a lot of people that doubted me
to look like apollo creed did in that
14th round because i got
back up repeatedly and when you keep on
getting back up like that no matter how
strong the person is beating the [ __ ]
out of you
they eventually look at you and say you
know what i'm tired
and i just want people to be tired
just be tired i want to make you tired
because i just continue so that's what
that movie did to me that that movie
changed how i looked at life
me too it did how do you pick the next
challenge
the next challenge is usually the
toughest thing out there
the thing i don't want to do the most
yeah so
my challenge has come off of what am i
afraid of
yeah what am i kind of cowering from
what am i looking at saying um yeah
because we all know what it is it's in
the back of your mind it kind of floats
back there it's like
you know for some of us it's as simple
as i don't want to get up and run today
yeah
that's what's next so for me it's always
what am i not wanting to do yeah we have
a theorist
and we have a practitioner the theorist
is a person that can sit back and read
books
from a library that someone else wrote
they become real smart about what
someone else wrote
okay a practitioner as a man
is me i put myself in hell
lived in it for a long time and figured
out how the human mind works
while being while suffering while in
pain while misery and that's how i wrote
my book
yeah i want to tell you exactly what
your mind is thinking
most of us don't stay in hell long
enough to write the book yeah
i stayed in long enough to write it and
finish the book
everybody thinks i'm the world's
toughest mom right if i just talk about
i broke the pull-up record i i i did all
these
races i went through seal training went
through i was in three hell weeks
ranger school if i talk about all the
badassery
like we like to do on social media and i
don't tell you
that i was a kid and i was scared
and i was depressed and insecure and and
all this
what good am i for anybody right i'm a
superhero
i'm a liar i'm that now but i wasn't
born that
yeah i had to make myself into this
what's your morning routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016.
okay so i get up i do that four days out
of the week i go to the gym
and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours
that was the killer part of the book
every night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time
set aside to quiet and recover
recovery's big the mind especially the
mind and the body
this is my time there's no phone calls
there's no emails
the world does not exist because i have
to get ready for tomorrow
get the body opened up why because as i
won't get you know two you wouldn't be
through you went deeper
it was awesome but your body's getting
tight yeah
you go hard tom yeah a lot of people go
hard what happens is that stress
yep starts to tighten up that psoas
muscle hip flexors so
lower back you got back problems all of
a sudden you have no idea why it's all
tightness it's all tightness man because
you're constantly charged and going hard
a lot of us are being forced into
solitude right now
in our homes apartments where we live
but we're also being forced
into solitude our own minds life is the
most brutal endurance sport of all time
and that's what we have to love about it
we have to flip it on his head
and love the fact that life continues to
attack us
there are no timeouts you can't just go
like an important event when a coach
doesn't like something call
time out you have to figure it out on
the fly
you have to be that person who's always
prepared but the solitude right now that
a lot of us are dealing with
is what we don't want to deal with it's
the fact that we have to think about
all these things that we don't like
about ourselves
we like to use life as a big escape the
escape is not there anymore
all these distractions that we use
they're no longer there
this is the time right now for you to
stop avoiding things
get that pen of paper out look inside
yourself
stop looking at me or other people out
here to be the hero
of your story this is time for you right
now all that solitude
to get to know who you are as a person
be alone with yourself
write that down start to start to face
these different things in life
knowing one thing in life we are all
very fragile in this world
we have to know that when we die we die
with some meaning
and some purpose in this world stay hard
in chapter 11 which
that's the last chapter right last
chapter and adam does a wonderful job
uh you know sort of narrating and
telling the story but but then you broke
into this piece that
i just like i had such an even deeper
appreciation for you
where you're like look man like this
visualization about like one day when we
all die
right so would you mind i mean i know
it's totally in the book no it's fine i
think it's a great way to
wrap this so let's say this man so
i don't care what you believe in i'm not
judging you yeah i
i am i believe in god yeah i don't care
if you're eighth i don't give a damn
what you are
but for this scenario yes let's say that
you're god
yeah let's say that
you guys you know for those of you who
read my book get the audiobook or the
hardcover or whatever
i used to weigh 300 pounds yeah yeah i
was 175 in high school and 300 pounds
yep let's say that i didn't improve
myself at all
i die at 75 years old on 300 pounds i
worked for ecolab my entire life
making a thousand dollars a month that's
what i made yeah and i go to heaven
and you're god and you have a big long
line of people
and i'm standing in line i'm coming up
i'm next
so you have mary anne and marianne
you're talking to her you're judging her
and i'm like
what what what the hell does god have in
his hand what's that paper
yeah and so god tears it away and throws
it
in trash can and marian goes walking
away yeah
now you have a piece of paper in your
hand and i'm next and god says sit down
david
david gaga that's right david geiger's
on top of the paper and i say
and god gives me the paper and i look at
it
when i'm reading this paper and on the
paper i'm seeing all these amazing
things
you were a 185 pound athlete you ran all
these crazy races you broke records
you were a navy seal you were the only
person to do this do that do everything
you had a best-selling book man you
changed
millions of lives now look at god
who is you right now and i say um
this says david goggins up here which is
my name god but this isn't me
i'm like you know i think he gave me the
wrong the wrong paper
and god says no because god knows all
god sees all and god looks at me and
says this is what you should have been
this this is what
you should have been yeah you should
have been this
we all have a choice in the world god or
whatever you believe in
knows what you're supposed to be knows
what's inside of you but most of us
take the choice that makes us feel good
we're not willing to break through those
barriers
to find because so my whole mindset was
this
that's how i visualize i visualize that
one day i will be judged by something
much more powerful than me and my whole
thing is
while i'm living on earth god knows
everything about david god
even god i want god to be up there with
a pen
get another piece of paper saying he did
what i didn't even know he'd do that
i know he'd do this i know so i want god
to be
impressed with how i turn out yeah which
means
i want to check off every single box of
all the possibilities
of what i'm supposed to be in life you
are your own hero
you are your own leader you are your own
master
and that is a big one because we idolize
so many people and we want to be them
we want to be someone else and in doing
that
you lose all the potential of who you
are you
mimic you be them you are them you
become them
and you lose you and we look up to so
many people in this world who will let
us down we're humans
i'm gonna let you down you're gonna let
somebody down if you put them on a
pedestal
you then lose time when that person
comes up and lets you down
you must hold yourself accountable and
being your own hero that's what that
does
you make yourself so totally accountable
for who you are you focus on you and
only on you
to become the best person you can be for
others
because we leave a lot on the table not
searching who we are
and then therefore you die not knowing
your greatest potential
so i'm sitting there and i think i'm i
think i'm going to die
and we're saving my life and i'm in this
tub
and i'm jackhammering and this and i had
this hot water hitting me
and i'm literally in the worst pain my
shins my feet i'm broken
and i'm just sitting i'm cramping up and
she said we gotta get to the doctor
you know your mom's worried i'm worried
about like i we've
never seen this for my life and i go i'm
not going anywhere
huh i want to sit here and enjoy this
pain
and and i and i know
the listeners hearing this are going to
say man you're a no
i'm not what i
got a chance to experience in that 19
hours and six minutes of my life
was something i didn't want any
painkillers
i i this was proof positive what i was
feeling
is what i just did i i
did something without training without
coaching without a cheering staff
without any knowledge i took a
raw human being with no training
whatsoever
put him out in a condition and just
through this alone
got through it amazing and i sat there
and i was like
this is it was the best feeling i've
ever had and would ever have in my
entire
i was in the worst pain in my life and
it was the best feeling
i ever had in my life not because of the
pain i was in
by the pain was confirmation
of my god did i just
do that wow and i had completed hell
weeks
but that right there was like don't take
this from me
man and and it was confirmation proof
positive
that this young kid that came from [ __ ]
that wasn't [ __ ] that lied and cheated
for
i was now the truth
i get a lot of questions people asking
me for help
so i asked them what have you done to
help yourself
most of them say i've been working hard
i'm all about being your own hero
but i'm not about kissing your ass
in life a lot of us believe that we're
working much harder than we actually are
we think if we got up early for four
days
we've earned something you gotta drop
your entitled mindset
is dead weight we believe you work
harder than we actually have
trust me most of us have it the one
thing in life you gotta realize is this
learn to help yourself don't count other
people
to help you stay hard i think pushing
yourself physically is the
number one factor of life
that is the true spot where you can
really
dive deep into life's about
self-discipline
it is about self-discipline we tend to
do the things that are easy
and that is the it builds no mental
toughness it builds no mental hardening
it builds nothing when you work out
working out is where you can build that
the fastest
because it's a constant it gives you
instant feedback
it's yeah you may not lose the weight
you want to real fast but the discipline
it takes it transfers over to all
aspects of your life
it's not people man why are you always
working out
stop stop looking at that way this is
the foundation
of life when you look in the mirror
every morning we all look in the mirror
to get ready to go to work to go
anywhere
the first thing you see is your
reflection if you don't like what you
see in the morning you
lost the war already it's not by even
liking what you see
it's about looking in the mirror and you
may start man i feel different
that reflection maybe not that
reflection is not everything
it's a feeling you're supposed to get so
you have to
in life once you leave your house the
war begins
in your house you have some control and
that reflects in that mirror you have to
control that reflection in the mirror
that's how you start your day if you
leave your house feeling like okay
i can fight i've established the
mentality to fight
and that all that comes from working out
it's not just from
you know you can't find that in office
the one thing that only gets me mad
nowadays
is that so many people die with untapped
potential because they think that
someone else is
better than them and they were born
you know not with the greatest tools you
don't need
you need the ability to grind your ass
into a fine
powder and when that fire powder find a
way to build that
back up repeatedly and it's possible
mediocrity is
everywhere right now and we're all
trying to find an easy way out
and we're judging ourselves let's say
there's 10 people in this room
and we're all mediocre but i'm the best
of the mediocre people i now think i'm
great
i'm great we surround ourselves around
people that
make us feel great they tell us what we
want to hear
the second we put ourselves amongst the
uncommon people
we don't like that feeling that
challenge and feeling that of
that person is waking up at 3 30 in the
morning hey push your [ __ ] on we're
going for a run
we don't like that challenge we like
that person who says hey
you know what man i don't feel good
today man and they say oh it's okay
brother
we'll take a day off maybe get a pizza
and watch the game we like that
we we love that feeling why because you
understand man we're good bro
we don't want that much like this hey
man no bro get your
on man stop being a punk we don't want
that in our lives
we don't want that person who's
constantly challenging our weaknesses
we want that process constantly you know
making us feel nice and good and secure
in ours
that's the mediocrity of life we want to
be the best
amongst the average people people wonder
how do you stay
hungry all the time because after i
accomplish something
i don't sit back like a lot of guys who
graduate buds graduate this graduate
that
they get comfortable they wonder why i'm
getting weak man
i don't know i lost my edge what's going
on because once you hit the top of the
mountain guess what happened i'm good
i'm good so you wonder why you're
falling down now because once you're top
of the mountain
you gotta build another one that's
mediocrity there's a lot of people in
mediocrity
who have a nice resume but they're
one-timers man
they hit they hit a one-time deal they
busted it open got a lot of money
but they're good you're mediocre now man
what are you doing today tomorrow the
next
day that's why i'm listening to
theorists i don't listen all that
i listen to who's like this man
what's wrong man tired dude why are you
tired
because tomorrow i gotta do the
again man whatever it is that made me
nauseous and sick to my stomach it made
me hurt
there's no ending and that's the person
i listen to
that's the person who's gained knowledge
you gain knowledge through suffering and
on the other end of suffering
is a world that very few
very few have ever seen it's a beautiful
world
because that's where you find yourself
you don't find yourself in over here you
find yourself on the other end
like the 100 mile race i was on i ran it
for 24 hours
i found myself on the other end
of that race that 19 hours
i found wow there's a whole nother
world out here that never even saw that
the world is in your mind
and that's what all that mediocrity is
about mediocre is contagious
i had to stop caring what people thought
about me i realized that everybody's
that's the one thing i realized i walked
around i put these people on a
pedestal everybody was better than me so
i can't tell you anything about me
because you're going to judge me and i'm
going to feel even worse than what i
am what i realized once i calmed my mind
down and
sat back and looked at how jacked up
this world is
once you realize that you are not alone
everybody that's talking to you
about how jacked up you are the only
thing they've done better than you
is they've hidden their world
better than you have that's all they've
done so
once i realized that if you want to sit
back like for instance there's all these
things that are on tv
and we have all these news people
judging people who [ __ ] up in life
and yeah they made big mistakes but that
person who is judging you on tv i
guarantee you that that news person
they say i'm glad that my didn't come
out but i'm gonna judge the hell out of
you
i know that about people so if you want
to sit back and judge how jacked up i
was and how messed up my life was merry
christmas go for it have a good time
i'm smiling at you right now knowing you
have a secret that you're not willing to
share
it gives you a lot of power when you're
able to go on a podcast this big and say
hey
tell me i'll tell you anything you want
to know can no longer care
how do you react or respond when someone
says something to you negative
or cuts you off in a car or something
happens in life every day
that could potentially upset you do you
react do you respond do you do nothing
do you give them a hug i mean what is
the process for you the process used to
be
angry david goddard scream at them
swearing at them yeah yeah pick a fight
that was the old me yeah the old me was
pick a fight
go go do whatever through this process
of my life
when you get to this point i'm at yeah
and i still be in the car and i talk to
my fiance this this
is jackass with everything or whatever i
now know
that i can escalate a problem that's not
really a problem
i now now i have a throttle
and that's through self-examination is
this a b is this
a big deal is this something i need to
approach with a level three
engagement of like we're going at it
right or just a level two engagement
so now you have to be mature enough and
i'm really big on maturity because i was
never mature for so many years
with age and knowledge you have to bring
in maturity
age doesn't mean you're mature it's
going back in and say okay man look
i'm at a point in my life what is smart
if i do this i i can see the future
i can see that if i do this this is
going to happen
i'm going to escalate this problem is
this warranted
there are some things that warrant me to
escalate a problem yeah yeah
and that's what i do now i take it
through a process rate yeah yes
it it goes on a rating program got it
the most important step we're ever
taking life
is our next one but a lot of us get our
feet stuck in concrete
we get our feet stuck in concrete
because we're afraid to make enemies
we're afraid to speak with our mind
we're afraid of
being in that group of people and when
you walk away
we're afraid what they might say behind
your back
all that fear clouds your brain clouds
your thinking
one thing in life you're gonna always
have haters embrace them
if you can walk up the water trust me
your hands are safe
you can walk on water because you can't
swim
learn one thing shut the [ __ ] noise
out
embrace the fact that people don't like
you it makes you doing something right
stay hard stay in the fight if you can
dream
and not make dreams your master
we all have dreams i had it when i was
younger
so i figured the best place to make
those dreams come true
are in isolation so i walked into
isolation
as dave the goggins but i walked out of
isolation as guidance
where you become a savage is in
isolation
when you train for a big mma fight or
just a boxing match
you don't stay outside of isolation
you go in isolation and that's when your
mind changes
that's when your focus changes your
dedication changes
don't use this time to up your mind
use it to grain strength gain focus
isolation is the key to strengthening
your mind
come on savage how do you feel about
letting others in on your goals and and
and having like
external pressure to hold you
accountable no there's no
external pressure that's best no you
know what i mean but i think other
people oh yeah
yeah it no it's important to have
circles it's important to have like
like i talk about man like like that big
rabbit hole of bad people
that you want to get away from like if
you're drunk and you want to stop
drinking
you got to get away from those people
you want to build this nucleus around
you of people who are saying
it's not okay to sleep in today we gotta
get after it
hey let me see your journal you're
supposed to be running five miles today
you only ran three
you got to have those people some people
need those people
and it's important but you want to get
to the point in your life
it's real important that you hold
yourself accountable
and those people start to fade away
because you now got it
you want to be that person because
they're not always going to be there to
hold your hand your mind has the
ultimate tactical advantage
over you it knows what scars you
it it it knows your fears it knows your
insecurities
and it protects you which i talked about
the 40 rule in my book
the 40 rules all about the brain has the
tactical advantage
over you it knows and it keeps you away
from all that
that's why it says don't jump out of an
airplane don't go in the ocean where
there's sharks
it's a protective mechanism don't go
back to the place where your dad beat
the [ __ ] out of you in your mind
don't go back the brain protects you
but protects you so much it doesn't
allow growth
so the brain is an amazing thing but the
brain controls you
you must control it you must take power
over your own
mind or your mind will guide you into
all the soft spites
soft places that your brain wants to
live in
your brain has enough information it
doesn't want to go through that process
of of mind hardening doesn't want to do
that
i gotta remember what time i gotta be
here what time i gotta be there
this is where i wanna stay i'm peaceful
and wants to stay very peaceful away
from scarring
i think we're all an underdog i think i
think the top ceo
on the planet earth still has that doubt
yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] where you're from
kobe bryant michael jordan the best on
the planet
we're all underdogs whether you're
underdog because you put yourself there
to be hungry
or just a real life underdog we're all
an underdog
and so this this is about
the mind and people discovering the mind
their own mind and one thing i know is
we all have an equation we all have an
equation like you know
i'll talk about three point you know
3.14 is pi
there's different equations to figure
out different kind of you know
mathematical problems
we as human beings are mathematical
problems
i cannot give you a book for every
[ __ ] body in this world that's from
my book
even though it's one book it's tailored
to the individual
it's not like you do these five steps
you're good no i'm helping you figure
out your
equation because it's different my
equation's different from your equation
what's going to make you tick what's
going to make you go the distance what's
going to make you go to that spot in
hell and say
i love this spot it's okay
that's what this book does it helps you
figure out your 3.14
helps you figure out your mathematical
equation and say oh
because once you figure out the equation
in any math problem
you no longer fail man you got it
figured out and in times of need
even the hardest person forgets how
badass they are
so i've been through a lot of my life
when you're going through a hard time
right now you forget all the hard
you endured so the cookie jar
is a reminder that oh i can get through
this hard time right now but you gotta
take
a second or two to reach into the mental
cookie jar
let's say it's a fortune cookie but in
my mind my mom used to buy these cookies
now in the cookie jar and
there's an oreo or chips or whatever
that's where i got the cookie jar from
but you got to open up and say okay man
i was in three hell weeks
and i got through two of them you know i
was in ranger school i i endured
being called [ __ ] i i saw these
beatings i i you know
my mom's soon to be husband got got
murdered i saw all these i saw a little
kid's head get ran about
all these things i endured alone i have
to remind myself
of the strength and the power that i
have that it's in me
it's just a reminder of how badass you
are in
hard times because you know we just
forget that that bad time consumes our
mind
and we forget who we are speaking of
making that list
accepting where you're at so that you
can address it
in the book you talk about like what the
things are that you're going to be doing
you're going to be
putting the list together how do people
go about
using i don't know if it's the
accountability mirror how do they go
about
addressing each of those issues okay so
let's say the first one is
you're not the smartest person in school
i had that issue so my big thing was how
i addressed that problem was
how to sit down each thing that is wrong
with you
has to be a focal point you can't look
at this gigantic list since i gotta
change all the
my god this is crazy no
you take off the first one i want to be
smarter for me that was my thing i
have to i have to become more
intelligent i have such a severe
learning disability man i can't retain
i had to now get that one thing and then
strategize
in that one problem how can i do this
i'm not gonna learn like you i'm not
gonna learn like anybody else how am i
gonna figure this out so i then
figured out okay where are my strengths
here where my weaknesses
in learning all right man how am i going
to do this and i figured out
a way to do it by this strategizing so
how i learn
to this day if i have a big manual to
study
i will have to get a bunch of spiral
notebooks
from the from the daggone store and each
page
i have to write each page out maybe 10
times
so there was a thousand page dive manual
that i got 18 months before i went to
dive school
most people i'm not smart i'm a ghost if
i can pass this test
i realized hang on a second i'm not
smart
how can i get past this how can i get
through this obstacle
i need to get i need to acquire this
book 18 months in advance
because it could take me 18 months to
write down each page
over and over again to then put it to
memory
so when the question came up i'd written
that question
so many times down in that in on you
know on paper
that i can recall okay page 71
was where i remember seeing this and i
can recall it that way
and that's how i did it so you got to
strategize on each problem you have in
life
slowly break down that problem don't
think about all the problems you have
just one at a time and before you know
it you fix
all these problems but you cannot focus
on all of them just on the one thing at
a time
i believe in a higher power don't know
the names don't know where it's coming
from don't anything like that
but i believe that this power
and visualizing me real quick let's say
it's a man up there or a woman whatever
and they have a chart and when you're
born
they say david goggins
born february 17th 1975 at 6 00 am
they write the chart down because they
can see everything they know exactly
where you're
supposed to be they know what you're
supposed to be
you die you go to so-called heaven you
arrive at heaven i'm 300 pounds
i retired as an eco-lab guy which is
okay just a job whatever
i go up there and god looks at me
and he shows me my chart and my chart on
there says you're supposed to be a navy
seal
you're supposed to weigh 185 pounds
you're supposed to be one of the
smartest people on the planet this this
all this you see this and now you're in
heaven you made to heaven but you're
like god dawg i was supposed to live
that life
i was supposed to live that life and
then you find out
that the reason why because we all think
that if we pray on it if we do this if
we do that whatever
if we don't work we just whatever it
could magically happen for us
no i believe that when i'm all said and
done with
my whole job is to outwork the chart
whatever the chart says about me the
all-knowing power up there i want to get
up there and say
him look at me and say i know everything
i didn't see this
i didn't see this i want to feel that
i want to get to the other end of this
world
and however i'm being judged whoever's
judging me
to look at me and say i did not
no i had you at 185 had you did this but
all this other
i was riding as you were living it
i want to i want to find
more all i can and in that
second you have to dive in that
to find more because if you're not
willing to go in there and face yourself
you're not going to find anything you
can live right here on surface man right
here on surface
so if there is an ending to this world
and there is somewhere to go and there's
a judgment you're gonna get there and
you might see a chart
and that chart may tell you who the you
should have been
and now you get the rest your life to
think about that
man i could have lived a much better
life you become complacent
you become very civilized in life you
know the worst thing that could happen
to a person you become civilized
when you get to that point where you
believe that you've arrived
when you my god man
i'm up there near michelle obama on my
book
i've done it man mm-hmm i'm good you can
coast
i can i'm good you don't have to do her
dude you played your man card
i'm doing i want to be a wildland
firefighter man i retire from the middle
i ain't got
i gotta go out there and dig fire line
for three miles i'm 43.
i've done it you should just be flying
first class
everywhere everywhere doing speeches and
getting paid crazy cash
laying in a hotel kicking it man and
that's exactly when it's over
that mindset right there to me is death
i'm not saying you can go as hard as you
did when you were 20
or not 43 but there's a new
bar that you must always set in your
life and once you become complacent
and you become civilized you've arrived
you're no good for anybody sometimes
where the mind gets overwhelmed
and you cannot slow it down but by
these these certain tools are developed
by not allowing your mind to get away
from the moment
you cannot you have to think about the
exact moment that you're in
but i saw when i was younger the moment
became too big
when it became too big i spazzed out and
i would quit
but now i don't think about even like an
hour from now i'll be eating
i don't even go there ah because then
your mind
goes oh no we must embrace this because
now
there's you have to be a leader in this
moment it's not about you just getting
through it
i had six guy i had five guys and six
including me in my boat crew
now is the boat crew leader so now
another trick is this
if you don't think about yourself
there's no pain
which can also lead to pain later on in
your life but in these moments when
you're struggling if you are a true
leader
and you're worried about your men or
women beside you
your mind doesn't care how cold you are
anymore your mind's only worried about
taking care of the men and women beside
you
so i started realizing man if i take
care of these cats to my left and my
right
in the worst moments my mind is no
longer thinking about you're
miserable david goggins get the hell out
of here think about how
is john how is andy how was sam how was
pete
hey how are you guys doing you're not
thinking about me i didn't have any
drive
i'm gonna go be a navy seal what kind of
stupid is that 300 pounds
there wasn't like a drive to go be a
navy seal i was an insecure
lying kid afraid i had to
look in my insecurities and in my fear
and find drive in that
we're all looking for passion passions
all around you
you have a whole a whole sack of it all
around you it's your insecurities all
that sh
you gotta dive deep in that all this
it's all in there
all the energy and fuel you need is
right in yourself
it's all there you got a lot of stuff to
do to overcome
and you know that's where i found it i
found it right there among insecurities
i found drive
in my own insecurities and that's that's
the most powerful thing in the world
when you can find drive in your own
doubt
fear insecurities you become very
unstoppable
to do that take a different vantage
point in life when you are
in the hell you can't see the beauty of
being in it when you're in it
get on top of that mountain top in your
mind guess what that mountaintop and
look down in what you're doing
you can see a whole different world and
that world is beautiful but you got to
get a different
vantage point in this in the suck
don't be in it spiritually get out of it
get that soul look down on what you're
doing be amazed
by the process of where you're at now
and where you came from
by no means am i expert at this but i do
know a lot about living the sewer of
life
i've been getting a lot of emails from
different loved ones about people
who have killed themselves my next door
neighbor two months ago
she just killed herself tons of veterans
i know
they killed themselves i got an email
two weeks ago from a family member
that an 11 year old boy killed himself
from people at school bullying them
one thing about life is that people in
life they are the ultimate puppet
masters
they exploit your weakness and they love
to walk you around life and own space in
your head
one of the biggest ways to cut those
strings and walk on your own two
feet to your own destination in life is
to build self-respect
self-esteem self-discipline all those
things
stay hard is not just about going gym
stay hard is about going that extra step
and you
can't that's what builds self-esteem and
self-respect stay hard
your biggest enemy your biggest
the most important conversation
you will ever have in your in life
is the one you have with yourself you
wake up with it
you walk around with it you go to bed
with it eventually
you're going to act on it whether you're
good or bad
you have to that's why the whole thing
about this book i have
it's about you it is about you
is strictly about you finding who you
are so many people
die live a hundred years never know who
they are
never know who they are you have to look
in that mirror and know
this there's so much more in here man
because i can literally right now be
a 300 pound guy spraying for cockroaches
still to this day
if i did not look in that mirror and say
there has to be more to this
this can't be it and then willing to go
into it
dive deep into it and give all i have to
find it
there's no hack what do you think is the
biggest stumbling block that most people
face with this kind of journey honestly
is they have the woe is me mentality
is too hard life isn't fair
these things in life are are not easy
for me you
you look to your left you look to your
right and you start to judge yourself
off other people like if you're a female
well she's skinny and she doesn't work
out as hard as i do and
everything starts to corrupt your mind
you start to look around too much at
other people what they're doing and that
starts to corrupt your own
dialogue we are judging ourselves
against too many
people you have to judge yourself
against yourself
and that's the one thing i started
learning man this in the race against
me and rich roll this race against david
goggins and david goggins alone
and once you can silence all that all
the outside interference and things that
are attracting your mind to everything
you can then start to grow and realizing
i'm stressed out for no reason this is
my own little race
this is my own timeline and this is how
i'm going to run it
let's say for instance we have a family
let's say we're all a big family here
all three of us all four of us are a big
family and every morning i'm getting up
training for a 200 mile run
and you see me get at four o'clock in
the morning and all you
are sleeping and by time i get done
running my 30 you come i come home just
getting up
how are you going to feel about yourself
a lot of times when you're overachiever
and you have people that's what talk
about the mediocrity thing
a lot of our family members a lot of our
friends they're mediocre
there's always those couple of guys who
are uncommon who want to be better
but you make that mediocre mother feel
like
whether it's your mom your dad whoever
you make him feel horrible i've been
there i'm speaking from experience
when you get somebody around you man
who's trying to be better and you don't
have the drive that they have
it's a constant reminder of how you are
you have to know that that's what it is
anybody in your court's not saying man
get after it brother i'm so proud of you
they have a problem with themselves
because all you're trying to do is
achieve more
if that's a problem for somebody you
have to look at them and say
man you really have a problem with
yourself huh
i'm in a search for a feeling
i'm not in the search for a trophy i'm
not in search for love not so much for
more followers on instagram or social
media
when i started this journey years ago
and i realized that i'm going to be
somebody
and i'm searching for a feeling a
feeling of true victory for myself
and only myself the second i shut out
the whole world
and realized that one thing that i am in
this world
alone i'm fighting in this race by
myself
yeah i'm all about people i'm all about
team i'm all about that
but i'm really all about right now and
in my life
it was important for me to finally
realize stop being all these fake people
i used to be
stop being afraid there was no growth
until i cut myself down
to nothing to the person i really was
the real human being
and once i found out who i really was
that's when i started growing
i was trying to build on top of a
lied foundation
you can't build a house in the
foundation so i had to get down to the
actual mineral soil
of who i was and that's when you can
start real growth
so the other day i got an email from
this lady
she said she truly enjoyed my book but
as she read it
she thought i was just crazy so after
she read it she put the book down
and started living her normal life just
going back paying bills
going back to work complaining about
a few days later she has time to think
about the book
and it scared her she thought well maybe
this guy isn't crazy
and that's what scared the most maybe
he's here trying to show us human
potential
what we're all capable of doing a lot of
people like to put titles on other
people
who are doing extraordinary things it
makes them feel better about themselves
give them a good idea free card i'm not
crazy
i'm just not like you in sports
there's a thing out there called load
management
a lot of us like to load manage our
lives when you do that
you're gonna find yourself right at
normal get off that
stay hard is there something that you
want to be
known for the one thing that you want to
stand out through all of these
accomplishments and be remembered for
um honestly
i honestly want to be considered one of
the hardest men to walk to planet earth
in the history of the world
and what i mean by hard i'm not talking
about the guy who does the most pull ups
the most sit-ups
runs the most just a person who's
able to overcome any adversity in front
of him
to figure out a way hardness isn't about
all this physical [ __ ] man yeah it
helped me get to where i'm at
but all i was doing in the whole process
the process wouldn't be ripped
it wouldn't walk around my shirt off
that wasn't it i knew through the
physical
challenges through the physical
suffering
my mind was getting stronger i was
literally doing that for a reason
i had a weak mind
all the rest just happened to come with
it i was trying to strengthen the mind
to handle
all the all the judgment that's passed
on me
perceived and not sometimes you make it
up in your own head
you know i i just want to be able to
handle all of that
everything physical mental i want to be
perceived as that
like an old school barbarian an old
school guy that's like god dawg man
nothing can hurt the guy which is why
the book is titled
can't hurt me i want people to have that
mantra
in their life take that with you take it
everywhere you go in life
and if you believe that and you work
towards that
callous in your mind strengthen yourself
can't hurt me as strong
in any situation like when i was in buzz
they beat the [ __ ] out of you
i'd be the first one to give and say
can't hurt me and they were beating the
hell out of me
but you say that enough to you false
motivation becomes
real motivation after a while so i got
the vfw award for the
for the um americanism award for
military service and giving back
i'm as human as human can be
that's why what you see is what you get
um at that moment when i was giving my
speech
and i thank my uncle for being there and
i got to my mom
it wasn't just about her it was
i i i know what she went through i know
what i went through
and we got knocked down so much i had a
moment
in front of all these great american
heroes where i had a chance it was like
so fast it went through me like like
lightning
of i can't believe i'm here
i can't believe i'm getting an award
like this
that that kid who was in the fetal
position
the majority of his life and
so much the fact that my body my hip
flexors are tight to this day
that even though i was standing erect
my mind was in the fetal position and
when i looked out amongst all those
people
it was a sense of pride that
i can't even i can't even explain
it's the moments of three hell weeks
it's the moments of
in that room by myself studying for
hours and hours and i was trying to
catch up with all the kids who are above
me
it's just those moments like the real
raw
moments of life that was like boom
hit me and we're gone but i was like i
did that
i overcame this you know it's like this
is power
behind all that and that's
the feeling i was looking for in my life
i found it wasn't money it wasn't fame
it wasn't awards
it was that feeling i have right now the
feeling i'm about to break down
but it's not of like oh my god i'm upset
it's like i worked myself
so hard that i turned
a person this into this
right here not off of reading a book off
a theorist
off of going to work on myself and
saying
i don't know how to do this but i know
that
to get over there that inside i gotta
grind myself into a
confined powder
and i did it i did it all for sure will
and very few people will know how that
feels
to get up every day or five days a week
whatever
when it's snowing shiny not not shiny
not not comfortable and
to go in the gym and work out when you
don't want to go to the gym it is not
fun
if you don't see results in the first
two days of the first week
i'm done that's the mentality of most
people
the struggle is too real we're not
patient we
like in a world where you can google the
best restaurants around me right now
no one is patient and for you to lose
weight for you to stop drinking if you
wherever the hell you're going through
it takes a lot of patience a lot of time
and a lot of
pitfalls a lot of plateaus you can hear
so many
plateaus if you don't know how to get
around that plateau
it's not going to happen fast yeah
everybody wants the hack
yeah everybody wants to have there is no
hack man there's no hack
well my morning routine is every day i
get up and running
every single day because why i hate that
the most
so that is why we share that feeling yes
i hate that the most so
you have to do something that sucks
every day because why once you overcome
the suck
oh now you're powerful you've overcome
yourself already so now you're ready to
battle
i go to the gym about four times a week
but my biggest thing i do
is my nighttime routine i stretch out
anywhere from two to four hours every
night
for the last five it used to be a lot
longer than that and i talked about in
my book why i started doing this thing
but i had
through my whole life as you see i was
using my fight-or-flight muscle
i was under severe stress as a child
growing up my job whatever
a lot of stress just sitting down right
now raw using our psoas muscle
your hip flexor muscle and i'll give you
a two second on that
that muscle attaches to your t12
and about five or six years ago i got
really really sick doctors give me all
kind of hormones take this take this
take this
and it's in the book real good so i
won't go deep into it now
but i laid back and i literally said you
know what i'm dying the doctors can't
figure out what's wrong with me my blood
tests were coming back fine
i just like my i can't even run a block
i went from around 205 miles i came
around a block i'm in my bed sitting
there
and i started realizing i had these
humongous knots
on my hip flexors and back in my head
and i said i'm just done so i started
slowly stretching out i couldn't do
anything
over a period of a couple of years i got
off this medication
that medication i was in like 15 i was
on several medications now i'm on one
and honestly i what i believe no doctors
have said this is what happened to you
i was literally so tight i was cutting
off blood supply in different places
in my organs the more i opened up my
body so now i went from running 8 30
mile
on a training run to now running a 7 15
to 7 minute mile on training run
it's the same heart rate and it's not
because i'm trained any different
it's just because my body my body's
opened up and it's allowed my blood flow
so
every night i stretch out and it's truly
i have to be wound
so tight like i couldn't sit in this
chair for this long
i'd like i'll get i could get out of
here man give me i go it's totally
changed my whole perspective of life
it's changed everything so stretching
out
yoga all those things has put me to a
whole different
state of mind and i'm the healthiest
i've been in my entire life my purpose
right now is to continue
i used to have a wash rag when i did
this and you know how you take a shower
you have a wash rag and a cloth and you
uh
you're sitting there and you're just
lathering up and before you hang your
rag
up you want to get all the water to come
on it and you know get all
that all you know all the suds out of it
you want to ring it out
and you want to hang it up so my big
thing is
when i live my life i want to make sure
that when i'm dead and gone
that i ring that wash rag out and that
rush rag is my soul
and i also believe that we're going to
end up one day meeting a maker
if you believe in one and i believe that
maker knows everything about you
everything about you one's else could be
here is talking to you knows everything
but you also have a choice to make you
have a choice to make we have choices
and the one thing that scares me to
death in my life
is getting to heaven and not being what
i'm supposed to be
and i believe that god has a chart and
he looks at the chart
and he puts it in front of you and you
get to heaven and he says hey this is
what you're supposed to be
and one of my biggest fears in life was
to
see that chart and not have every block
checked off
you know i want to make sure that i'm
constantly pursuing
whatever it is i'm pursuing just to be
the best i can just constantly grinding
myself into a fine powder if you want to
be great you want to be
best forever at what you do
you could be misunderstood by everybody
because you're going to be so [ __ ]
obsessed and so driven to get there
that's what it takes
that's the truth it takes every second
of your life anybody says balance
yeah balance is important for a lot of
people it is
but if you can go to that edge where
people do not like you don't understand
you
question everything you can do you
you've arrived
when you are misunderstood to the point
where people think you're psycho and
you're nuts and you're this and that why
are you in the
gym at one o'clock in the morning you
just got through doing a op
for 13 14 hours after ranger school man
at the gym was wrong you will never
understand what is wrong with me and
that's why
i'm so glad you don't because i'm in the
right
spot when people don't understand you
anymore you're in that spot
of obsession and drive where people like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
i don't want to talk to you man because
you're not going to get it
you're not going to get it boom i want
you to get it yeah
i want you to get it and people wonder
why am i not achieving more
it's because once you m all of us once
we achieve something
we celebrate for a long years
time and we wonder why don't i have
drive anymore where is it all at
if you don't develop a routine of
suffering and suffering it's not like go
out and kill yourself every day
it's being uncomfortable yeah that keeps
you hungry every day
if you live in your victories for so
long and say i'm gonna go challenge
myself for 30 days or for two weeks or
one dish run this one marathon it ends
i did one marathon okay
that's why it leaves you it leaves you
because you haven't set up the next
obstacle obstacles is how you grow
you must continue to have friction
friction is where growth is at
with no friction there's no growth you
have to be on a constant reminder
almost like how you put a reminder on
your phone 15 minutes you got this
that has to be in your brain you've done
too much
stop and what happens in life is that we
start to see our lives becoming so
successful
we're making money we're doing this
we're doing that
i went more i went more i push harder
i'm all about pushing hard don't get me
wrong obviously i'm
all about it but to push as hard as you
can
you have to be mindful of the machine
that's pushing
it is going to end up dying and then it
takes years to get it back so you lose
that time
totally that time is gone you know i
lost five years of
i could be crushing it where now i'm
just now back to crushing it realizing
god man
i learned the hard way let's believe
sometimes one way to learn
so i just finished the leadville 100
mile race
tough race went through all the ups and
downs
there's two kind of mindsets you have um
under load under load under stress one
mindset's a brittle mindset
and that brittle mindset gives you all
these ways out
oh i don't need to finish the race
i can come back next year i want to drop
out because things aren't going right
you also have a savage mindset the
sadness mindset is this
like in a house a house you have these
low bearing
walls some people aren't really
educating low bearing walls
doing remodeling to the house they tear
the low bearing wall down the house
crumbles
that's a brittle mine the savage mine
when things are going
bad guess what they do quitting's out of
the question
all they think about is how the am i
gonna get through this
there's no quitting it's just getting
through and thriving not surviving
walk me through a day in the life what's
it look like right now well
i mean it's got to be crazy right now i
i leave here and i fly out to oregon
and i'll be in oregon with uh cameron
haynes we'll be getting out there for a
few days
a lot more podcasts a lot more
interviews but every day every morning i
get up
i still get my run in every morning how
do you structure the training
the training is basically structured off
of my schedule so look at my schedule
and i said okay um jennifer what do we
have today
we have this at seven o'clock in the
morning
roger that that means i gotta be up by
four o'clock in the morning to run
that's how it works that's how all my
[ __ ] works
so she lays out the schedule of events
two out you just you just set it two
hours earlier
she says it could take an hour to get to
rich rolls let's say we were at seven
o'clock today
in the morning it takes an hour to get
to rich rolls with no traffic okay let's
let's block into hour 15 for rich roll
okay we got that the morning time i'm
gonna run
seven miles this morning i need uh 52
30 for that roger that put in [ __ ]
shower shave
add that in so the schedule dictates
but i have always just push it back
right so that means getting up at 1 30.
trust me roger that i've done that
several times yeah several how much
sleep do you usually get
i i like getting seven to eight hours of
sleep
nowadays i can do that but there's times
where the schedule says hey man
you're getting three hours and if that's
the case right merry christmas
you look in the mirror and say wow i eat
a little too much no you're
fat my exoskeleton is larger than yours
right no that's the new one right yeah
that's
i mean you you cannot say that to
yourself no but see
you have to make a list yeah of the
things that you don't like to do
this list should be very long like if
you're like making calls
yeah yep the very first thing you should
do
is start making a ton of cost because
why that
begins to own you yes you start to drive
yourself
this way versus this way but you'll
figure out
if you start making a whole bunch of
calls if you like calling
call a lot yeah guess what happens you
get over it you get over it
so what we do a lot is i heard a lot of
people say triple down on this triple
down on most of your strength
no no no no that works for a lot of
things
but when you're afraid and you don't
have the courage
you have to triple down on your
weaknesses and make
that become where you start to guide
yourself okay i'm like calling
today i'm making a hundred calls
whenever life will start getting good
for me
god would throw a nice anchor and stop
me right there
so i'm going through pear rescue
training and there's this evolution
called
water confidence and water confidence is
pretty much
what gets people kicked out of special
you know special forces special
operations is the water
and they try to drown you pretty much
this was not in the warning order so i
didn't know anything about water
confidence
long story short what it is is they put
16 pound weight belts on you whatever
they can do to make you uncomfortable in
the water
so for six weeks of a 10-week program i
became very uncomfortable
we got down to about 25-30 guys left i
was one of them
and getting near graduation this program
thinking my god i'm about to get through
this barely though
water confidence is killing me right
they took me to medical
they they they drew my blood and
realized i have sickle cell
yeah so sickle cell is a blood disease
that some african americans have
which is not good no so they took me out
training for a week
and when you go from being uncomfortable
that's your lifestyle you get used to
being uncomfortable right
when you go back to being comfortable
your mind says i don't want to go back
to being uncomfortable again that's
right
so i was like i don't want to go back to
the water so my whole mindset was i want
to get out of this training
so i was hoping that they were going to
medically disqualify me from pear rescue
program
that didn't happen a week later the doc
called me in the office and said hey
guess what man we're gonna put you back
in the training
i was like okay well i missed a week i
got about two and a half weeks left i
can do this
i went back to the you know to the ceo
the command officer he said hey guess
what
we're gonna start you back from day one
and when he said that to me my mind went
back to the old david goggins so i
thought i had changed
yeah learning learn how to swim learn
how to read and write
all i was doing was attacking the
surface i wasn't getting down into the
dungeon of what was really bothering me
so whenever
like tough times would happen any tough
time that
really tough time that would happen i
would go back to the sewer
of my mind so this happened i went back
to lying
i said hey you know what co this guy you
know the doc didn't know about sickle
cell he didn't give me a good reason why
he's talking about sudden death heart
attack stroke
i'm not comfortable so he gave me a
medical
from pear rescue so he allowed me to
leave but i really quit
i didn't want to go back in the water
again right and that's when i went from
weighing 175 pounds
to 297 in about three and a half years
wow
so i did a job called tac p yeah
controlling fast movers behind enemy
lines but
that job wasn't the job that i wanted
and
the spiral of depression yeah trying to
find things i was comfortable doing
and whenever you find things that you're
comfortable doing you're going away from
the journey of life
and i was going so far away from my
journey that my weight
showed my whole mindset we all have a
voice in our head
some of us are very spiritual some of us
are not but we all have this voice and
you're doing
this is wrong don't do that the more you
don't listen to that voice
the further that voice gets away from
your head some people call it the holy
spirit some people call it god some
monks whatever whatever you call it it's
there we all have it
it's the right or wrong voice but the
more we don't listen to it the more that
voice
goes away the only voice you hear is
yourself
we all when the only voice hears
yourself you're wrong
there's a voice that guides you through
life but sometimes this guy in your
direction that you don't want to go
that's usually the right place to go
it's that uncomfortable place
so that voice is always talking to me
but we don't listen to it
and the thing about it is like if you're
in a in the kitchen and you're cutting
up cucumbers
yep you cut your finger it happened 30
years ago
that scar is still there they say what
happened to your finger guess what you
do
i was in the kitchen one day i was kind
of cucumbers you know
cut my finger you have those scars in
your
brain yeah from life yep but what we
don't do is we try
to hide those scars we don't want to go
back and revisit it
this is not as simple as a cucumber you
know you know cutting a cucumber
so i started realizing that my life was
causing a whole bunch of scarring on my
brain
and i had to go back while i wrote this
book i had to go back and really
break open that scar and let it bleed
and that was a very painful journey for
me to go back because you know like
right now this is all surface
learning disability call me [ __ ] well
it's it's all surface
i guess a lot of people have dealt with
that stuff yeah very sad yeah
but the way i talk about the book i'm
i'm getting your hand
yep and i'm taking you back there with
me yeah as that kid in that classroom
who opens up his spanish notebook he'll
sit in the back because
i had a fourth grade reading level i'm
in the back
up my spanish notebook on the first page
they had a hangman drawing
of me saying [ __ ] we're going to kill
you very back
i'm a sophomore in high school nothing
but white people
i shut that thing up and i leave class
what's the impact that you want to have
on the world
the impact i want to have in the world
is for everybody
to be able to face who they are i want
to have that kind of impact where you
can go
on tv you can put your life on a
billboard
you're not ashamed of who the [ __ ] you
are you're not ashamed of what life
made you what you helped life make you
all that all that bad
that's now in this big pot that's
stirring you're no longer ashamed of it
you realize we're all
stop judging yourself against other
people who have
hidden it better than you it's all
they've done
they've mastered better than you have
and now they're flipping it back on you
and saying you're
i want you to realize that this world
life is one big
head game and once you learn to play the
head game it's no longer a game anymore
at all
you can start living your life it's easy
to look at you and that guy's
that guy is lit up on anger and
resentment
back in the day so i gotta say i've
never said this before i was actually
telling my fiance this the other day
people think
anger was my fuel just so yeah anger can
be a fuel
anger got me to look
into things to become better i want to
show him but i
tell you one thing when you're suffering
and you're
at the wit's end and you want to quit
that anger is gone brother well it's
also not a sustainable feeling
your mind is thinking about let's get
out of here so i realized this angry
i didn't think about my dad beat me up i
think my kids call me [ __ ] i think
about it
i thought my man water is cold as balls
now i get the [ __ ] out of here
so i realized anger was no fuel for me
it may have got me to say i want to be
somebody anger got me caught up in some
serious ego
trips man i uh stuttered real bad
severely bad
fifth sixth grade fourth grade horrible
i had
like my hair would fall out white
splotches over my skin
horrible horrible anxiety
so me talking about myself as much as i
am
on stage on podcast i'm still
overcoming you're still battling because
it's comfortable for me to say i'm off
to sort of meet you
don't talk to me i'm good go back to be
my hermit
this is very uncomfortable so i'm
constantly coming outside my comfort
zones and doing this stuff now sharing
my story with people
as much as i can buddy of mine calls me
the other day and says uh
he's having trouble running past eight
miles this is a guy who can run 30 miles
any time of the day so i tell him to
come out to my house
and we'll get some runs in so he comes
out he goes mad i'm telling you i can't
run past eight miles
but i realize in his life he's had a new
kid more responsibilities at work
all this stuff he's not thinking about
this i am so i take him out for a run
we get 30 minutes into it how far are we
going goggins
i ain't telling them get an hour into it
i ain't telling
an hour and a half into it didn't tell
him so soon he shuts up
we run three hours the guy does fine
next day we go out there he's able to
run 20 miles again
so this is what happened to him his
circuit breaker blew
our minds are very similar to circuit
breakers when they blow
you got to figure out what it is
sometimes you just add it too much to
your
plate go back in your mind and figure it
out what's the best advice you've ever
received
i didn't receive any advice and that's
the thing about it when i grew up i just
didn't receive any advice
my my family was in such turmoil that
the best advice i received is for myself
and that has to be to study yourself all
the bad
because the good's already there you'll
need to study that study study the best
stuff about yourself
and learn from that and grow the truth
of the starting line
we live in a world that's very
unauthentic
so who are you what do you stand for
what do you believe in you know a lot of
people don't like what i say
a lot of people hate that cuss a lot of
people hate a lot of things about me
i don't give a [ __ ] when you find out
who you are that's where you start
living your life
don't fit in just for the sake of
fitting into life
make sure that you have something to say
say it social media nowadays
is one of the biggest forms of being
fake in the world
people buy likes people buy friends
people buy comments all this
make sure in life you do what you have
to do
say what you have to say and live the
life you have to live
don't walk around being a fake human
being don't be scared to be who you are
stay hard our mind wants to protect us
the mind is like honestly it has a
tactical advantage over us
it knows our deepest darkest fears or
insecurities it knows
where we start to feel uh we start
getting that doubt creeping that says
hey man you know what man maybe this
isn't good let's go back home to the
wife
let's go back home to the kids this is
not comfortable
so in that moment the mind directs us
it's a protective mechanism
it saves us for doing bodily harm or
or it really saves us from discovering
that the mind's like i want to be in
charge of you
i don't want you to be in charge of me
so it tells you let's just stop right
here
but once you start breaking through that
barrier and start
breaking down that governor the governor
that you've put in your mind
because we forget we are in control
of our mind we believe it's the other
way around
no we put in our minds what we should do
but we believe our mind is telling us
it's giving us all this feedback
we have to reprogram it and tell us no
no no we're good
we're good we go this sucks but it's
okay
when you really sit back at your life
and you in that dark
room and you're looking at where you
started from
and you tell yourself ah man
my mom is this way my stupid step dad
got murdered my dad beat the [ __ ] out of
me
i can't read and write to say my soul
i've lied about it to everybody
i've cheated on all these tests my god
man
and then you put a goal in your mind
how are you gonna feel man when you
accomplish this goal
coming from that [ __ ] coming from the
hell you came from a lot of people start
from a good starting point they have a
good foundation
what if you can surpass all these we
have everybody who was
way up here started up here and you had
you started with no legs you had to grow
legs to even start walking
and then crawling and then running and
then you start passing people and all
that's given to them
i had to use all this negative that was
making me weak
and horrible as a person i had to use
this as
the power that now fueled me had to flip
it on his head and say hold up
this might be exactly what i need the
darkness
is exactly what i need it's how you look
at your situation
and i was looking at it all if you're
willing to suffer
and suffer and go back in the grind that
internal dialogue you have with yourself
when you're in misery
and you're uncomfortable it's a real
scary
unfiltered no lying dialogue between you
and yourself
and people know exactly what i'm talking
about
when you're in a bad spot in life and
your mind is saying all kind of
that's who you really are that's the
real you
no rocky balboa moments going on up
there like hey
you know it's around 14. let's come on
we got this no it's like this i'm out of
here man this is crazy
that's where the growth happens when
you're able to stay in that moment
and talk to yourself talk yourself back
into the suck
of wherever you're going through and you
start stripping those layers away
but as you're stripping those layers
away you're building calluses
over top in your mind that's where the
growth starts to happen
is when you have to force yourself to
stay in it
you can't you can't leave it the most
important conversation you'll ever have
is the one you have with yourself
you wake up with it you walk around with
it eventually
you act on it and my self-talk was
most disgusting self-talk of all time
so the sewer of my mind like i said you
have to go back in there
and fix things a lot of us are afraid
like right now 20 years ago
you wouldn't find me on this show i was
too embarrassed to tell you
i stuttered i lied all these different
things getting beat up getting bullied
whatever
happened but that's where the true
transformation starts to happen
when you can look at people anybody
thousands of people one person and say
hey
this is who i am and this is where i
have to fix myself
and this is where it really happened i
thought it happened
when i was in you know 19 18 years old
trying to pass this military test right
it happened here when i was almost 300
pounds spraying for cockroaches
making a thousand dollars a month and
you know people call me dumb people my
dad called me so many things and not
even funny
being beat just stripped me of all
self-esteem
this is when i realized i was alone on
this earth
you know i have god alone on earth and i
have to fix
everything so this is where i started to
develop an indestructible mental toolbox
okay so i came home one night after
spraying for cockroaches at
lab and literally i was praying that
steak and shake
and i would go across the street to
7-eleven at a 45-minute commute home so
i work from 11 o'clock at night at 7 00
in the morning okay
i had a 45-minute commute home and
my my stop would be you know steak and
shake chocolate milkshake
across the street 7-eleven box of mini
chocolate donuts
and i would eat that on the way home
yeah sure now i come home i turn the tv
on
i take my shake because the box of
donuts were i mean they were killed
oh yeah i kill those yeah go back to the
back turn this
you know turn the tv on and take a
shower listen to the tv when i'm taking
a shower
this day i heard these guys on the tv
talking about navy seal
toughest class 224
so i heard stuff about navy seals you
know these are the baddest of the
baddest yeah
and i'm so i come out and i'm watching
this show while i'm drinking my shake
and when you're watching the show of
guys who are putting
out there and they're quitting quit left
and right oh sure just can't help
they're going through hell week
they show them going through first phase
second phase third phase and they're
dropping like flies
i looked in this one guy's eyes who was
ringing the bell to quit to put his
helmet down out of the navy still
training
and i saw myself and i saw what
everybody said i was going to be which
was nothing
what i said i was going to be that that
that conversation you have
that's who i was so that's why i lied to
people to tell them
a different version of the truth sure
i had to make all those lies reality i
had to make them real i had i had to
become a real person
so that's when i put in my mind that i'm
going to go
to the toughest military training on the
planet
and where it has the most water
the thing i was scared of the most i had
to go back so a lot of us run away from
our fears and we box ourselves in
to uh a lifestyle of this is all we can
do
right i'm afraid of everything outside
this box yeah so i'm comfortable inside
this box
i jumped the box oh you did for the
first time i laughed mentally i jumped
the box
and said hey i got to come out here and
play i'm the only person in history of
the military
who has ever gone through air force um
tactical air control party training
um army ranger school whereas arnold man
in three hell weeks yeah so only person
ever do that
but the reason why i did it was when i
was a young kid i considered myself very
weak
very weak and as i started developing
this
indestructible mental toolbox because
what i realized was
the things i was like most afraid of i
cowered from
i had to start facing these things and
becoming an expert
at the things i feared the most yeah i
was afraid of my own mind my mind would
get off on these crazy places of
what was me my my internal conversation
wasn't great yeah
so i had to start mastering it once i
started mastering it
and the horrible place i was at i was
literally i considered myself the worst
person
ever alive that was my conversation
but once i started mastering my own life
i started realizing
my god man this was in me yeah i was a
300 pound
fat guy now i'm 181 pounds or 90 pounds
there was
i'm going to go through all these hell
weeks so i started realizing
the capabilities of the human soul in
the human mind as i have the ability
to see the end before the beginning even
begins and what that means is i know
that to get to the very end
i can see it right now so before i went
to butts and i was losing
weight i saw myself walking across the
stage
at 191 pounds that's what i had to get
to to get into the door
i saw myself six months a year later
whatever's going to take me to do i saw
myself walking across that stage getting
that
certificate of graduation from buds and
i was able to be there
at 300 pounds and that
feeling that i was nowhere near that
feeling i was able to put myself there
a million times every day and that
feeling of like
my god that is going to feel amazing
that's what made me suffer that's what
allowed the pain to be real and say
this is worth it i want to feel for this
next 18 months it took me 18 months to
finally become a navy student to finally
you know just get through butts
18 months six months took me 18.
that's what woke me up every morning was
i'm gonna put myself through this much
pain and suffering
for a few seconds that's all it is
a few seconds of joy it's so
worth it man i said people don't get so
i'm able to put myself
at the finish line even though i have no
finish line
but at the finish line of an event
before i even start to
say how are you going to fill it into
this that's why i i've been able to
put myself in cold water put myself in a
hundred mile race
millions of times before i've done it
and i'm able to go
through the race and see i'm going to
feel at my 50. almost
to the almost to the exact exact feeling
right so when it comes up it's no
surprise no surprise i've already done
this a million times
sealed training became pretty hard and a
lot of guys weren't getting through it
so they designed a sil pet prep program
like a boot camp for the boot camp
that's right yeah and it was two months
in my last two years before i retired
from the military
they sent me there to train these kids
wow to get ready for 14 19
20 years young kids so when they get to
navy silk training man they were
physical studs
they were running swimming i mean they
were they were hybrids
wow but they get the buds
and the same amount of people would quit
why is that this is why
we were training bigger stronger faster
quitters
hmm it's not about not the mind that's
right
we weren't diving into the sewer
everybody's got a story
we don't share it on social media we
share our nice
life on social media we have we all have
a dungeon
i'm just willing to talk about mine yeah
most of us don't really talk about it
i'm want to talk about my dungeon i
wasn't getting into the dungeon of these
guys minds
i wasn't building that so-called mental
toughness mental toughness isn't
something that you
sample it's something that you live in
every day
so when something hard would happen to
these kids like in hell week
it would draw on something that made
them very insecure
and they look for comfort whenever
hardness comes and you know it is
it may be different for you than this
for me but
you go back to your insecurities and
then when you go back to insecurities
you then look for comfort
within those insecurities and we all
look for that cookie that your mom used
to give you
when you were sad when you were sick we
look for our wife or our husband we look
for comfort
it's in those moments you must retrain
your mind
to think differently in hell
i wasn't training them to do that why
weren't you training i wasn't training
myself yet because at that time
i was doing what i was told these guys
needed me a
standard physical standard a physical
standard
the physical standard is not what they
need to meet
it's a mental standard you must meet in
life
in the book you tell people to make a
list of everything working against them
every
real valid excuse right why do you have
them do that
there's a lot of power in that list so
in that list of who you are what makes
you [ __ ] up
all these other things it goes back to
once again
accepting you have to first accept it
before you can fix it
a lot of people walk around oh man i'm
good
i'm good no you're not
you have to accept what you're not you
have to and people don't want to do that
that's the only way you can fix it you
have to accept it first before you can
go on the journey
a lot of folks never even start the
journey man they never start to join
because they live in this fake
life that who they want to be
they act like they are but they're not
because they haven't fixed all this
stuff yet
you got to fix this first before we can
start our journey in life
so that's why i have them make this list
you fix these problems
now your journey can begin because you
no longer care about
how people are judging you when when you
care more about how someone's judging
you
you're gonna stay right there i
understand that you
lost some friends in operation red wings
so how did what did that feel like to
you
being that i went through i was in three
hill weeks i knew a lot of the guys i
knew every guy that died on the
operation
so the story touched me so much i wanted
to find a way to raise money for their
families
so i found a special operations warrior
foundation if you're a special operator
and you die
it would give 100 tuition to your son or
daughter to go to college
great foundation so now i gotta find
something to do to raise money for it
so i started googling all these
different races i found the bad water
135.
so it's 135 mile run through death
valley in the summertime
had no idea about ultra running i'm 250
pounds i'm a big meat head
so here i am calling the guy up on
wednesday he goes hey you got to qualify
for this race i go how you qualify
he says you gotta run 100 miles in 24
hours or less
i'm like is that even possible i haven't
run
over 20 miles the whole year yeah
going through buzz i started realizing
that you had to learn to control your
mind in these situations
so at mile 70 when i was in the worst
shape my entire life
i was able to draw on being calm
i never thought in my wildest dreams i
could be a navy seal
it's until you opened your mind
open-mindedness creates that
we all shut down our mind like for
instance when i broke the pull-up record
everybody around me who heard the
pull-up record was 4020 pull-ups
that's the first thing they did oh my
god four thousand and twenty four hours
or
yeah it's four thousand twenty pull ups
and twenty four hour period yeah yeah
the first thing i did versus closing my
mind you're like oh my god that's crazy
i went and got a penny okay how many is
that every minute exactly
every hour every second instead of
taking life and making out to be
this grandiose thing start breaking it
down
start breaking it down and most of us
we live in a box and we don't want to go
outside that box
at all ever outside that box
is all these possibilities of life what
we do is we shackle our mind we are a
prisoner in our own mind
that this is all i can do this is all
i'm good at
and we we we take away the possibilities
of you could be this
you could be that yeah you could be all
these things and i never thought at 300
pounds i could be negative
wow so if my mind was shackled me and
you would never meet
there'd be no book right there'd be no
book right
there'd be nothing so what people
understand is that they live for
themselves
not knowing that you have the power
within yourself
to change millions of lives yeah by
facing life
it doesn't go from like one morning um
this way the next one i wake up and
presto the you know five steps to
greatness
no it ain't that brother you read my
book this is hard work it's
every day like right now i had to be
honest with you man
i'm even shaking right now being on this
show i'm a big time introvert
how you address it is you face it you
face it every day you face it every
single
day of your life where you say okay
like if you're fat you need to lose
weight it's patience
it's patience in this fact of accepting
who you are right now
i'm fat i don't like myself except in
fact if you lose three or four pounds
that's a huge accomplishment you have to
live in your own
[ __ ] world you cannot judge yourself
that's why social media
all these things are horrible you can't
judge yourself off of the so-called
competition that we have made up in our
mind
the things that how people look how
people like how smart someone is
this is a race that you run completely
alone
and you're all by yourself i had tons of
sticky notes all over my mirror
it wasn't like be better than john or be
as fast as whoever okay david yesterday
you did this
today our next goal for the week is this
so i had a year goal weekly goals
daily goals hourly goals and the big
goals i lied a lot growing up
i wanted to be accepted one goal was
let's go one day without lying let's go
one day and then when i would lie to
somebody i would say hey man
now go i had to go back now and
apologize hey man i lied to you you know
how hard it is to go back to somebody
say i lied to you
hey man you know what back there i lied
to you dude i
i was really jacked up so i figured out
these ways of total
total accountability like right now i
had to run this morning
before i talk to you because why that's
what i'm about
i'm about mind mad body fitness
a lot of folks talk so much
about hey i'm going to change your life
i'm going to do this i'm going to do
that
are you accountable for what you're
doing are you accountable
and i mean to the t for what you're
saying
i am and that's where it started it
started with that total
total accountability of let's not lie
today
let's tell people the truth about who
you are and when you can get on
and tell someone like i'm doing right
now exactly how [ __ ] up you are
that's the goal in life to put your life
on a billboard
on the busiest road in the busiest
highway in the world and say
this is how i used to be i have to be
very present in everything i do like
right now i'm a rich role
i'm not thinking about but rich roll and
what the [ __ ] coming out of your mouth
right now
that's what that's what gives me a huge
advantage in life especially today in
this day and age with so much
going so fast and everybody wants to
keep everything going everything up and
everything
i want to be the greatest you know the
greatest multitasker of all time
not me if i put my hundred percent
into what's in front of me i will
destroy it
if i'm out here just multitasking it i'm
going to half-ass everything i do
so that's it is the most important thing
the word of me is being focused at the
task at hand
there's so many times in life you don't
want to be doing what the [ __ ] you're
doing
you can't just quit remember this
this isn't a hobby it's in the joke it's
a lifestyle
so what you say to yourself is important
there's no [ __ ] coach there's no
trainer to keep you going it's only you
so think about this you've been working
your whole life to get a seat at the
table
to see the tables you want to be the
best amongst all the best people in your
career field so you finally get that
letter
it's steak lobster it's a big dinner
everybody's showing up dressed to the
nines
make sure you show up soaking wet for
[ __ ] after
working out hard tower on your neck you
respect the event
so make sure you put that towel over
that nice chair
so you don't the whole thing is this
don't say a word stay uncommon amongst
uncommon people
you're never done don't stop when you're
tired
stop when you're done stay hard the
reason why we go back to old habits is
because our goals are too lofty
we're not achieving our goals fast
enough so what happens is you know what
ah man
we're very impatient nowadays for me
it was good i have a phone i was i was
i was out of this world by myself
it was a race against david goggins it
wasn't a race against
god i don't look good for this person or
that person it was me
i gotta change myself so for me if i
lost five pounds in a week
i got a feeling i allowed myself to feel
proud
of that i didn't look i gotta lose 106
pounds
i'm like man i went from 297 now i'm
292. in one week man i'm i'm killing it
we don't we're not proud of ourselves
for the small accomplishments
what we need is we need this monstrosity
of the thing to happen say
i did it no there's a process that you
have to go through and patience
is the process and if we don't have
patience
after a week i haven't lost 30 pounds
and i'm done i'm over it
so that's why i found out with people
man they're not patient enough to
realize and to
enjoy the moment not living it just
enjoy it
there's no finish line in life but enjoy
that moment
roger that man lost five let me go 10
next week
so that's the whole thing about it
that's how people lose it
you you get the opportunity to become a
navy seal
and then you end up going through buds
three times
it's like yeah merry christmas i got
lucky yeah i was very fortunate to go
through three times and not in a
sadistic way
in a life-changing growing way i found
out so much about myself
through going through that training
three times and i went through the
hardest part
of the training three times you know
after the first so so first phase is the
crucible man
and that's where i was at for three
times i spent most of my time in buds
and first phase
in the hell week in the hell weeks and
being in that grind
and in that grind i got time to examine
myself
i caught the live autopsy and also
examine
other people because i was really good
about putting people way above me
because i was i wasn't i was never
nobody
so for me to be on the same stage as
these great
wannabe navy seals and bus trains like
my god you guys are amazing i actually
got here with you all
thank you so much for allowing me into
play but as i was there for so long
i got a really good chance to sit back
because now the cold water is just water
now
it's not a cold anymore your mind starts
to change
they say get in the water most people
think about it for you
it became my life so i started learning
that
if you start to change your mindset
versus it being like oh my god this
sucks
i became a professional bud student so i
wasn't going to leave until i graduated
so i started realizing if this is my
home
this is what i am i had to always reset
the bar i had to reset my new norm there
always had to be a new norm so
one thing we don't do is we don't have a
new norm my new norm is
you get up every morning at four o'clock
and you suffer
this is your new norm that became my new
life
most people want to get out of it i said
no this is your new life this is who you
are
you your new norm is you wake up and you
suffer
and i started realizing if that's my
mentality
this [ __ ] ain't hard anymore you're
enormous you wake up you get in the
[ __ ] cold water
you're gonna be here to this done
whenever they say you're out you get out
so my new norm so i i do that now today
my new norm now is
if i'm doing a 200 mile run your new
norm now man you
are doing 200 miles the roger that
mentality that's
it man i don't i don't live on the
surface of anything yeah
surface is what got me where i was at it
got me from 175 pounds to 300 pounds
telling everybody i'm good i don't i
don't give a damn i'm good
no they're they're hollow words
a lot of us speaking hollow words i used
to speak in hollow words
i don't do anymore everything that comes
on mouth has substance is real
and we all have these feelings in our
bodies and our minds and our souls
i act on mine a lot of us who are afraid
of something we allow our minds to
choose the path of least resistance so
we go a different route
and i'm afraid of something that's
telling me you must kind of
you must do that yeah you have to go
that way
and most of us don't understand that
mentality
we go left and we wonder why we haven't
fulfilled something in our lives
it's because we continue to take the
journey that is mapped out
and how i look at is i i talk in life
like a lot of us in life want to take
the four-lane highway
that has road maps and all this other
stuff on it man it tells you where to go
gas stations
the next 10 miles up you're gonna see a
mcdonald's a crackle barrel
yeah it's the easy route very few of us
want to go to the right side
a lot of us dream big you you should
dream big drinking big is important
you know some of us will be doctors
lawyers dentists so much more you know
want to be in special operations so you
have this big dream you can see it so
clearly like it's right in front of you
you can go out and touch it
but the thing about it is somewhere if
you dream big enough somewhere down that
journey
that dream becomes a nightmare and what
happens in that nightmare
so they have all these questions like if
you want to be a special ops you may not
be a great swimmer you may just realize
that i'm not a great swimmer i'm not a
great runner
you may start to fail tests and all
these questions start to flood your mind
why am i here i'm not good enough trust
me i know all about the
questions they will flood your mind if
you do not have the answers for them you
will quit
the answers lie in the repetitions you
must not forget the repetitions you put
into trying to dominate the craft that
you're in today
always always embrace the suck
adapt the sun a lot of us don't know
of a whole nother world that exists it's
on the other side of suffering
once you break these barriers that you
have made for yourself
like the mind is the most powerful thing
in the world in the world
it is so amazing that i used to be a 300
pound guy
and i thought that was it could barely
read could do anything and now
that what was inside that person was
this guy that's in front of you today
that's how scary the mind is and that's
what i started realizing through this
journey
is that once i got a taste of wow man i
haven't even
cracked i haven't even begun to crack
what the mind is capable of and when i
start realizing is on the other end of
suffering
that's the real growth of life because
you realize
how the mind processes and i talk about
another thing called theory and practice
a lot of people are theorists
they these smart guys that read these
books
man and they sit down they tell you what
the mind is supposed to do
and a lot of us listen to that it
becomes like this is it man
this this old man who has been studying
the mind forever
this is the cap that we have by being a
practitioner
i went out and realized a lot of these
guys are so wrong man
the mind has capabilities that are so
unknown and i found that through
suffering
and there's a whole other world on the
other end of that sometimes we can be in
such a bad spot in our lives
that the only answer is to say
and go for broke in my life
27 years ago i was in that spot and this
guy asked me a question yesterday
was a question jennifer he asked if
you're paying the price
physically now for what you put your
body through am i paying the price
so my answer is yes i am
but what he didn't know was literally
i stepped back at 297 pounds looking the
accountability mirror i saw a reflection
i didn't like
it wasn't so much the outside there's a
lot of the inside
so that bothered me and i was going to
do whatever it took
to change that reflection you got to
find out what you're going to do
to change the reflection accountability
mirror so one big thing is
accountability mirror
you have to start with yourself so what
happened
in my life was we start to get i call it
like the rucksack a rucksack is a pack
that you carry in the military
and you put all your stuff in it your
radios your food your water all that
stuff you have to carry the military
that's your rucksack it's a backpack
pretty much
as you're growing up we all have a
backpack most of ours
hopefully is empty you know and what we
put in it
is all the crap we go through in life
that's what is in the backpack for the
civilians
and we carry it around with us so what
you have to start doing is realizing
that no matter where you're at in life
i got called [ __ ] a lot my dad abused
me
you know learning disability stutters
immaturity insecurities
self-doubt so much crap on top of me so
much stuff i lied a lot to create
friends so people so much stuff was in
my backpack
no one's coming back to help me so
it starts with that person in that
mirror you have to realize you are on
your own now
and whatever else you believe in i don't
care what you believe in but
on earth it's a very lonely journey
it starts with the accountability mirror
of looking at saying hey my dad who beat
the hell
he's not coming back all these things
are coming back i have to face myself
and you have to own all those things
that people may have done to you now
it's yours
you got to own it it's yours now to fix
the problems that people did to you
it makes no sense it's not fair i get it
but if you live in that what was me
mentality of guess what
my dad did this to me my mom just did to
me people who bullied
did this to me you're going to always
live right
there you have to figure out ways to
move forward
because you're not coming back it starts
with the mirror i call it the
accountability mirror in the book
if you walk into any kind of
event whether it be physical or mental
if you walk in with already putting that
block on your mind if man
this ain't going to happen people go how
did you want to hurt 35 miles to death
valley and
how'd you run a hundred miles with no
training
because i went into it not thinking i
can't do this man
i went to it with a strategy i had
open-mindedness
so until your mind is open to the
possibilities
that i can do this you would never be
able to do it
once the mind starts to believe it can
be achieved
it then only then does it start to break
down tactically
how we can do this until then you're
gonna always lose
when you're afraid of something you have
to master it
that's how you start to overcome it so
what i realized when i get to that point
where i want to quit
everybody they get the point where they
want to quit this is what happens
the mind tells you let's go home let's
take a warm shower
let's get some food this is not right
this is that
if you cannot answer the questions at
that moment
because your mind's gonna start giving
you all these questions
all these questions and if you can't
answer them
you're going to quit what i realized
when i was going through
buds ranger school officer 100 mile race
200 mile races pull up records
my mind would come creeping in like when
i was doing 4 000 30 clips
at 2 000 pull-ups and my hands were
ripped open
my mind said look brother we've done all
these other things you've proven
yourself you're good
if i didn't have the answer to respond
to my mind and say why i'm here
why i'm doing this you will always lose
that fight you have to have the response
to what your mind is going to tell you
and another thing about that is
self-talk a lot of people have like
these big four on
mental toughness all this crap about
self-talk visualization it's true
but the thing about self-talking all
these things they ask me what do you
think about when you're on mile 100 of a
205 mile run
what are you thinking about when you
realize you've run for 24 hours
and you have 24 more hours to run and
yeah another 105 miles what goes through
your mind
what do you say to yourself i want to
know
a lot of people think self-talk works it
does but it doesn't work
without the suffering before your mind
starts saying we need self-talk so what
i tell myself
is i go back to the months and years of
preparation to get to that day
and i'm telling myself the 3 30 in the
morning
and i'm looking at my shoes and i want
to go out there and run 30 miles
i have to in that second in that moment
of this self-talk my mind saying you got
to find more you got to find more
i once again calm down go back into my
mind
in my cookie jar i call it and i had to
reflect back
on the [ __ ] i did to get here and that
becomes my self-talk self-talk does not
work unless it is real
most of us lie to ourselves in this
self-talk it doesn't work
it has to be real it has to be something
that you've done to make it really work
what happened most is that if i would
have died at 300 pounds let's say i was
75 years old
i got to heaven and god has a chart like
that on everybody's life
god knows all let's say that i don't
care what you believe in
doesn't matter i'm not judging anybody
let's say my thing is god
you get to heaven i'm 300 pounds i sit
down i was a cockroach
terminated my whole life and we're
sitting down just like this you're god
and i'm david
and he gives me that chart and he says
look at this
now look at this chart and on the chart
it has all these different things
but my name's on it but these things
aren't me i was gonna change the world i
was gonna
i was gonna set records i was gonna be a
navy seal i was gonna be
all these things in the military that i
accomplished you're gonna get the vfw
award you could be
honored here honored there i'm like god
i was
this isn't me like it says david goggins
i was an ecolab guy i sprayed for
cockroaches and i'm 300 pounds i said
here i'm 185.
it says here i got a a bachelor's and a
masters it says all these things
and god goes no that's who you were
supposed to be
wow my biggest fear in life
is if there is a final resting place in
this world and there's a final judgment
and you talk to something much bigger
than you
i don't want to sit down have a
conversation with someone
with something that says you're in
heaven
this is what you should have been on
earth and
are you really in heaven now are you in
hell thinking about how much i left on a
table for fear
for not willing to go over the wall and
over the next wall
and over the next wall so in my mind i
believe that
and god knows all at least i believe
that
i want god to be up there right now as
we're speaking
writing stuff down saying my god he
exceeded even my
expectations that's how i live my life i
now know
that there is no cap on the human mind
there's no cap we cap it ourselves
whenever i'm weak at something wherever
i'm scared of something i master it
i was a weak my you know a weak minded
person so i mastered my mind
and the master in my mind i mastered the
human mind
and i realized why i no longer judge
people why i'm not gonna put people on a
pedestal because we're off
our own way we all have demons some
people hide them better than other
people
so i know we all have them but i mean
knowing that i know that most alpha
males are very fragile
very fragile they never want to see
another person harder than them
especially in that kind of ego
attachment
ego is serious so if i can hurt your ego
i got you so by me having such a fragile
ego growing up
all this was my advantage i was doing a
live autopsy
on how i was i was like hey this [ __ ]
me up i better
tell people up too so i started using
all these different tools and tactics to
get instructors heads
and taking souls that's what happened
man we were wednesday
freezing cold everybody's jackhammering
everybody's everybody wants to you know
everybody's just want to get through it
now
jackhammering's when you just can't stop
shooting you can't stop shivering you
know you're sitting there this
uncontrollably jackhammer and the
instructors take great pride in watching
you suffer they do
we're you know in a in a sick way it's
it's kind of funny you know you know
you were there once as a as a student
now you're an instructor
but i knew how would i be thinking if i
was an instructor i would love
seeing this sadistic go on but when i
what wouldn't i like to see i would hate
to see
some guys just looking like this is just
another
day on the beach and go yourself
i would hate to see that so they all
want to think like
when they did it they were harder they
were harder yeah everybody's hearts i
said you know what man
it's time you all i can't fight you you
guys can
be up all day long that's your job and i
love your job i love what you guys are
doing you guys making us better but now
i want to take the tactical advantage
and i'm going to start with you
so i got my boat crew bill brown i had
chris kyle my boat crew right
american sniper i had a couple of
hardcore and everybody right now is kind
of like in their own world
let's just get through this man i can't
wait till friday so we can graduate how
we can get going
i said let's go ahead and have some fun
i said we're gonna start we're gonna
start
so the evolution here was we've got
through with med check
you know we're stripped down to nothing
and they're checking us out making sure
we're good
you know checking for pneumonia checking
for knees my knees all jacked up they're
giving me shots
and i was like the boat crew leader of
boat crew 2.
so i'm in the front of the boat and i
tell our guys this we're going to do
the boat was like on our heads so it was
we're supposed to lift the bolts up
above our head that's all you gotta do
but when you're this weak and this
fragile you're this tired
the boat's heavy so there's a thing you
can do when you do boat presses
you can get the boat and like just toss
it up toss it up and catch it and that
shows like you're jacked up
so everybody's holding the boat and
they're shaking and they're both
starting to come down their head and all
the boat crews are all lined up and
they're
now i'm looking at that and i turn
around my brokers hey guys
it's time to take some souls they'd be
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i said we're gonna get i go you see like
instructors out here on their
jackets and drinking coffee and laughing
and smiling
i want their faces to go straight up and
numb so we're gonna do this we're gonna
start boat pressing this
just take my lead trust me you'll get
energy from it we started throwing this
boat up in the
air catching it throwing up and catching
we start yelling i can't hurt [ __ ]
bull crew too
we're yelling our ass off and we doing
it
and they make a stop like like what the
[ __ ] like to stop
i look at these instructors and
their faces literally look like someone
like just like took their soul out
because i know where their minds were
like
they were thinking about themselves like
what
just happened man i know me on wednesday
i couldn't have done that
how they doing it so the rest of time
going through hell week
it was like we just we owned it right
vote crew 2 we we won every single race
we were just dominating
and um it was uh it was a strong boat
crew
and that's where taking souls is uh
there's a few taking soul stories but
that's one of them
there's energy all around us but we
think that we have to have it has to
come externally a lot of times
we gotta have like a tv in front of us
watch somebody listen to a podcast
listen to a great music a lot of times
in life it's
quiet and those are the times when you
want to run and hide
you got to be able to find energy you
got to make up
games make up tricks make up whatever
you can to get to the next
evolution of life so taking souls
is just another way it's not about
hurting the person you're against
it's about finding the tactical
advantage in every situation you
physically can to get to the next you're
trying to
inch further to the goal line
and you don't want it what is that line
the goal lines whatever
it is for you for me i want to get
through hell week
that one get the hell with like you know
with my head up high
being strong i don't know what the goal
line is for everybody
my goal has been very different for most
people but you're trying to find
energy and strength to stay in the fight
to continue on until you get that second
wind the second wind is coming
whenever the second wind may be for you
it's coming
but what happens is we get so stressed
out that the end is so far away
that we just can't find another foothold
or another handhold
so we jump off the cliff and we just
fall well life took me somewhere
unexpected i'm unprepared
it's about six degrees out here and i'm
under dressed but guess what
no one gives a [ __ ] you gotta get them
sometimes
life can really hijack your mind when
that happens to you
you're all your goals your ambitions
everything is out the
window in life we all go through
different things
sometimes your girlfriend or boyfriend
breaks up with you guess what get the
over it they no longer want you maybe
you fail a test in school you worked
your ass off guess what
you fill out the test get over it move
past it
learn to not let life hijack your brain
at work you've been working your ass off
that new promotion
you don't get it someone else does maybe
they kiss better ass than you do guess
what
get over it life will hijack your mind
if you let it
don't allow all these things to make you
a lesser person
you must own your mind don't let life on
yours
all that i went through in my life to
get here today it is tattooed
it is tattooed in my brain every day i
wake up
i am constantly battling
that person that is like man you know
back in the day this happened to you man
you know like
you got called [ __ ] so many times and
your dad beat
it out of you man and you know you you
couldn't read and it's
dad going junior year all these things
start to creep up
even now where you're at today every day
you're having to constantly battle it's
not as bad as it used to be by any means
right but that person is still there
it's
that person always lives that's the
that's the point about you have to
continue to always
challenge yourself every day the one
thing i'm most scared of in the world is
is uh losing losing touch with
the the best thing in the world is is
your mind
your mindset how you can picture
yourself how you can focus how you can
drive how you can put yourself in so
many situations get out of it
because those headphones you listen to
those those phones that
that we google to find information
there's so many situations in my life
where that's just not going to help me
it's not going to help me and you're
able to just
turn that off so fast because i know
what's helped me none of that stuff has
ever helped me mm-hmm
none of that stuff's gonna help me what
has helped me has been me alone
getting my together and being
accountable for who i'm not
and who i want to be i coach a lot of
people nowadays billionaires
who called me on the phone and said matt
i'm still missing something
it's because they did what they were
good at
and they had this beautiful family two
three houses
cars everything has everything to work
on the outside looking like my god man
how can you be unhappy
i walk around with the backpack with all
my stuff in here no car
right and i walk around happiest person
in the world
have nothing happy as hell it's because
i found out the whole key to life it's
not in all that
you have to face yourself so many people
live to be a hundred years old
and they die miserable having everything
because they never
examined i call it my live autopsy
you never examine this
happiness peace enlightenment
it's all up here man it's all up here
if i start talking like this people are
man you know i don't know
it's the truth man yeah it is true it's
all up here
you just gotta want to go and face it
and that's the hard part
a private school you don't need to have
this humongous gpa and also
what you need is the one thing i talked
about my book which is straight up
brutal work ethic you have to be willing
to
outwork everybody in the world
and that that that's the hard part
that's the hard part this isn't like
some
five-step process where you can do these
five steps
you're going to end up with this magical
world now
i'm basically teaching you how to
callous over
your victim's mentality i'm teaching you
how to
like i did 67 000 pull-ups and training
for the pull-up record
i was seriously calloused in my hands to
protect them
what i'm trying to do with people is
teach them how to find more themselves
to where they empower themselves i'm all
about the underdog the most important
conversation is the one you have with
yourself
you wake up with it you walk around with
it you go to bed with it eventually
you act on it sometimes you act on it
good sometimes bad
you got to change the internal dialogue
that person in your head that's talking
that to you
until you change the internal dialogue
in your head
until you callous over the victim's
mentality
that the world is out to get you because
of you are the only
you gotta change that [ __ ] man yeah but
you don't understand my life david yeah
i do so that's the thing about it and
that's what i can talk about but yeah i
i get what you're saying
a lot of folks don't under i get that
mentality i once had that mentality
that no one understands what i'm going
through and if you keep that mentality
you're going to stay in the same exact
spot that you're in
that no one understands me there's a
whole there's millions of people
why do you think a book that i
self-published you know
is doing so well with a story that's
sold
people like i never give up i went to a
publishing house like who's gonna
resonate with this story no one's gonna
buy this book
i'm like are you not in the world
are you not in society you're never
alone
everybody's going through so when people
get this
mentality of like you understand me you
can throw a
rock to someone that can understand you
if they're willing to break themselves
down and stop hiding
a lot of people understand you but you
got to stop hiding
and that's why i tell people a lot of
people are going through
they just hide better than you did what
happens is once you
transform yourself and even though i'm
still i'm not running from myself
i'm constantly facing myself i'm
constantly battling myself
i'm not running from them anymore i used
to but now i'm constantly battling them
so now what happens is once you get to
port in your life where you're able to
be on a podcast or be on a tv show and
tell everybody how
you are i will answer any question you
want about me
anything i did anything bad good ugly i
will tell you
when you get to that point in your life
that's where your real journey begins
and you no longer have to have a a small
victory to keep you going
you now realize what your purpose in
life is
and you realize all this just part of it
but at first you need all these
different tactics to keep you going
because you haven't figured it out yet
once you figure out that you're in a
race
amongst billions of people that live in
this world you're in a race by yourself
you have a purpose and it's your purpose
not everybody's purpose
it is your purpose and only your purpose
and it's your race
so then you're like hey man i'm doing my
thing i'm doing the best of my ability
what's next
there's no longer these small increments
to get through life
because once you figure out why you're
here
it just becomes a process talk about mr
dobbs
um he's a good friend of mine still to
this day
and he went into that place man and i
knew where he was going
is my third hell week and i knew sean
real well
but i knew he was real arrogant he had a
serious chip on his shoulder like i do
i still do i gotta control it every now
and then it got me in a lot of trouble
sometimes
but i knew he had it i knew that trip on
your shoulder not being controlled
it will it will get you up and it cost
him a lot going through buds
and i saw the look i saw the look
because i once had the look when i was
going through pear rescue school when
something got so hard
and your mind can't process the hardness
you don't know the the
the right tools to get through something
hard because you've never been
challenged before i could tell he was a
superhuman
that nothing never challenged him but i
knew because i already been through her
week a couple times i knew
don't don't underestimate that it will
it will find a
demon and we'll bring out some
insecurities in you and it did
and i it was like uh maybe 30 hours in
the hell week or something like that i'm
looking over at him
and i smiled at him we're we're standing
just like this in line
and he's getting his med check the
doctor's looking at him doc it happens
to be a beautiful timing
and i'm sitting there i'm getting med
checked and i'm looking at him
and his eye says he's a thousand yard
still looking right through me
and he's getting med checked and i'm
looking at him and
before all this happened i told him i
said don't underestimate this
man he was i can't ever see myself
quitting goggins
i go watch out i go watch out i go this
will get in your head i go the end is a
long way away so we're sitting there eye
to eye
and he didn't see me i'm right in front
of him and i can tell you thinking he
has that quit in mind starting up
and look at him i go i told you
i told you the next thing i knew man
a car pulls up and um he
he rolled out rings the bell he rings
the bell and he quits but um
it was uh he's a great human being
um hard mother it it doesn't make you
you know when you quit something like
that man
it's a huge lesson learned that i can't
go into anything
thinking that there's nothing that's not
going to get in my way
you got to be prepared for all those
obstacles when i picked up your book the
thing i loved about it
is the amount of effort that you've been
through to give us i'm sure
this was suffering too like writing this
book the amount of effort that you've
been through to actually give us
detail right on your life we all have
different things in our life that have
scarred us
we want to act like those scars don't
exist so those scars like you know if
you go out
and you get cut that scar is going to be
there on your arm you can go down and
look at that cut and say
oh or or that scar and say oh that
happened from
you know i was in the kitchen or what
happened we have the same thing in our
brain
i have all these scars on my brain from
growing up
from you know being abused from
suffering through life from having a
learning disability from stuttering from
having just a really bad childhood and
so all those memories i had to cut open
that scar
and go into it and that was a hard
process for me to do
not only was that a hard process for me
to do for me to have the courage to
share that with people
you know because i'm the so-called
toughest man on the planet
so they think so for me to break open
that shell and tell people hey
that wasn't always me you know it's it's
hard to do you know
it's hard to do so it was a tough
process throughout this journey i
started becoming this new person
i started creating this new person and
people started seeing me
as this amazing superhero
in the back of my mind i knew the real
story and i was like man one day you
have to really share it i'm like man but
do you have the courage
you know like it's great to live right
here i've established this people think
you're great
just stay here don't go back let's not
go back
but the only way you can help people out
is let them know that this is possible
so i had to go back and say this is
where i come from
yeah and where i come from as hell we
live in a world now
that's so kind we we find the kind way
around everything like if you don't look
good i have to find a kind way of saying
i don't like your shirt
right that's not the approach if that's
the approach you're looking for
that book is not for you can't hurt me
is not for you the approach you have to
take
at least i took you take whatever
approach you want the conversation had
to be a real
honest conversation in the
accountability mirror of guess what
i was fat don't find a kind word to say
that you know what
i've gained some weight no you're fat
when i couldn't read not like hey you
know even learn disability
no i cannot read i have a fourth grade
reading level i'm struggling
and sometimes i call myself stupid not
in a way to put myself down
so don't take it like my god those are
so horrific yeah the hurtful
dishonest the conversation has to become
an
honest conversation of where you're at
mentally where am i
mentally i look like i feel like
i'm not this i'm i'm falling behind in
school i'm lazy
my house is a mess you have to look at
what it is and call it what it is
don't find words to make yourself feel
better because
that's what so we hang around people
that make us
feel better that tell us what we want to
hear
not what we need to hear and so we stay
away from those people
and we stay away from those people like
our internal dialogue
becomes that kind it's okay it's not
okay
so that's where it starts it starts with
that accountability of
it's not okay anymore this can no longer
be okay
and calling yourself out for exactly
what you are and exactly how you need to
fix it as you know i'm a serious
introvert
and um very afraid of people
i i got judged so much growing up
that this is uncomfortable for me all
these podcasts you know that's why i
post once a week
yeah i don't you know people are ugly
people are nasty they make me want to
choke the [ __ ] out of them
and they're just nasty people so i stay
away from them
but the one thing i realized um why i
wrote the book
is honestly i have a story to tell
as we all have a story to tell and
what i realized on my journey was a lot
of us don't believe
that we can achieve the impossible
and along my journey i started realizing
man
i gotta tell some people about this man
like i discovered something that some
people have
but they don't even know all of us have
it but along this way i wasn't like i
said i wanted a theorist i became a
practitioner
and i was like my god i'm busting down
so many barriers of
like i have a learning disability okay
but i'm catching up with everybody i i
figured that out
i figured out all these negative things
in my life that were keeping me
in this hole like i gotta tell people
man that
hang on a second man you can achieve
the absolute impossible i used to hate
people
not liking me one of the hardest things
in the world for me
at a young age was my god i just want to
fit in
i want to fit in i want you like me so
that's a
horrible place to be in life because you
lose yourself
when you want to fit in with people so
badly normal
people no better than you you do
whatever you can to fit in
that's a bad place to be you lose
yourself in trying to create a character
that other people will accept and
the that's where i found a lot of joy
man this is god this is me
i speak in the third person going on i'm
still working on myself
take it or leave me you don't like me
take a number and get in line man
the motivation when people are losing
all these people who come out here and
talk about how great they are and i see
it all the time it makes me sick man
get real with yourself people cannot
relate to you
man you are unrelatable when you come
out here and say hey man
i'm the baddest mother to ever live
okay great well i what am i gonna learn
from you
you learn from people who are willing to
tell you
this is where i started from this is how
much i fell on my
ass this is how bad i used to really be
i still have those moments because why
you're human we're all jacked up man
we're all jacked up and that's what
makes my story relatable
i'm willing to let you in to see i'm
decently successful now
but didn't it come out like this man i
didn't come out
that's the story is you have to give
people just
a little bit of hope there's no hope
when they see greatness in you
everywhere you have to be
able to get yourself down to a level of
check it out man
there's hope for you that's what i'm
trying to give you
just a little bit so what's your [ __ ]
excuse
is it too cold where you live is it too
hot where you live
does it rain too much now it's time for
some real
talk maybe you're the only black person
applying for a [ __ ]
job maybe the only female maybe the only
[ __ ] gay person
job whatever the market may be maybe
that's
in your [ __ ] head maybe that's your
excuse for not being better
life's a real big picture when i was
young
all those things got my head black not
smart enough
single mom all their own space in my
head
if you're allowing people and things and
situations
throwing space in your head you're
losing
last thing life's one big head game
you play with yourself if you lose
it's because you allow life to get in
your head when i got through with that
first hundred mile race
that i did around that one mile track
that i didn't prepare for and i was
considerably it was horrible
and i'll never forget i found
such peace and beauty and i got that i
was in the worst pain in my
life and i got done and my wife pulled
the car up on the my ex-wife
pulled the car up on this little lawn
and i got in the back of it
and i got up the stairs i'm not gonna go
through the whole story but i remember
laying in the
in the tub and she put the shower on me
and i ran 101 miles like 19 hours and i
was like
peeing dirt out of me and i'm sitting
there and i'm i'm
jack hammering and my body is just the
most broken it's ever been
even to this day and this feeling came
over me
call it crazy if you want but very few
people i guarantee you've ever felt this
before
to push themselves so far outside of
what they thought was even possible even
for me
i laid in that tub and i didn't want it
to go away
i had drained myself of every
bit of strength energy i had
and it was the best feeling i had in my
life all that pain it was
it was confirmation it was confirmation
that i had gone through a crucible and i
figured out another level of david
goggins
a level that i thought was humanly
impossible for anybody to do
when i was at mile 70 and pissed all
over myself
it had 30 more miles to go and i was
damn near dead
and i was able to go 31 more miles
in that process of the next 31 more
miles
i found out more about myself and that
31 miles than ever have in my entire
life the conversations
the mental blocks the roadblocks
everything
horrible it was just feeding at me like
light speed
get the out of here man like i was able
to figure out
different tactics and when i finally got
done with that i laid in that tub and it
was over
the feeling of my god man you just
really
discovered a whole new world a whole new
part of the brain that guaranteed very
few people have
so think about when i say suffering
people cringe
people that's the that's the one word
whenever i post about it
people cringe it's not about
suffering how people may look at
suffering like you have to just
go to a place that just every day of
your life is suffering
you have to tap into suffering every day
of your life because we have so
much scarring that we have to clean up
you have to look at suffering as almost
like i look at failure
to succeed you must fail
in failure and in suffering all the
answers
are in there all the answers to all the
test questions the test is your life
all the answers are in there you have to
live in suffering and pain and failure
all the time
you have to learn i need to visit it
like people hate working out
you're only going to visit working out
maybe an hour a day
23 other hours of the day you're not in
it
but how you become in shape is you must
visit
suffering visit working out one hour a
day
visit suffering one hour a day visit
your past failures
one hour a day the relationship with it
is the answers are in there
they they are in there within the
suffering go in there
and i call it the live autopsy the live
autopsy how you find out someone died
they crack you open after you're dead
how you can live
is do it while you're alive go back in
your brain crack it open
while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead
to figure out why you died do it while
you are living
go in there go into the suffering go
into the pain of your life and say why
does this suck for me so bad
why am i afraid of all this stuff why
have i shut down the whole world
i guarantee i'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these
nooks of the suffering within your brain
in the scarring
are all the answers to why you are on
the couch feeling sorry for yourself
they lie within the scars visit them
for at least an hour a day study them
and then you'll find out more about
yourself you will then grow
so don't look at us every day i suffer
go into it an hour a day
learn from yourself learn from life
learn from your failures learn from your
insecurities
learn from your self-doubt don't just
say i'm afraid to jump off an airplane
what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why i studied my mind why i
became so powerful in the mind
because i realized i was weak so instead
of running away from the mind
i dove into and said what is making me
weak oh
this makes sense i came from hell
i came from a place that beat me down to
nothing
which is why i'm afraid all this makes
sense
so systematically one by one i went back
and met every single person in my mind
every situation i went one-on-one with
them again
in my mind it said okay let's
now revisit this and that's how you do
it i'm okay with going on this easy
highway over here
the easy highway has all these signs and
directions how to get somewhere
and you have to first be uncomfortable
with how you feel about yourself
with that voice that a lot of us like to
run away from we all have it
we all have that voice to say hey man
you know you're you're kind of wimping
out right now you're kind of being a
little punk right now
but a lot of us say okay that's okay
it's okay to tell these little white
lies to ourselves
so we first have to face the real you
the real me is david goggins the real me
is a guy looking at you right now saying
i don't want to
be on this show right now because i used
to stutter as a kid
and i'm afraid of that i'm afraid that
here in a second
i'm going to start stammering and
stuttering the whole world is going to
know
that i have all these issues but that's
when i see right now
okay goggins you gotta go on the show
that's goggins goggins is saying okay
david goggins
you're a punk life made you this way we
can't live like this we can't live in
fear we can't live in judgment
we can't be afraid of what the people
right now are looking at me saying about
me
we cannot be afraid of that that's
goggins
god is saying all of you who don't like
me who don't want to
and that person then comes in but you
have to be david goggins and say man i'm
afraid of this
i'm up here life made me this way here
i stutter i i have these issues with
with reading and writing and
and i'm i'm fat and i'm insecure you
have to face that in that dark room
and that dark room is who you are but in
that dark room
is where you have to create another
human being
that walks out of that dark room to face
who you are that's the only way you're
gonna get over
all those things you have to create
someone else
not like you have two different
personalities it is you
but you have to find strength and that
visualization of almost me
cracking out goggins like almost like
that superman cape
like i'm coming out a different person a
person that doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything
who doesn't care about being judged who
knows i'm weak
who knows i'm afraid who says whatever
you think about me
take it whatever i'm here that's goggins
in the dark room you face yourself
you realize you want to be better you
realize you don't want to be this weak
insecure person in the world he has all
these problems that we all have
we all have social media is a great
platform to tell you who
we want to be not who we are what are
the some of the most valuable things you
learned in the navy
be it about yourself or you know what
some of the most valuable things a lot
of people say
teamwork and stuff like that teamwork is
big
but i learned that you have to be a good
individual first
you have to triple down on your
weaknesses
because a lot of times like you always
count on your buddy next to you to help
you out
sometimes that buddy's not going to be
there you got to make sure that you are
a jack of all trades and a master of all
trades
and that's one thing you got you have
your buddies back they can have your
back but you got to work on yourself
every single day i'm not a big guy on
social media
you know i'm just not big on that stuff
even today
i'm just not a big fan of it man i'm a
big uh introvert i get a lot of my
strength from being introverted
and um going out there and doing what i
do is very all this is very difficult
for me man
all of it i don't know what do you have
like 600 000 plus on instagram or
something like that
yeah and for somebody who's you're
averse to it you don't like it you hate
it
you only post once in a while you don't
really
advertise what you're doing at all but
you've grown this huge
following of people who are super
interested in what you're doing well i
think it's important
um to do things you don't like and i am
i was very ashamed of my life story for
a long time
i i i didn't want to go out and tell
anybody [ __ ] about me
so that's why i had two people i you
know i created one david goggins and one
goggins
right and um i didn't want people to
know that i had all these issues
but after a while people start to give
you these different taglines you know
like you're super human you're amazing
they start
i'm like you [ __ ] don't know anything
about me man i'm this
insecure kid i started realizing there's
a lot of people out here who are going
through a lot of problems
that i once tapped into you know i had a
whole bunch of issues growing up
and you know i felt compelled to this
you know what
you gotta start sharing this stuff man
cause people see where you're at today
they see where you're at today they they
see the man you are today this
this hard rock hard human being
show these people where you come from
right as many people as possible
you are pretty good about celebrating
the victories along the way and
celebrating yourself
i talk about with my fiance every single
day
i talked about with her two hours today
i said we are
grinding so hard that we are losing the
vantage point of what we have
accomplished today
we got podcast podcast interview flying
do this
do that i'm like stop stop
it's just me and you in this mom-and-pop
thing that we
that we're doing look at where the [ __ ]
this book is at right now
it's crazy look how many people were
touching shut shut up
and just think for a second let's let's
stop because all we did was talk about
this and this week
i don't know enjoy this for a second
let's we we have to take time
and realize what we've accomplished here
that's an evolution for you man huge
huge but that's a very different david
goggins than even from
a couple of years ago huge because you
have to what is it all about
i'm gonna keep on grinding that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying though
is
you have to respect what you've done
take a second not live in it not sit
around and say i'm good
sit back and say let me look at the
vantage point now that i'm at
we when the that's why you reset the
vantage point
get the tactical advantage if you get
the tactical advantage too quick
and start fighting you got to take a
second to
take observation of where where i'm at
what have i done
am i in the right spot i'm obviously in
the right spot right now
now we can go back to fighting i get a
lot of questions about how i lost so
much weight
people want to know how they can get
started so basically
you're thinking too much off the bat
when i lost my
weight i didn't look for a trainer i
didn't do all that thinking
i didn't go on jenny craig i didn't do
all that
what i do is i basically stop eating so
much food
i cut my calories down so as far as the
workout goes
we overthink that also until you find a
trainer
go out there and start walking put some
shoes on start running
go to the gym do the elliptical trainer
it's not rocket science
a lot of folks talk about over training
you gotta train first
before you can over train sometimes you
wake up in the morning time and you're
sore
and you feel like you're over trained no
you got sore [ __ ] legs
get out of your own head and stop
overthinking it
the world is so fast-paced the word is
so noisy
so my conversation now a lot of times is
my god
slow down the world can take you
here here be here be there be everywhere
and i lose myself sometimes so i catch
myself in the airport i catch myself in
the playing around writing stuff down
okay
remember this remember that like hey
hang on a second goggles what got you
here
this isn't what got you here slow the f
down go back to the quiet place of that
dirty mirror
in that seven dollar a month place you
used to live in
that's where you grew you so i so that's
what i'm constantly reminding myself
go back to your roots i'm not saying go
back
to hell but i'm saying don't forget
where you come from as you start to
explode out of the gate when you become
someone
my conversation is do not forget
your roots do not forget your roots
don't let this become so big that you
lose yourself
amongst the noise go back to the
quietness
of what made you successful i write down
my day
and what i do is i go back and study
that day like sometimes i might
i might get sick i might be over trained
i might um
gain a couple pounds here i might feel
whatever
that and i it's like my accountability
journal
of what i'm doing with my life physical
mental
um i had a eating journal all this
and helps me go back to once again study
i'm a lab rat
and i study myself and i'm like when i'm
feeling
i go okay what i do last week and
usually i can find out
where i messed up last week you know how
much i'm traveling how much i'm sleeping
how much i'm doing all this stuff and
and through journaling man you can
really figure out so much
about where you're messing up in life
and what you need to fix
about yourself taking constant inventory
costing honest about that
and that's thing about you cannot put in
there yeah it's gotta be a real
a real journal about hey today i messed
up here
today i should have been a better person
here and not just saying it
but actually trying to fix it tomorrow
well i sat back and i had the top five
people come at me top five publishing
houses
and it was down to the last two and
they're offering 300 000 on my first
time
you know first-time author and i decided
to go with one of them
and three hundred thousand dollars for a
guy at me i'm sitting back no that's
pretty good money
so a few days before i was going to sign
the contract
i sat back talked to my fiance my family
and everybody's like you know
hey you know this is good this is great
whatever
um but
i started thinking about my life i
started thinking about
everything that i've gone through my
life everything i had gone through
and had a chance to reflect and that's
one thing i never did in my life
long enough is have time to reflect i
was always
what's next what's next what's next
what's next what's next
now that i'm retired and you have a lot
of time to look back
on what you've done where you started
where you're at now
and i said you know what it's just not
for sale
300 000 isn't even a fraction of enough
money
to sell this so i decided not to sign it
and
i self-published i pissed a lot of
people off
and i said i'm not signing this i'm
going to self-publish and
that's kind of how it came to be i took
that time to reflect and i'd rather not
make a dime
i wrote this book and that's honest to
god's truth um
i i am fine with the trophy i have in my
mind
don't do everything in your life for
money
don't do everything yes we needed to
survive
there's a great drive and passion behind
doing things
for the mind and the soul there's a
great drive in that everybody's man
you talk with such passion this is a
life
this is my life so that's so that's what
i want people to get from all this stuff
man like
there's something inside you the the
brain is the most powerful thing the
mind's most powerful thing that we have
it's not your phone it's not the
computer it's not anything it's your
mind
and if you can tap into that you can
come from the
from the daggone roots of hell
and become such a great seed
a powerful seed that can grow into some
great daggone garden
and people don't get that it's all up
here and if you don't believe that
you're here for a reason
your life will seriously hurt and i
started looking at my life and all that
i went through
as god put me some god whatever you
believe and put me here
to go through this and now i see all the
hundreds of thousands of lives i'm
changing
by the hell i went through there's a lot
of power in that
so my purpose as i started going through
this journey
instead of looking at like what was me
god man why why the man why
why i started looking as it's the
perfect training ground
you knew exactly what you were doing you
know exactly what
you were doing obviously you put me in
every situation possible
to tell a story that needs to be told so
i get an email the other day this young
man wants to be a ranger
but he's afraid to go to ranger school
not because how hard the training is
but because he's afraid if he fails
what people are going to say by judging
them
one thing in life this applies to
everything in life
anytime you move from being normal to
trying to be exceptional
people aren't going to like that those
normal people
it makes them feel like they're gonna
judge you and nowadays
it's very easy to be a coward why
we got instagram most folks don't tell
you to your face
they go online they post about like
cowards
don't let cows get in your head and last
day
make sure you do you i i came home one
night from work
spraying for cockroaches and
um long story short i turned on the um
discovery channel
i saw some guys going to navy seal
training and
they're going through hell week and
they're getting their ass just beat you
know
in and out of the water guys ringing the
bell
um there's suffering and i was weighing
like 297 pounds
and i had to make a change in my life
you know
i was at all-time low and i wasn't going
anywhere
and i was exactly what everybody said i
was going to be which was nothing
so i had to make a change what was it
about seeing suffering that's
that's really interesting and i actually
get it but i want to hear you explain it
why suffering was the thing that
triggered that thought
well for me growing up i came from a
horrible background
i got called [ __ ] every day of my life
growing up um lived in a small town
the clan headquarters at that time was
about
um 20 minutes from where i lived
the uh one of the high ups in the kkk
son sat behind me in two classes so you
called me [ __ ] all the time
i got my first car they spray printed
[ __ ] we're gonna kill you on it
so i was just an insecure scared kid
and the only way i could find myself
was to put myself through the worst
thing possible because i'm going to say
the exact opposite of what the world
today's world is saying so we read a
bunch of books nowadays
as humans we we want to find out how to
be
someone else what we don't do is we
don't go
inside so literally turn yourself inside
out
read the book that says like we're
writing a book every day of our life
every day we're seeing who we are as
people when i was growing up
i i lied for people to accept me because
i didn't accept myself
so i would make up stories so then you
would accept me into your world
i would uh everything i did was for
someone else to like me
it wasn't until i started reading my own
book about how pathetic i was as a human
being
i can blame my dad i can blame kids at
school i could blame having
health issues atd my mom not being
around great mom but she was doing her
thing
right i could blame a lot of people and
that's the book i was reading
and i put it off on everybody else it
wasn't until i said you know what
for me to fix this i gotta read what the
hell what
is wrong with david goggins not blame
anybody read my books okay
i'm afraid of my shadow how can i
overcome that
go in the military get your ass kicked
do things you hate to do
be uncomfortable every day of your life
roger that
i'm not the smartest kid in the world
okay
is there somebody saying oh no you're
smart no no don't say that to yourself
i said to myself no i'm a dumb mother
okay roger that
how you get smarter educate yourself
so the things that we run from we're
running from the truth
we're running from the truth man so the
only way i became
successful was going towards the truth
as painful and as brutal as it is
it changed me it it allowed me to become
in my own right who i am today i never
set out to write a book when i was in
the dungeon and no one was coming back
to help me
i just wanted that reflection in that
accountability mirror that i hated so
badly
to be something that gave me pride to be
something that made me feel it wasn't
it's not about money it's not about
success it's not about people oh my god
that's david goggins
sign my book no when i started this
journey out years ago
it's about i just want to learn to read
so now i'm at a place now
where i see the possibilities of the
human
of human potential what are we capable
of is the conversation now
the conversation now is how can i now
talk to people
in a way they can understand the message
that i have for so many people
for so many people so that's the that's
the new conversation now is that i
you are constantly evolving you never
stay
either you're getting better you're
getting worse not staying the same
so for me i have to constantly be
getting better i could constantly be
evolving my message so
i'm constantly thinking in the quietness
of my mind
honestly my my biggest fear to this day
is um and i say it a lot and i say a lot
and
it's it's going to heaven
and being judged by god and
you know god has i believe that god has
this
knows everything about you from time
you're born
when you're gonna be born when you're
gonna die when you're gonna graduate
buzz whatever's gonna happen to you he
knows all this
some people never do what god
knows you're capable of doing because
you keep getting you know we have
choices
my biggest fear in life was to was to
get to heaven and god look at me
as i'm being judged and i was some fat
300 pound guy like i used to be that
still sprayed for cockroaches it was a
car
you know that's that's okay it's what
you want to do i didn't want to do that
and i made a thousand dollars you know a
month and i got to heaven and god
laid out this chart in front of me and
they said hey man
look at this chart and it had my name on
top and all this amazing
i'm like that's not that's not me man he
goes
that's who you were supposed to be my
biggest fear in life is that one day if
i ever get judged
by something someone some some energy
force
that go up there and i failed the
mission whatever
whatever force up there thought i was
supposed to be some badass
and i went up there underachieved you
know i want that force up there
that knows everything to be writing as
i'm living and saying i had no
idea he even had this in him so i want
to just be
the best i can and a lot of people say
that
i truly mean that and what is it that
you have to learn
i still learn me you know i i still feel
there's you know there's times where
as a human being i'm a human and
you you still fall back in these in
these ruts of life
where you think that you had a permanent
fix because i'd done all that
i realized it's not about money it's not
about fame it's not about
being accepted by your peers and
everybody else it's about figuring out
who i am and being happy with who the i
am
even though i'm going to be judged for
all these things being able to put a
middle finger up
to everybody and say this is david
goggins
and to get to that point it felt great
david
tell them about the cookie jar the
cookie jar it's something i invented
as you all know your mom has a cookie
jar and sometimes you might have an oreo
sometimes you might have a chips ahoy
sometimes you might have a oatmeal
raisin cookie you never know
it's just in there my cookie jar
has every single failure and success
of my life except i overcame so what
happens in this in time of life when
you're stressed out and things get bad
even the hardest guy in the world
me everybody thinks and i think i'm the
hardest guy in the world
you gotta believe that you gotta believe
you are something
i will in my mind reach into my cookie
jar
and sometimes you forget how hard you
are in times of of need
you because you're you're stressed but
you forget i'm a
navy seal i'm a ranger i'm this and that
but you forget all that because your
life sucks i calm down take that one
second
get control of my life
[Applause]
reaching the cookie jar
well you got called [ __ ] your whole
life and you're now the only person in
history do this this and this
put it back in the cookie jar reset my
mind you have to remind yourself of how
badass you really are
in times of need that's the cookie jar
so many of us are on cruise control
myself included and we get into our
daily routine and routines are
unbelievable but routines can also be a
rut
only if you really challenge yourself
and push yourself and get out of
your routine your comfort zone can you
get better like you can't improve
when you're on autopilot so you have to
set goals
and you have to set um challenges that
you don't necessarily think you can do
or going to push yourself way further
than you think you can
to improve so you got to get out of the
complacency of the routine
the whole thing about comfort zones is
if you live in one for too long
that becomes your norm it never allows
you to gain experience gain knowledge
gain
any kind of mental toughness well i
learned that we all have a reserve tank
that we're all capable of doing so much
more than we think we can
and only by really tapping into that
reserve tank whether it's in business
whether it's in physically you want to
get more fit
only when you really push yourself and
push your limits
can you find out what you're really made
of and what's in your reserve tank and i
mean he taught me that every single day
and it just led to me getting better in
the various buckets in my life as i
tapped into that reserve tank
yeah i think i said don't be you know we
call it the 40
rule that's something that david uh kind
of told me and shared with me
and i bought into it and it's but it's
proved effective not just in working out
but even in
business or my family life it's like
when i'm frustrated when i'm done
when i hit a roadblock when things get
complicated
you have so much more in you people are
saying man you cuss all the
time why well i hate to say it the best
way for me to get how i feel across
i can't sit here and say you know what
yeah i went through hell weekend man it
was it was really hard
no that takes your damn soul
rips it inside out and then they say
now we're going to start
it it allows me to express
where i was at at a point of my life
if i don't give you all of me why the
hell am i here
why how will you learn from me people
take so much offense to me
you will never learn from people if we
always tap dance around the truth
oh god i love that we tap dance around
the truth by
finding the right word so i don't hurt
you because you have thin skin
no tighten up people it's okay
trust me it's okay you might be called
[ __ ] one day
it's okay you might be called some
jewish word or some
[ __ ] or gay word it's okay let them
call you that
what are you going to do now they don't
own your life how are you going to
control that now
how are you going to flip it upside down
and say roger that
now i'm going to harness this and you'll
read about me years from now
how that's the question how are you
going to do that
thicken your skin become more of a human
being don't be afraid
of the reflection in the mirror because
that's all you can be afraid of
once you overcome the reflection in the
mirror
you've done it i literally broke all the
metatarsals
in my feet stress fractures shin splints
everything the pain going with my body
i've been through
every training on the man ranger school
held week three times all kind of stuff
this event i'm explaining to you right
now enough time to explain to you in
detail
was the worst thing i've done in my
entire life pain wise this is when i
realized human being is capable of going
to limits unknown
to most people this is where hardness
comes in
people can read a book on hardness and
tell you about mental toughness and
hardness
but until you put your body through
hardness and realize that there's walls
and doors you must break through
and once you break through them you are
amazing and your body resets
but we are scared to get to that wall
because that wall says what
stop right but every wall has a what
a door you got to get that key from your
pocket and don't be scared to see
someone else at the door
i would like to know when you're in that
moment
failing and you
have to keep going what do you say
to yourself what if
a lot of times i'll be in a 200 mile run
or something like that
and i'm all jacked up body's broken
mind's broken spirit's broken
i start to say what if i can pull this
off when i first walked into the navy
seal recruiter's office
he looked at me and said there's only
been 35 african-americans in 70 years
make it through
you know i said to myself what if i can
be the 36th
it's the what if i can pull off a
miracle
what if i can become someone that no one
thinks i can be
and just that just me talking about that
i have the hair going up on my arms
because it makes me just like what if
i can be that guy that people who call
[ __ ] and this and that
and now i'm speaking at tom ferry's
[ __ ] event
what if that's it the first ultra
marathon wasn't smart at all
at all um just so basically what
happened was
i was at military free fall school with
morgan latrell
marcus cettrell if you guys don't know
was the lone survivor the guy
he um was in a bad op off went bad he
was the only navy still that lived
long story short got to get the book
read loan survivor great story
morgan is marcus charles twin brother
and i was there with marcus
so what happened was myself and morgan
were in free fall school
at the same exact time marcus was
in the worst incident in still history
so i knew
that marcus might be dead he wasn't dead
everybody else was dead
so i actually brought more you know i
actually told morgan hey man
your brother wasn't a bad incident i
don't know if he's alive i don't know
what's going on
long story short marcus is alive and i
go on to
want to raise money for families all
these guys died they all had kids
i want to raise money for the special
operations warrior foundation
it's a foundation where 100 tuition goes
to these kids to go to college you know
full tuition
whatever so i found this great
foundation i'm gonna raise money for it
so i said you know what i have to google
something that's that's evil something
very hard
i knew nothing about ultra marathons i
hadn't even run a marathon
i knew nothing about this world so i
googled that
you know the top 10 hardest races in the
world and what comes up is a bad water
135.
so 135 mile race through death valley in
the summertime
i thought it was a stage race i thought
it was a race where you run like
20 miles set up camp you know
barbecue outside and then go run some
more the next day
so i called the race director up at the
race and said hey chris his name is
chris costman
i want to do your race so we had a long
conversation you know i was i was much
heavier then
and i hadn't put running shoes on over a
year how heavy are you at this point
i'm around between 240 to 270. whoa
i'm in there i'm in that ranch i've my
weight has buried a lot through the seal
teams and out of this hill team so
i was a heavy guy but the long and short
of it all was
i hadn't put running shoes on in over a
year i was a big time power lifter
i lift their weights heavy that's what i
did right i just got back home from iraq
went straight to free fall school and
then this happened
so i called chris kosman up on a
wednesday he says look man
the only way you can qualify for my race
is to run 100 miles
at one time in 24 hours or less
there happened to be a race that
saturday
so four days later and he said if you
qualify
by running a hundred miles or less in 24
hours i will consider you my race
i'm gonna cut to the chase i signed up
for this race it's called a san diego
one day
where you run around a one-mile track
for 24 hours to see many miles you can
get
my goal was 100 miles so
i got to mile 70 and i cleared 70 miles
in like 12-13 hours pretty quickly
but i was done my feet were broken i was
stretch fractures shin splints muscles
were tearing
i was in bad shape i was eating ritz
crackers and drinking bioclips
that's all i had no water didn't know
what the hell i was doing out there
had on some tube socks it was just
ridiculous it was it was a clown show
so i sat down at mile 70 and at this
time i was married
and i i looked at my wife and i was like
um
i'm i'm messed up bad so
i literally start to turn white and when
a black guy turns white you're pretty
so here i am i'm off in this chair
i'm at mile 70. they got 35 miles to go
i'm jacked up
i got to go to the bathroom and the
bathroom's like 20 feet from me it's a
porta potty
i can't get out of the chair so i'm
peeing blood down my leg whoa
pooping up my [ __ ] back and i got 30
miles to go
and i'm i can't stand up because my my
blood pressure's all messed up i've been
in three hell weeks
ranger school overcome so many obstacles
in my life
this last 30 miles of this race is when
i realized
a human being is not so human anymore
we have the ability to go in such a
space
if you're willing to suffer and i mean
suffer your brain
and your body once connected together
can do anything
and this 30 miles was the life-changing
moment
i was out of it i was in the worst pain
in my entire life
i was to me on the brink of death
and i was able to chunk this 30 damn
miles
into small pieces i was so driven and
i'm not going to say motivated because
motivation is crap
motivation comes and goes when you're
driven
whatever's in front of you will get
destroyed
so i sat in this chair and i was so
driven
to succeed in this race and at this time
everybody goes were you thinking about
the guys that died and
i'm not gonna lie to you i wasn't this
became
a personal thing this became me
against this race me against the kids
that called me [ __ ] me against me
it it it just became something that i
took so
so violently personal and
i broke this thing down into small
pieces i said okay i gotta get nutrition
i gotta be able to stand up before i can
get off this curb and get off this chair
and be able to go 30 miles
so i went through all these small steps
and i was able to stand up
and then from staying up i was literally
walking around
with my wife at the time and she goes
you're not going to make the time she
goes you're running
you're walking like 30 some minute miles
i got to my 81
and the second she said that i'm not
gonna make the time i ran the last 19
miles
non-stop and i can show you right now
when we get done with this
matter of fact i'm going to show you
right now this was years ago
and i had to put compression tape
on my ankle and i had so this was years
ago
i had literally the size of half dollars
i had to get compression tape and i
taped up my ankles
and i taped up my feet and that's how i
got through that race
it was like a hematoma i mean what do we
know see what happened was
like my shins hurt so bad from having
stretch fractures
that the only way i can continue on was
i taped it so i wasn't doing the flexor
motion that that
activates your your shins so
i taped my ankles and my shins up and i
got that from
because in my third hell week they won't
let me go back through you know train
anymore right
so i literally went through all the buds
my last seal training with stretch
fractures and shin splints and how i did
it
was i would take my ankles all the way
up to my calf every morning so for the
first
hour the pain was excruciating but what
happened is
my feet would go numb and i did that
every single
day for six months whoa
and that's how i got through my third
hell because i was so broken
from the first two that the commander
said hey
the ceo said this your last time or
sending you through so that's how i got
the idea
to do that so with the right and people
may listen to this and say this guy is
sadistic he's crazy he's
no if you know how i came up you realize
i was just
a scared kid that found drive and
passion to be something
much better than what he thought he was
self-talk
and visualization are two keys to my
success
i believed for that last time 19 miles
i was indestructible because i took
myself in that chair
crapping up my back peeing blood on my
leg shin splint stretch fractures
i use all that for motivation versus
negativity
i use it for motivation i i said to
myself who on this
earth would still be going right now
you are you are
you got to be the hardest mother on the
planet is it true
i don't give at that time
right it got me to the finish line of
that [ __ ] race
i believed it i believe it today i
believed it
enough to where my body said he's not
going to stop
and that's i took all the negative
things
i need to go to the hospital this and
that and i use uh who the hell
could even get on that chair you did who
the hell would even think about
taping stress fractures up you did
all those things i used for motivation
but routines can also be a rut
what's the point of living you know a
lot of us go through our daily day
routine
kiss the wife kiss the husband whatever
you're doing and that's our life
you know i believe everybody's put on
this earth for a journey
and everybody's journey is different but
most people don't
you know take their journey they they
try and take an easier path
so that's what it's all about you got to
accept your journey and a lot of times
your journey sucks but
that's what you got to do it's always
about giving back you know god gave me a
gift
you know a gift to kind of achieve what
i need to achieve
you know a strong mind and if i can kind
of relay that message you know to these
young kids
young young men and women it's just uh
having these events around
it's just it just helps them out helps
them grow kids need mentors nowadays
yes and and to hear a positive message
from people who
don't have much to know that hey i can
do it yes
that's what it's all about you don't
need much to you know become a lot i
started doing this
triathlons and endurance sports ultra
runs just to test
my soul to see what i'm about to see in
150 mile race
at mile 75 when i feel really bad
that's when you know that's the only
time you can find out
what the human body is all about what
you're made of to find out
limits to myself limits to the human
soul
and every day i'm trying to see if i
have limits
i run anywhere from 125 150 in a week
so i'll try and put in about 450 miles a
month
usually every day i wake up at 3 o'clock
in the morning and i run anywhere from
10 to 15 miles in the morning
and then i i live about 25 miles from
work
so i i get my bicycle commute into work
do a normal work day at lunchtime around
noon i'll run again anywhere from
five to eight miles whatever maybe come
back work
and around 5 30 i'll ride back home 25
miles on my bike
if i'm feeling good and when i get more
miles i'll get off the bike
and do like a short three or four or
five mile run
that's my everyday life so i don't just
train like an hour or so
i train until something is uncomfortable
and then naturally know who you are
[Music]
the only easy day was yesterday it just
never ends
i mean i've done some races where you're
on a one-mile track
and you're running for 48 hours straight
so imagine running 48 hours running one
mile track
and it's not like you're sleeping you're
you're running for 48 hours
how many miles you can get i want to
talk about mine torture
[Music]
my life doesn't have a finish line so
when i cross the finish line of the iron
man
it doesn't matter because i know that
you know two or three weeks from now
i'll be doing something else to put my
body through more pain
[Music]
i believe you know everything i try to
do is kind of defined by excellence
but i don't think i ever reach
excellence myself because i have my
standards of my life are really high
so i don't ever reach it but i try to
every day
you have to be a good individual first
before you can be a good team player
i know for a fact how bad hell we get i
i went through it a couple times
it's probably the most brutal like
brutal military training anybody can go
through
so everybody to my left and everybody to
my right they've been through this so i
know
mentally you know these individuals are
extremely hard
and when stuff gets bad and you know
in any situation i know these guys have
my back
i've done a lot of things i thought were
impossible nothing's impossible anymore
my family cream to swim yeah you know
what i'm saying i mean
we had little athletes in my damn family
and um
and i was a kid who kind of got the kind
of like the the bad genes
you know i have all these little sickly
issues all these allergic to
it i was a little sickly kid and it's
funny how when people hear my story now
they want to put a title on me
like um i'm super human yeah like you
had some special
capability and i love it because
basically it makes you feel better
by putting a title on me right you can
do it too
that's right right and so basically
choice yeah it's a choice yeah
it's a horrible choice right it's a hard
choice it's a lot of suffering involved
so for me to get the start line
through that start line journey i
realized
i'm capable so what happens to this
whole process is the change of the mind
it's a change of the guard someone once
owned my brain
i never owned it yeah i never had no i
had no control
out you outsourced it that's right
everybody had it it was my dad's fault
it was the kids that called me nigger's
fault my mom wasn't home fault
my soon-to-be step-dad's fault the
little kids that get rid of by the bus
fault
my life was everybody had a piece of my
frame
and through this journey of suffering
and the suffering i put it in
because i started finding myself yeah i
started oh no i'm taking something back
from me this part of my brain is mine
now
i start puzzling back this piece of my
brain
and through that i grew confidence in
this process i went from david goggins i
started
forming a guy named goggins i had to
really
invent i realized i had to reinvent a
whole nother human being right
within myself because who i am wasn't
going to make it this is not this guy is
not going to cut it
so he i'd be a guy who can take any kind
of pain
any kind of suffering any kind of
torture mentally physically emotionally
spiritually
i had to have the people who i
everybody that called me [ __ ] you had
to be in a room of people like this
i had to make up these things in my mind
of things i had to overcome
and i started callous in my mind do it
through a process and it based on it
with working out it started with working
out i started with doing
like if it started raining outside for
instance
my mind would say that man i'm gonna go
run
if it was three o'clock in the morning
start raining outside my mind said
you gotta go get up and go around you
have to because i was fighting this
other person so you essentially
tried to do everything you didn't want
to do that's all it was period
everything i didn't want to do is what
got me to where i'm at today
interesting every single thing so where
we find comfort
yeah that's where i started getting
scared yeah when i started saying oh
it's raining i'm not going out there
no you cannot say that you cannot do
that
you you have got to do this the other so
whatever my brain thought i did the
opposite
where the comfort wasn't with the
opposite direction and over a period of
time
boy it callouses out of your mind
you start to really develop a whole
another being
i say what if a lot it sounds corny and
it sounds weak
but it's true one of the recruiters
said there's not many black navy
salesmen in fact i was a 36 african
american seal in history
it's in over 70 years because water you
know
right i mean people get mad at me and
truly just get over it
and so i was like man
what story would it be if my fat dumb
lying to be friends with people insecure
ass
can overcome the and that what if
mentality like
that that dreamer mentality just would
always fuel me
it was just true man what if i can be
what if i can be a seal man
what if i can go from where in a quarter
mile now and i run 205 miles
what if i can go but just what if i can
go in and and what if
how would that feel if i'm graduating
can i get at the graduation thing i was
talking about 2 24 that
like the video i sat down and watched
this command officer stood up and he
said
to the graduation guys who are
graduating buds like 18 of them
he said we live in a society where
mediocrity is often rewarded
and he went on to say something about
these men detest mediocrity
and i wanted to be a man that detests
mediocrity
my biggest advice to give everybody in
the world is like i say
we live in an external world everything
is is
you got to see it touch it it's external
if you can for the rest of your life
live inside of yourself stop listening
to people who are calling you fat
gay transsexual [ __ ] everything that
is makes no sense
all these insecure people putting their
insecurities on you you got to flush it
out
you got to just be whoever the hell god
or whatever the hell you believe in if
you believe in nothing but yourself i
don't care what it is
you got to take everything and throw it
away
you have to believe in one thing and
that is yourself
and and i'm not saying don't believe in
god or what you believe in but
right now for you to find greatness in
yourself
you're not going to find it by looking
in a book
or by even hearing me i may give you the
spark
but you've got to go inside yourself to
find it and that means you gotta be
quiet
shut the [ __ ] up go in a room stop
talking
search your soul search your mind search
your
abilities and you'll find it but if
you're not looking for it
you won't find it so you got to go start
your journey
and the journey starts you finding why
the hell am i here on this planet earth
why am i here and if you don't know that
you will live the rest of your life
searching always asking the question why
as a leader the one thing i did horribly
wrong
on my second platoon i actually um
started developing an attitude towards
people who didn't peek too hard
who didn't get after who worked because
i know i i took it all the way to the
limit
and so i should have been a better
leader by no one okay no not everyone
wants to be david goggins yeah everybody
wants to go 100 miles everybody
everyone's got different everybody's got
different skill sets
and you know right you know maybe you
know when i go to the gym
whatever the gym is fine but it was just
a different standard
so i couldn't take away my standard for
the
whole of the group interesting i looked
at people i [ __ ] you man
you know yeah you ain't trying to get
hard so my mentality i wasn't a good
leader
and i look back on that now trust me a
lot of people get done things
differently i'm taking accountability
for i could have done differently i
looked at that
so my mentality from a weak kid became
super hard
like beyond hard next level hard and um
but that's what i was getting myself
into as a leader i should have stepped
back and was hey
these are your expectations david
goggins right
what are we here to accomplish right
it's important to lead by example
and when i say lead by example if you're
the leader it's the loneliest job on the
planet
and if you do it you have to be up early
you have to leave late you got to do the
sucky jobs at least that's how i look at
it
you got to be the man that is is is
always the person
who's being held accountable to the
highest standard and not expecting your
people to do anything that you're not
going to do
20 times more than they are even when
even when you're the leader
mm-hmm and and i and it's it's all about
accountability for yourself in
leadership roles not about
being pissed because people aren't doing
what you're doing
when you think that you are done you're
only 40
into what your body's capable of doing
and that's just the limits that that we
put on ourselves
got our leader of the 150 mile coming in
mr david
you never really know how i feel i never
really tell you the truth
i'm always going to feel good he's the
person i want to feel
and show you no weakness congratulations
thanks a lot man 150 mile champion first
place new course record
way to go congratulations i'm never
happy and satisfied with
one thing i do it's always a continuous
journey and in all my races
there's never end they just kind of fall
in together it's like one big journey
that
that won't end ty die growing up being
the kid i was i found
strength in different movies yeah so i
come home in one movie i found a lot of
strength as funny as it may seem but i
visualized this scene
i do it today during the pull-up record
i did 4030 pull-ups
the last time i did it actually got it
took me three times i played one song
for 17 hours pretty much it's from this
movie
rocky one round 14. i related
to the person in the movie but just the
one scene
when apollo is beating out of rocky he
falls in the corner
and everybody in rocky and paul turns
around arms up happy
i i got this guy he turns around not
knowing that rocky is trying to get up
off the canvas mickey's saying
mickey's his trainer saying stay down
everybody's saying you did good
you did good you had 14 rounds with with
the champ
rocking in here he got up and was fixing
my mind today still
and i've seen it right now when he got
up apollo starts to turn around
to see the aftermath of what the [ __ ] he
just destroyed
and he did not expect to see what he saw
right and
what i see are the whole movie i see
apollo creed's face
yeah fear crept in yes and i said to
myself as a young kid
i want to be that
i don't need to win i don't need
trophies i don't need people to
like me i just want what he has yeah
a fictional character whatever the hell
was
i want that and i visualize that
and i want you to become the guy who can
get off the canvas
and look at somebody who beat the [ __ ]
out of him life
yeah it's about life right now
in life even life itself pushed her head
down towards david
yeah this is not going to stop right
so that mentality became
what i wanted nice and that's how
it started with that visualization of
the canvas
and all i got to do is just keep getting
up this different mindset i turned
negatives into positives
so i would i would take like who who
would even think about doing this so i
would sit my couch saying
who at 297 who can't swim that great
who's scared of the
water would have the balls clear the
balls to
man up quit a job and go and put
everything on himself so it's how i
started talking to myself
and putting myself in a whole different
category and that would fuel me the next
day and i just kept using that as fuel
and fuel no one would do that no one
would do it
you're the best around you're the best
ever live
and i had kept fueling me with the with
the right kind of message
that i needed to hear that i was never
telling myself and through time
it became reality to myself
so you start out on the first day and
then
do you start running again the second
day yeah the second day went right back
after it again
but i started realizing i can't run that
far right so what i did was i became
damn near a professional cyclist with
the miles i put on the bike
so i never whenever i watched tv
i had to be doing something so i was
riding the bike i rode a bike a lot
to to lose the first initial kind of
weight because my bones were just
hurting so bad my body was broken
and i learned to get over that also and
i tried to swim a lot i went a great
swimmer but putting fins on
kind of equalized my body i wasn't so
negative buoyant so i started
fitting a whole bunch and i spent hours
in the pool
hours in the pool trying to get more and
more comfortable not because i was going
underwater
i was so scared of the water that i had
to live in the water
i had to become one with the water so
going to the pool used to scare me
so i went to the pool an awful awful lot
and then the bike got easier i was able
to run more
i went from like one mile one mile was a
great accomplishment
two miles and then from two to three was
a big one then i went from three to six
and then like they have a warning order
that they give people to get ready for
buds
and the whole thing was running six
miles five days a week
and that was my goal and so i just kept
i failed i go back to scratch i used
some
positive motivation i had like one day
without that getting defeated
but i started realizing this is part of
the process this is part of the journey
i had to realize this is part of my
process
versus just saying like i used to i'm
just not good enough
if i'm not good enough we always say
that it's not good enough and then we
try something else
i'm gonna make myself good enough and
that became my mentality i wanna
i'm gonna make myself good enough and so
i misunderstood a lot
but that's that's all it came down to i
made myself good enough
and the days i couldn't run that far the
next week
i would do two a days so like on the
running
if i ran a quarter a mile i waited a
couple hours it'd haunt me bother me
i tried to run a half mile next time
same day
you can do more than this if i had to
walk i had to walk it just became just a
process of
grinding and grinding and grinding not
even a good word for it
it's not even a good word for it and
just
just going further and further and then
when i got through running i go to the
bike
i go to the pool if i got tired
somewhere my legs retired
i go to the gym and i developed this
crazy workout where i was doing
volume like two three hundred reps
of like very light weight people say hey
you know how come you don't have any
like
loose skin my workout routine in the gym
became
sick it became sick i was just doing two
300 reps 400 reps
on like chest just like for one simple
exercise
the bench press and i rack it get back
on it just rep it out
trying to burn as many calories i can
build that muscle mass and i just became
just became obsessed with it you once
said that if you were growing up in this
generation that you would have a field
day because you would take their souls
what did you mean by that the younger
generation quits
not everybody so i gotta i gotta put
that people get their butt hurt
so not everybody most of this generation
quits the second
they get talked to you did this wrong
you did this wrong
or they get yelled at it's so easy to
you know to be great nowadays
because everybody else is most people
are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness
any any ability do you have any fraction
of self-discipline the ability to
not want to do it but still do it people
have a hard
thing understand i hate to run and what
makes me so crazy it doesn't need more
is
people well why do you run if you hate
it what are you talking about
i don't want to take showers and eat
either i hate that too
the whole that's a life man
and and it it wasn't until i changed
that mentality
that i became somebody i hated going to
school so guess what i was dumbest
that's what one plus one is two
but if you can get through to doing
things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness that's
what people understand
by me running i am callous in my mind
i'm not training for a race i'm training
for life
i'm training for the time when i get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life
i don't fall apart i'm training my mind
and my body my spirit so it's all one
so i can handle what life is gonna throw
at me because the life i've lived
it throws a whole bunch at you and if
you're not physically immensely prepared
for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody talk to me about what it
takes
to be on one side of a door in iraq or
anywhere knowing on the other side of
the door people who are not afraid of
you
they're ready for you to come in and you
still have and they have guns
and you still have to breach that door
that's that's a great question
it that's a very scary situation
when you are on one side of the door
and your mind is racing because on the
other side of that door
it could be no one it could be four guys
with four ak-47s
that that door you're about to open
could be booby-trapped
so once you open it boom your legs are
gone so
there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy
second guy third guy getting ready to go
in a room
and flood it and that's why i talk about
the warrior mentality
and that's why so many people are lost
when i start talking
you have the right
you're lucky that you don't have to
think
like warriors think you're very
privileged i chose this world
to be a warrior and i would choose it
again if i came back to this world
but the mentality of a warrior is very
different than normal mentality
you must be that person on that door oh
get ready to open it thinking to
yourself
if i die so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
knowing there's a great
chance you're going to die it's like
being a seal you train with live ammo
you jump out of airplanes everything you
do
you could die so to be a warrior
why people don't understand me i'm glad
you don't understand me
merry christmas good on you because
being a warrior takes a whole different
mindset
a whole different mindset to know that
there's a great chance i may not
beat him like i was in for 21 years i'm
lucky
i'm very lucky that i'm alive able to
talk to you able to still run
but when you sign up on that dialogue to
be a like a seal
your mentality changes i may not live
you gotta accept that and that's the
mentality you have
and that's what makes you a warrior if
you're scared to die you're a bad
warrior i hated jumping out of airplanes
i hated shooting guns i hated the job as
a navy seal
but i did it because i wanted to change
myself everything i do i'm not really
comfortable
doing but if you choose
to go that route to go be a navy seal
you might as well go be the hardest in
the world because if you're choosing to
do something you have two routes you can
go there and be a little
a little weak person and get through
barely and that's your reputation
or you can go through the hardest guy
you can possibly be that's your
reputation
so my whole thing is if you're going to
choose to open that door in iraq or
afghanistan
open them up and go in hard because
they're going to remember you
by slowly opening it and peeking in
so if you're going to open it and you
made the mind open it
don't crack it open open the door go in
that's with life
if you're choosing to do if you're
choosing to do something attack it
because they're going to remember you as
not attacking it
so i want to be remembered you can hate
me but one thing you can't say about me
i didn't attack it so that's the
mentality you have if you're gonna do
something you might as well attack it
because you can do it anyway
right do you use that in civilian life
like do you still
employ the i'm going to attack it i'm
going to take their souls like how does
that play out in a non-um
combat zone it still works for me
in in life as far as attacking things
because uh
no matter what i want to you know no
matter what avenue i choose
i want to be the very best and the very
best may not
be i'm number one the very best is
did i leave everything inside of me
out there so attacking is not like oh i
want to win this or win that or be the
best
the best is i'm i'm running against
myself in everything i do
and and that's and that's what i attack
i attacked myself
i'm always questioning myself you know i
worked out so hard
i didn't have time to stretch my i was
running 150 miles a week
i was back into work man i was getting
after it man i was working a full-time
job
and um stretching and doing that so my
body was literally getting tired and
tired not just from what i was doing
about things oh cause you ran this no it
wasn't that man
and um so i said no i'm gonna try and
stretch out
so i don't do anything for like 10
minutes or
you know i don't do those six minute abs
so i started stretching out one hour
hour and a half long story short man i
shaved my head almost every morning
and that bump that was on the back of my
head i started realizing it was
shrinking
for some reason i don't know why because
i shaved my hip back and i was like it's
getting smaller smaller that bump got
the healthier i got
smaller that bump got i was like oh hold
up what's going on
that's so as muscles started getting
more and more stretched out more relaxed
and over a period of five years i'm in
the best shape of my damn life right now
from stretching out wow that's all it
was i went from like
i can't even count the medications i was
on now i'm on a very
low dose thyroid pill period do you ever
do yoga
all the time man all the time and i i
if i were to tell somebody one thing
right now man that that soul has muscle
and getting that hip flexor opened up
because we're all stressed it was
it's so much worse than others it
changed my life i'm one of those
i i've drone on too much about yoga i'm
like one of those vegans it's like
you got to do it man just try it i get
annoying like a born-again christian or
something
it's like i'm getting that way now man
i'm getting that way now for anybody who
does anything
hard like you know if you do anything
like
with weightlifting type or martial arts
type
where it's just everything's explosion
it's lifting it's heavy it's push push
push right yoga just will balance your
[ __ ] out
yeah well yeah really well man and
there's all these people that resist it
like there was some article recently
that something along the lines of hot
yoga
is just trendy nonsense i read that and
then even in the article it talked about
that there might be some benefits in
terms of like the
strengthening your arteries and they
didn't even mention heat shock proteins
there's a study going on right now i
believe it's at harvard
right one of my friends was telling me
about it where they're um they're trying
to find the benefits of 90-minute hot
yoga classes
because they think it might mirror the
observed benefits of sauna
which they already know for a fact has
big benefits because of your body
producing heat shock proteins to deal
with the heat
right that's why i put that sauna in
here man i go in that all the time well
no one can tell me it doesn't work
it's big it's proof positive it changed
my life it wasn't a medication or this
or a dr
it was stretching yeah it was yoga
stretching all that stuff combined
changed it
when things hit you in life that you're
afraid of
or you're not good at the first thing
you're gonna say to yourself is
why am i here anyway this isn't for me
the water's too cold the sun's too hot
i'm getting up too early why am i doing
this to myself
that's what the normal mind says
i had to start training my mind to think
about
how the can i get through this
not giving myself a way out never giving
myself
creating a wall around all the [ __ ]
ways out in my mind
and just slowly started to build this
wall so my mind knew
this is not going to give himself a way
out of here
in my first tail week i had a huge
setback i was broken
my legs were broken i had double
pneumonia
i got rolled back to day one week one of
navy seal training
i got through that second hell week
during the second hell week
i actually broke my knee i continued to
limp around for a couple weeks
i couldn't make it anymore got rolled
back to day one week one
i'll never forget standing there in
front of captain bowen
he was the ceo in charge of navy seal
train at the time
and he had no mercy on anybody if he
believed in
managing your expectations i wouldn't be
here today he challenged me again
i was challenged my whole life not by
the mindset of managing expectations
by exceeding expectations not by
managing him
i'm standing there with crutches
i'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes dog is this your last time
we're gonna put you through navy seal
training this will be your third hell
week
in one year we're not gonna put you
through a fourth
so this is your last time i'm thinking
how am i gonna get through this
i'm i'm badly jacked up my legs are
broken
my knee is messed up and he goes you
have a couple of months to get better
a couple months isn't going to do it i
won't get healed up in a couple of
months
but i realized i'm going to get through
this i'm going to find a way to get
through it because why i put
barriers in my mind so my third hell
week
i went in there with pretty much i would
put a black sock
on first i would get duct tape
and i duct taped my ankles all the way
up to my calf
every single morning and then i put
another black sock over it
and what that did that prevented me from
moving
my ankle so i didn't really out
i wasn't flexing my shin as much and i
started running with just my hip
flexors in this hell week it was a bad
hell we had a guy die
on thursday morning of hell week i went
on to become a navy seal
greatness is not something that you meet
once
[Music]
it's something that you meet thousands
of times in your life and you don't
reach it
if you're not constantly in constant
pursuit
of greatness so if my mind were to say
right now
i'm great i just lost we're going to
grow
we're not going to triple down on our
strengths
we're not going to do that crap we're
going to work on our weaknesses so we
grow
we need friction to do that without
friction there's no growth without
friction there's confusion
confusion is david goggins how did you
become who you are today
i put a bunch of friction in my life
and i grew that's how i did it you know
you get really tough
it's a lifestyle instead of hitting that
news button in the morning and not
making your bed not cleaning your house
you don't hit this news button you get
up you don't want to go run
you go run you don't want to go swimming
you go swim you want to make your beds
you make your bed
you don't want to clean your house and
clean your house you don't want to study
and study that's how you start to
callous your mind so that became my life
if you say you're gonna wake up at four
o'clock in the morning to go run
wake up at four o'clock and it's gonna
suck
it's not gonna be fun do something that
sucks every single day of your life
that's how you grow embrace the suck
i never forget one time during a
basketball game there was this coach
mr trout he knew me when i was a kid
in that school when i was in third grade
getting set back mr trout always loved
me
this white man loved that i mean i don't
know why he did
but he was my jv basketball coach my
sophomore year
the visiting team was at our home
stadium
it was at the end of the game and the
visiting team started chanting i was the
only black person in the whole
dad gone stadium they started chanting
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all i remember at that time in my
life that's all i remember
but not 42 years old i can look back on
that time with clear eyes
in a clear mind and see what mr trout
did for me
he was in that locker room where i was
crying and upset and he cried with me
this white man cried with me about that
time i didn't see that
all i saw was red i saw hate this whole
town hated me
everybody's against me my mind lost it
and for some reason i couldn't sleep on
my bed until this day
i don't know why the floor felt so
comfortable and at
22 21 years old i went from 175 pounds
to 297 pounds fat
out of shape insecure i was everything
everybody said i was going to be that's
what i was
and it makes you feel like so i got josh
praying for cockroaches at night time
not saying it's a bad job but i didn't
want to do it
so for about six months i went around to
your local eateries spraying for
cockroaches
this one night i came home the first
thing i do i walk in my living room
turn the tv on first thing i do then
walk back
to the um to take a shower
and i was listening to the tv as i was
trying to take a shower
[Music]
this day changed my life it helped me
accountable for what i wasn't facing in
life
they're going through navy seal training
and i sat down
i came out of the shower and i sat down
something brought me back to sit down
and watch these guys go through hell i
saw a ton of them quitting
ringing the bell ringing the bell means
you quit navy seal training
i saw him putting their helmet down this
went on through the whole show
and it finally got to the very end
there's about 15 to 20 guys at the very
end
and this one statement changed my life
they were all sitting there and they're
dressed whites
and the ceo this command officer stands
up in front of these men
and he looked sharp and he i could tell
he stood for something
and he said we live in a world where
mediocrity
is often rewarded these men
up here detest mediocrity when you hear
a statement like that
it forces you to think about yourself i
wasn't even
mediocre i wasn't anything
i was at the bottom of the barrel of
life i chose
the four-lane highway for my life the
easy route
the route that has gas stations the
right that has
signs that say 20 miles to the next
service stop
all this [ __ ] i chose that right most of
us choose the four-lane highway
when i was born there was also a shovel
over here in
the corner that's the no one wants to go
to the shovel
they want to choose the four in lane
[ __ ] howard that's the that's the
nice route
the shovel means you're gonna hurt the
shovel means you're going to suffer
something means you're going to hit rock
a lot of time and we all know what
digging through rock is like
when you hit a route you got to get some
more tools out
if i had no more tools just a shovel i
was choosing a four-lane highway
this is when i decided to pick up that
[ __ ] shovel that we all decide not to
take
i had to make a change in my life so i
said you know what
i have to join the military i went on a
navy seal training
became the only person i believe in
history to go through three
navy seal hell weeks in one year steven
saljo was my recruiter
i walked in when 297 he looked at me
strangely and i said i want to be a seal
and lucky enough the guy looked at me
and said let's see what we can do
he weighed me i weighed 106 pounds
overweight the guy said man
there's a program that's about to end
that
you can go and if you make it through
buds you then go active duty
right and you'll be a seal if not you
come back home
right and i was like yeah so anyway
you're gonna make y'all lose 106 pounds
less than three months so i gotta make a
statement did you lose the weight in
three months
you just run your ass off i couldn't run
the first thing about it was so i said
to myself i'm gonna run four miles
my first run off the gate i'm gonna run
four miles
i ran a mile i went a quarter of a mile
walked home sat on the couch depressed
i said man there's no way i can do this
but what i realized though
is i wasn't going to give up because
i've already given up a million times
and i thought about how would i feel at
50 years old
if you gave i'm not if i gave up now not
to have you know
so i kept all this stuff in my mind and
um
basically i started becoming obsessed
i slowly it didn't happen that night on
the couch right
over a period of time i started becoming
obsessed with
studying with weight with being somebody
with making people who thought was gonna
be nothing
kind of like feel like i became obsessed
with
you have to make this right and the only
person could do is yourself
so i became obsessed with just being
obsessed
before i started race i actually
imagined myself
going through all my little checkpoints
i'm imagine all these different emotions
and things i'm going to go through
so when it happens it just flows
all this imagery is so important in life
if you can see yourself doing something
you can do it
if you can't see yourself doing it
usually you can't achieve it
every race i get into i hit a wall in a
race that's
so long you hit several walls and every
time you hit a wall
it's a big deciding factor in that race
or in your life if you're not running
and you have a decision to make you can
stop at that wall you can go parallel
left or pillow right
you're looking for that door and when
you get to the door you have another
decision to make
should i open it or should i keep it
closed if you keep it closed you made a
decision to quit
if you open that door you made a
decision to carry on and continue on
with your journey or your mission
wherever you're on
and i always open that door because
once you open the door and you go
through it your mind resets and it gets
you
a few more miles
i can't describe it to you how you feel
when you know you're going to complete
the hardest thing you're doing in your
life the second you realize not to give
up your body gets back in tune again and
you're ready to go
i have those mental blocks all through
the race but that's when i smile too
i signed up for that race to see what
kind of decision i'm going to make
and that's why i do it and usually it's
the decision to keep on going forward
i have to experience life and that's how
i experience life
with your learning disability with your
dad beating you
screaming at you emotionally challenging
your mind
with uh the racism you dealt with with
um
the different struggles you felt with
bullies what was the
hardest obstacle to overcome from
up until about 15 16. the hardest
obstacle was myself
i started realizing more and more and
more
that all these people were gone what was
haunting me
was me i can't control my dad
i can't control the people calling me
[ __ ] i can't control
all these things but they were things
that kept me down
it started to become my reality my
reality was
what they made it out to be and i became
old
the most important conversation you'll
ever have with your life you know in
your life is when you have yourself
and my conversation was absolutely
horrifying what were you saying to
yourself
i'm dumb i'm nobody my dad i mean my dad
was great
in mental warfare a drunk insecure man
will make everybody around him feel like
hell
yeah because he wants to give you no
power
and that's why he was so mean to my mom
and myself and my brother
because he didn't want anybody to get
above him
he want to keep you down low so when
you're growing up with all this stuff
all this hate it wasn't the beatings
i could hit the beatings all day it was
a mental torture
so when at a young age your your parents
put a dialogue in you of confidence
or you're nobody so that voice in my
head was i'm a loser
and then it was confirmed when i got in
school
and in third grade i was falling behind
they want to put me
in a special school yeah you know with
kids who can't learn
right then it was confirmed what you
know what my
dad was saying so that confirmed it then
i started cheating
so i started realizing you know what i'm
taking the easy way out again yeah and
it started snowballing from there now
now the kids are calling me [ __ ] but
it wasn't all the kids
so what happens is you start to get this
picture that
everybody hates you because your reality
becomes so
so big mm-hmm that you don't you i mean
you can't see the clear picture it might
have been three or four that's it
doing it over and over right but it was
the whole town yeah everybody hated me
so the world hates me that's right yeah
and that's when it
that's when it became toxic and that is
where
i became my worst enemy well everybody
it's groundhog's day again for david
goggins
if you pan it down here you see it's
about three o'clock in the morning
and there's not a car or a person in
sight if you pan over here
it's the same thing not a car or a
person in sight
people want to know where i find my
strength at where i get my strength i
get it from a lot of places but right
now this morning
i'm getting it from there's nothing
that's up
there's not a car there's not a person
everybody's in their bed sleep dreading
that it's a monday
hate this a monday and i'm loving it i'm
loving that while everybody's getting
weaker
i'm getting stronger it's not about the
running
the swimming to push up to sit-ups it's
about what those things do for your
mentality
you don't get better on the daggone
couch you get better by coming out here
and getting after every daggone day
i was obsessed with rocky rocky
one in particular and when i was a kid i
come every day
and i watch the [ __ ] show rocky and i
would fast forward
with the little vhs tapes to round 14.
round 14 me up like nobody's business
why this song came on right so when i
brought the pull-up record i listened to
the song for 17 hours it's 2 minutes and
13 seconds
and i'm able to visualize
and dream like nobody's business and i
know that
i can create a vision that many people
can't and
i work for it so the vision i had was
when apollo creed beat the
rocky beat it out of him he kept
fighting
he was a dumb fighter couldn't read
couldn't [ __ ] that was me
couldn't read couldn't write just punchy
everything about him and rocky beat this
or probably
he was in that corner everybody was
saying stay the down
and him getting up him getting up
apollo creed raised his arms up and
turned around thought he won the fight
he turns around and sees this guy
getting up and it was the face of apollo
creed
that changed my life the face of apollo
creed it was like
just by that getting up not winning
just by him getting the up apollo crew
was
his champ he's the best rocky had taken
his soul
had literally taken his soul his head
goes down he looks at him like who
what the [ __ ] are you i wanted to be
that
not rocky i want to be the guy that
people looked at i don't care if you
like me or didn't like
i don't care but it said this is going
to keep coming
after whatever the is in front of them
i wanted that i wanted that i wanted
that
worse than anything in the world so
that is i kept picturing me
falling down and getting up and every
that called me [ __ ]
i was dumb even myself even myself
i wanted to feel something besides
defeat
i wanted to just go to distance and that
going a distance pushed me to a point of
where now i'll go way past the distance
what was the greatest lesson your mom
taught you
growing up honestly the greatest lesson
she ever taught me is a lesson that she
she doesn't know how much she taught me
because
she wasn't much in the teaching mode my
dad took her soul
but what i did as a young kid is i
observed
everybody i wasn't really smart in the
books yeah
but i was real smart when it came to
life yeah and i was able to sit back and
watch her mistakes i was able to see
how she struggled through life and how i
don't want to struggle through life
and i was able to see she never picked
me up the biggest thing she did for me
and this is honest to god truth and she
doesn't even know she did it
but i would bust my ass but i would fail
yeah
when i was at the bottom of the sewer
she never picked me up
she never gave me that cookie and said
hey son you know it's gonna be okay
never she didn't have time for that and
sometimes she gets upset when i talk
about my past because it pains her out
to be
not the best mom if i had any kind of
mom in that kind of environment i would
have never made it
because she forced me for every reason
she forced me to you better figure this
out
or you're going to be a statistic wow
and this is something that she didn't
sit down to tell me
i realize this this is the world that is
in front of me
and what most people do is they see this
world
and they look at it as an excuse to get
out of it yeah
i started looking at it as
this is the ultimate training ground for
the rest of my life
i have all these valuable lessons
because if you look at the world right
now today
it's not a nice place but i'm very
prepared for it
yeah you are i'm prepared for it i'm
prepared for all the failure coming my
way
i'm prepared for everything my way and
that's the biggest lesson that she
taught me by not teaching me
by never saying it's gonna be okay
matter of fact you're telling me the
exact opposite life sucks
but when i started getting these emails
from people saying hey you know what
you changed my life that part changed my
life that part of your story changed my
life
and because i have so many different
parts of my life that
so many people resonate with different
spots
maybe it's the obese part maybe it's the
bullying part maybe it's the learning
disability part
maybe it's the abusive parent part
whatever it may be
so many people draw from my story and i
started getting these emails and i was
like
god man you know and i'm a big believer
in something more powerful than me
i don't know what it is but i'm not the
end-all
so i was like uh i gotta start doing
more
if i'm touching these people's lives a
few people here
right maybe i need to go out here and do
some more
god put me in a very interesting spot in
life
where he made hell my teacher
he made hell my teacher and a lot of
people
don't understand that so i'm trying to
give people a different thought process
of life
where failure hell disappointment
discomfort is a great learning tool
and many people don't understand that
and a lot of people won't even
understand this interview when we get
done with it
but it's these few moments in life that
you have
like for me i always talk about it rocky
1 round 14.
that one two minute and 13 second
clip of
rocky getting up when apollo knocked him
down
that one clip when i was going to a very
bad time in my life
i saw what i wanted to be
and it wasn't a guy that won the one the
guy that won everything he did
it was a guy that kept getting up after
being knocked down
so i realized if that two minutes and 13
seconds changed my life
so i was i saw something that i needed
to be
in the world i was living in maybe
my story will give someone the two
minutes and 13 seconds they need
to change their life means that people
live in a very comfortable place that's
fine
don't listen to me a lot of people are
looking for that two minutes and 13
seconds
and i might be that person and i believe
that we're all
we're all teachers we're all teachers
and if you don't learn something and
give
back like what you learned
yeah what's the point of living you're
wasting yeah you're wasting it you have
all this knowledge of what you learn
some people may think you're crazy some
people may you know may put a title on
you
but it's it's it is you know it's those
few people who are like you know what i
need to hear that
and i i often talk about taking souls
this morning this person i usually train
alone
this person wanted to run with me i said
fine we'll run
15. this morning comes
there's storms coming in this way and
the person calls and said hey
why don't we do it tomorrow taking souls
is when i told him [ __ ]
i'm going to run 15 today and i'll run
with you again tomorrow
that's what taking souls is about
don't worry about the elements and
what's going on
you gotta get out there and get it and
that's taking souls and obviously
he wasn't the only one that felt about
taking the day off
because the storm is coming in right now
and there's not a soul out here but me
everybody's journey is different i was
on a journey to see
who david goggins was and that journey
took me
in some of the hardest areas a human
being can even imagine
and right now at 41 i'm the happiest
person on the planet because
you know i had to climb mount everest
several times just to look down
on my life to see where hell i came from
and that's what kept me going through
all this stuff like i
i envisioned myself going through like
when i was a young kid and they called
me [ __ ] all the time i got
my dad beat the hell out of me and i was
had no self-esteem
i had this vision of if
i can make it to where i want to go
imagine when i look back on my damn life
how proud i will be and now i'm here
i'm able to look back on this life i
lived that many people will never
understand because why when you're
passionate
they think you're crazy and you can't
even explain to people
why you're doing or why you did what you
did because you found your purpose and
once you find your purpose
you can't really explain it to normal
people because they don't understand
passion because
they live every day life that's going
not really finding their purpose so
i become a foreign language to people i
think so they put me in the category if
you're just crazy
no no no no no i'm passionate i found my
purpose in this life
well there's something i invented a long
time ago
and when you have nothing to draw from
i was able to find strength in every
molecule of this earth
i'm able to be in a room with nothing
with no motivation no inspiration
nothing and find
it so what i did in those situations was
i invented this thing called taking
souls
when everybody's off and you're
exhausted and you're weak and you're
tired and you're looking around
and everybody looks as bad as you or
even worse
i'm like you know what i want to now
make a statement
it's the perfect time to make a
statement to make a statement to let you
know
where your life ends and mine begins
and so the statement there is i muster
up every bit of strength from their
looks on their faces and how they feel
and how i'm gonna now from my childhood
where i came from how's the bottom of
the barrel i'm now amongst all these
uncommon people i'm now going to now
make you feel
like you're common so i use their
their sadness their weakness their
parts of their life for god this sucks
i'm like all poopy pants they messed up
i use that for my strength and i have
this moment
of like let's say we're in the sand
we're
running or whatever i will do a surge i
would do something everybody's like how
the
is he doing this and from that
that look on their face that feeling of
god man this guy must be something
something special it then surges me
further and further and faster
and harder for a long time so
it's energy is everywhere but the thing
is it's so loud
that that that voice in your head of
pain and suffering and
discomfort and i want to do this is so
loud that you're unable to really calm
it down it's
okay there's something here it's a
patient
calm that you have to bring yourself to
say i know i have something here
but that voice is so powerful that i
just want you just to let's leave
right we're done we're done it spazzes
you out and you want to go
versus saying let's take a second hang
on before we spaz
hang on and in that moment you can think
clearly
and find that strength out there for you
we believe like
so many people before i give them a
workout plan they're talking about
recovery everybody
everybody that hears me speak they want
to go straight to recovery
work out first work out first before you
talk to me about recovery how to recover
yeah
work out first we are always looking for
like whenever i talk to people people
take my words
and they and they and they put it in a
way to where
they want to feel comfortable this guy
you know they
they they want to put you in a box they
want to put a title on you
no you're putting a title on me to make
yourself feel better about yourself
if you read this book of mine and you
see where i came from this person was
this person was not built this
this person was not made by god this
person
sorry this person was built i made this
person
i made this person by diving into the
insecurities that life gave me
because now they're yours they're yours
to own if you're not smart
call yourself dumb it's okay because you
are
but take that knowledge you put yourself
down if your fat card yourself fat i
used to be 300 pounds
we we want to talk so soft to ourselves
we're looking for that recovery day
and that recovery day is everything in
your life
everything in your life is a recovery
day we're looking for it it's not coming
it's not coming get over that recovery
day
and that's the mentality i took with me
and what happened through that process
was all the frivolous things of life
started to float away
i had to tell people lies so they would
like me
because i was so insecure when you start
to build yourself up
and start to have the one thing that we
don't have is confidence yeah
real authentic confidence from hard work
everything else goes away you no longer
look to other people
for yourself validation you now know
i walk in the room now and i know that
hours and years and decades
i put into david goggins that's some
it's not on the wall it's not a trophy
on the wall it's not a male around your
neck
it is actually a feeling in your heart
and people why don't you ever smile
i don't have to yeah i do have a story
look at my face
i'm a very focused person but the thing
i have in my
soul and my heart that's why i need to
smile
i don't need to smile i don't need you
to look at me and say oh my god you look
happy
because help us aren't happy we're
giving you something that we think you
want to see
i don't do that anymore i don't care how
you perceive david goggins
because through my journey i figured out
the one piece i was missing
i thought it was cars i thought it was
women i thought it was
i thought it was mud i thought was
everything the one piece i was missing
was me
having the courage to face myself i
wanted that comfort zone that everybody
looks for
that pat on the back they don't want to
hear all the bad they want everything
that they're doing right and i realized
that's what kept me
in this world that's what kept me in
this world of not accomplishing
anything so what i did was
i became that big bad nasty that you
don't want to walk into at night time
i became the roughest critic in the
world on myself
and that's what changed me i literally
saw myself in the mirror
i saw the truth versus saying you know
my dad did this to me from you know from
beating me kids in school from call me
[ __ ] did this to me
my life did this to me my broken
foundation this to me
i took that and said you know what well
some people may help this happen
but now i have to own this no one's
going to come back to save me
no one's going to come back on the couch
and say hey
it's okay you're going to be okay no i'm
not
i'm not going to be okay i had to
realize i had to take a stand i
had to make a real stand and it was
painful
to look at who i like who i was what
the world and myself created it created
a
a a very lonely depressed insecure man
that would do anything just to have a
friend
and i saw that as very pathetic when you
look at the truth
it becomes very ugly and pathetic my
first time going through buds
i got to hell week um stress fractures
double pneumonia i got rolled back day
one week one
second time going through buds i
actually
um fractured my patella before i got
into hell week
made it through hell week with a
fractured patella went two weeks after
hell week
and then because why i didn't want to
get rolled back to day one week one
yeah but i couldn't keep up with the
class got rolled back to day one week
one
after hell week and then i went through
my third time
and i graduated that class we had a guy
die in that third hell week
class 235 so that's kind of how it
happened
i had to have some so i'm really good at
creating an enemy
i'm really good at at creating something
that i'm against
and i'm also good at if you ever tell me
something that i cannot do i'm gonna let
you know that i'm doing it
somehow somehow you're gonna know one
way or another
that i'm doing it it may not be like in
your face
it may i may make sure that i run across
the daggone world
so then it's on the news and you turn
the news on say how the hell
did he do that i want to do something
that you know i'm here
i'm here this isn't for anyone looking
for a break
there is no finish line so stop looking
for one
don't believe if you work your [ __ ]
that one day
you'll hit that finish line there's only
one finish line
that is death you must find our limits
in everything we do
and push slightly beyond it remember
this
just because you worked your ass off it
doesn't mean
you will achieve what you've been
working for
very few of the mindset to work through
[ __ ] with no guaranteed success
never expect have immediate results
mindset we want to stay in the suck
longer than anyone else true victory
comes
when there are no crowds and no finish
lines
the real victory is your willingness to
work your ass off
while no one is watching stay hard what
i started figuring out
going through buzz was that the harder
something is
the more it was challenging my mind so i
had to find different ways to stay in
the fight
in the state of the fight it got me
tougher and tougher and tougher so i'm
actually happy i went through three hell
weeks
i never examined myself and as a human
being you gotta examine yourself and uh
like and i guess the best place to
examine yourself as
navy seal hell week three times so i got
to examine myself a few times
so it started there it started in hell
week
and it's still going now at 43 years old
some of you just don't
get it i'm not here trying to prove
myself
how tough i am i'm trying to make you
think
i'm trying to give you tools on how to
find more of yourself
so why am i in the water right now
at three o'clock in the morning
well when i was going through training i
used to hate night swims
they bothered me when i retired
i said i'll never get back in the water
again at nighttime
so guess what i'm doing right now
going for a swim at nighttime think
about being better
you know people didn't think i was human
they thought i came from outer space man
from some spacecraft and
landed down here and just formed goggins
from the rocks and the soul of the earth
no that's not how it is man so i said
i'm gonna
i'm gonna share a secret with you all
when i talk to people
like i see where i'm at today but i know
where i come from
and it's kind of hard to almost separate
that i'm almost
not in a way i'm kissing my own ass but
i'm amazed at what a human being can
actually do so when i start talking to
myself in the third person
it's strictly because i know that i
literally made
this human being out of uh out of just
like
a whole bunch of scraps mm-hmm and i
wasn't
you know i wasn't a a mechanic i wasn't
a carpenter so i didn't know how to do
anything
you know i wasn't trained in how to
build a human being from nothing you
know like
my mom didn't train me my dad didn't
train me life didn't train me well
life yeah life did train me correction
and i started putting this scrap metal
together like i wonder what's going to
happen you know
the first year i try to do is off and
after a while i start
learning more and more and more through
pain and suffering i started learning
just learning so much
about stuff before i knew it man i built
this beautiful car and i'm like how the
[ __ ] did i do that
and i knew how to and i i know how to do
it because i have all the tools
through all the failure i went through
trying to build this person who's
goggins i believe that most human beings
are only living at
about 40 percent of their capability
so the mine has a governor like a car
if you're driving a car and the car has
a governor on it
the car may say 130 miles an hour but
the governor set for 91.
once that governor sets in you get to 91
that car starts doing this
the car wants to go the car wants to go
but that
factory said uh-uh we're not going past
91
we have a factory a nice governor in our
brain
and it's a survival mechanism it
protects us from pain and suffering
the second we feel that our mind says oh
no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable
and there's something about the mind the
mind has the tactical advantage over you
at all times at all times of your life
the mind has a tactical advantage over
you why is that
it knows what you're afraid of it knows
your insecurities it knows your deep
dark lies
and it starts to push you away from that
it pushes you in a direction that is
comfortable
the mind controls everything so what i
realized was that when i was growing up
and i was 300 pounds and i got all fat
and i got all insecure
i realized that my mind kept taking me
in this direction when things got
uncomfortable for me when i was facing
my insecurities i was facing my fears
my mind said oh no we have the tactical
advantage we need to
get you separate you from this feeling
this feeling over your life's all about
feelings
we want the happy feeling we don't want
that feeling of this sucks
why am i here and you don't have any so
you can't answer those questions so you
leave
i started realizing that if in that
moment
you can answer those questions and you
are now
in charge of your brain versus your
brain ruling you
that's where all that stuff comes from
so so the 40
rule is all of that you get to 40 your
brain says
we're done let's roll man this is
starting to get painful this is
uncomfortable
so you sit down you have to figure out
ways and everybody's different that's
how the book kind of talks about
like we all have these things about you
know five steps to this and four steps
to this
it's a lot more than that that's all
it's
it's a practice that you have to it's a
habit so
if you know that at 40 i'm still you
know i'm feeling pain
at 40 i'm feeling pain that's where the
40 rule kicks in
now it starts okay i'm feeling pain my
mind's saying all
to me is saying get out of here run flee
the fight or flight kicks in okay we're
done we're not good enough
it starts telling you all these things
you start to believe it because the mind
controls all
this is the time where you have to gain
control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if i can go 45
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and it goes from 40
to a lot further than that but that's
the start of it though get to
get to the spot where your mind is
saying stop
wherever that is you gotta get there
first and then that's when that
starts to work for you you gotta control
yourself in that moment
so i prioritize trying to win the battle
in the morning
so i always win the battle in the
morning so i get morning time every
morning i go for a run
that's the first thing i do every
morning i haven't taken a day off of
running since
december 2016. i've
every day up in the morning so i also
stretch out
every day for about two to three hours
every day i miss two days in about
five and a half six years so
that's just my routine and about four
days a week i'm in the gym hitting the
weights
because you know you can't just be a
runner so this is every single
day the the monotony in my life
but this is what builds discipline you
know and not everybody i'm not
telling everybody to do this but this is
my lifestyle this
is how i build self-discipline you made
this decision to self-publish this book
yes sir right now it's at like number
two or number three
on amazon on of all books
right right that just doesn't happen
with a self-published book well that's
been the story of my life
i uh i see something that's that's quite
off
quite not the same and that's what i go
for
i've this this book is exactly who i am
as a person
exactly the way i did this book is how
i've done my almost my entire life
is i see what is not the norm
what's impossible with we know what all
the theorists say you shouldn't be doing
this
that's the wrong way to go and i'm like
hmm
let me see if i can pull this off it's
my junior year in high school
and i fell back a lot i fell back in
this
whole of life the second you think that
you've overcome it you climbed everest
you're on that last hold and life will
say
not to it'll push you down
and my junior year in high school i uh
missed a whole bunch of school was lying
to my mom had like a
one point something gpa i was just
jacked up i mean it was it's
i was in one one of the worst spots of
my life
and my mom was going with a lot of too
and she didn't have time to
sit back and baby me and it was me
against me
my pants were down to my knees i was
just i was
not whatever was going on i wasn't in
bad shape so i went to the bathroom and
i had this weird haircut because i
wanted attention
i was an attention getter i went to all
white school pretty much
um some of the kids like me a lot of
them didn't like me whatever didn't
matter i was looking for something so i
was dressed differently
crazy haircuts and i went to the mirror
and
the reflection in it revealed a lot of
bad things
a lot of things that i was hiding behind
the saggy pants
and i'm looking at myself in the mirror
going like god dawg dude you gotta
you are something else man like you have
created a character
i want to be the cool guy table and
whatever i could do to to get attention
i did
it wasn't me it wasn't who i was inside
but i was scared for anybody to know
who i was inside so in that
accountability mirror i call it
i got real of myself i said
you have a third grade reading level
which is hard to admit when you're a
junior in high school that you
copied on every single thing you did
because a fear they're gonna put me in a
special school
we all know what special means i'm gonna
have a title on myself the rest of my
life
and being cool you don't have a title on
yourself so i started cheating
i was dumb and people say oh you know
you're learning disability
i don't learning disability but i
realized i was lazy
so um i called myself out there
i called myself out every which way
possible i didn't call myself i was just
honest
i was honest look at yourself man
look at yourself and it was that day
in a couple of days after that i just
got real with myself and every day i
came home
i called the accountability mirror what
am i going to do today
to change what i see in this mirror
what am i gonna do today and a lot of it
was i stopped sitting with the cool guys
i actually took my shirt and went to
school looking like hey man this is how
i'm gonna look
if you don't like it so be it i had to
really wear this
this this layer of skin
i had to develop a really callous skin
on me to take
whatever you're going to call me you're
going to call me whatever i'm going to
be you know i want a geek
but whoever i am you're going to see me
you're going to see me for who i am
because i need to change who i'm not and
that accounting billionaire
just became raw and i became fat over
the years i fell back in the hole
i called myself fat because i was fat
and people don't want to do that
they want to say oh don't call yourself
fat don't call yourself dumb
if you're not real and raw with who the
[ __ ] you are
nothing's gonna change in this nice new
world that we live in
we want to hear you're just a little big
no man
you might be fat and it's okay to hear
that from yourself and from arabella so
that's where it started at
and it's raw it gets ugly sometimes with
me in that mirror
but i'm also proud of myself to be able
to tell myself that and then fix what's
in that mirror
well i was praying for cockroaches when
i got to the air force
i sprang for cockroaches i was about 297
to be exact
and i saw this discovery channel show on
tv
and i was like and that discovery
challenge show was these guys
going through hell week and i saw these
guys
freezing a lot of water and i was like
you know what it brought back memories
of me going through pear rescue training
so at 297 pounds i decided to uh
try to be a navy seal and to make a long
story short i had to lose
106 pounds in less than three months
and that's where it became challenging
for me
so i knew to lose 106 pounds in less
than three months
you're looking at 3 500 calories is a
pound
so i was basically doing a whole bunch
of math in my head
so i knew if i were to stop and be
stagnant there was no calories being
burned
so i i was basically trained all day
long
so that's how i went and before i knew
it
i lost the weight well it's that time of
year again we start to feel real happy
why because we're
we're not going to work if you believe
in santa claus and
you celebrate christmas you're looking
forward to santa claus coming down the
chimney giving you some presents
it's a real good time of year so in a
good time of year we start to feel real
good about ourselves
so i start to feel great so we start
making promises to ourselves about hey
i'm going to lose some weight i'm going
to do better in school
i'm going to be better here be better
there but guess what happens
the real merry christmas happens when
all of that noise is gone it's
quiet and it's you against you and now
all those endorphins are gone
and i promise you made by getting up
early and getting after it to go lose
weight study harder
guess what it's a lot harder now that
repetition becomes a lot harder now
so a lot of us can't do things on our
own so find somebody in your life so
when you throw that towel in
they throw that back at you and say
you're not [ __ ] done yet
stay true to yourself stay hard now i've
got a really special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time and what
place you're going to take action you
have a 91 chance of
actually following through versus just a
35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan and when
you share your plan publicly and have
some
accountability you increase your chances
even further of
actually following through so i want to
know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
how do i gain more confidence it starts
with yourself man
you got to start diving into those
things that you are afraid of
you don't gain confidence by going to
the spot that makes you feel good
it's to be a false reality in the second
life gives you that challenge
all you want to do is go back to what
makes you confidence
or or or what gave you confidence is
that happy spot
no what gives you confidence what gave
me confidence
was spending years at a kitchen table
trying to learn how to read and write on
my own
realizing i can't learn the way you
learn i can't
but i can learn what gives you
confidence not being
afraid it's overcoming the fear
isis stutters severely bad so right now
i don't know how many people are going
to watch this
you know what gives me confidence is no
i no longer care
if i sit or start stuttering to you yeah
that's what gives me confidence is
facing these things overcoming them
and maybe not overcoming them every day
but facing them
and facing their face and preaching like
this you know what man this is where
it's at
it's not in that comfort zone it's in
the discomfort zone
is where my confidence is getting built
that's where it's getting built
but people want to and they want an
easier answer
yeah there has to be an easier way
there's not
i'm sorry i searched for it my entire
life
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
some awesome motivation from mel robbins
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there